in this mstat course nickel will guide
you step by step in building a
state-of-the-art AI chatbot similar to
chat GPT through this Hands-On tutorial
you'll Master the depths of the M Stack
Implement Advanced authentication
mechanisms and seamlessly integrate open
ai's capabilities into your full stack
application by the course's end you'll
have a production ready scalable and
secure SAS chatbot PL platform
underpinned by the latest in web
development best
practices hi everyone my name is Nel and
welcome to a usest project on a channel
so in this tutorial you will Master the
monack and you will build a fully
secured AI software as a service project
with a mon stack so this is an AI
chatbot built with the open a and the
mon stack so users can ask their queries
and their doubts to the chatbot and
chatbot will come up with an answer so
this is similar to theat chat GPD as
well so this application includes a
fully responsive web page with a modern
design so it is completely responsive on
any screen size you can check the
responsiveness as well and this
application starts from the home screen
so anyone can log in and register and
they can start their conversations with
the chat B so they just need to click on
the login they can provide the
credentials over there they can click on
the login and after that the user would
be logged in and we would be restoring
all of the chats of the user with the
chatbot and the conversations would be
stored in the database so anyone can
access their chats any time so you can
see this is a UI for the chatbot and
this is similar to the chat GPT like
thing you can see if you ask any
question like show me how can I declare
variables in JavaScript so this chatbot
will come up with an answer and it will
also show you the code blocks as well so
if you need any code blocks so it is
capable of showing all of the code
blocks to the
user and the users have the
functionality so they can clear the
conversation with the chat Bo as well so
they just need to click on the clear
conversation and all of the chats of the
user would be deleted and the user
session will be active till the 7 days
so we'll be storing the cookies inside
the browser we'll be storing the HTTP
only cookies and we'll be storing the
tokens inside that and they can't be
accessed by the JavaScript so they
cannot be accessed by the JavaScript so
they can only be accessed via the back
end so users do not need to log in
within the 7 Days of logging in so after
only 7 days they are required to login
again to generate a new
token and we'll be using the openi
conversational model GP 3.5 turbo and4
and on every chat message the user needs
to verify their session and the
authorization details as per the
security because the security is on top
priority so that's the demo of this
application that we have created and
this is our homepage the user can move
on to the register page as well so sign
up will look similar to the login so
this is all for the demo and now let's
understand the text TX that we'll be
[Music]
using so we will be using the nodejs
express for the back end for creating
the rest API and we'll be using the
mongodb database for storing the data
efficiently and on the front end side
we'll be using the V for fast Dynamic
and reliable application and for the
authentication and authorization we'll
be using the password encryption using
the BP we'll be using the jwd Json web
tokens and their authorization we'll be
using the HTTP only cookies which can
only be accessed by the server and we'll
be using the validations as well we'll
be using multiple middleware checks for
the security and much more and for the
design and the UI for this application
we'll be using the material UI Library
which is the best UI component Library
out there for react and we'll be using
the context API for the re react for
providing the authentication as
authentication provider as a rapper for
whole application and with integrating
all these Technologies we can build a
modern fully secured and a full stack AI
chatbot similar to the chat gity service
with mon
stack and with the openi integration
we'll be using the openi for chat
completions with the nodejs and we will
take care of the security measures for
this application and will take care of
the API keys that are being kept as a
environment variable and all of these
things working with the open Ai and we
will explain each and everything that
how you can integrate the openai with a
M Stack application and in terms of the
scalability this application is
completely scalable to anything so in
future if you want to integrate the
image completion audio completion video
generation as well so this application
will work completely fine with all of
these things so react and the nodejs is
completely scalable and and our back end
is completely scalable for that and if
you want me to scale that application to
create the image completion audio
generation and video then please comment
down within the video and I will help
you out so I think that's enough for the
short introduction and let's get our
hands dirty into testing this
application and seeing the demo once
again and then we will move on into the
project so let's move on to the project
once again so you can see this is our
homepage we are using the animations
over there we have some animations we
are just giving some designs over there
and we have built with love by Indian
coders so this is my channel this is my
YouTube channel and there you can see
the login screen is there the signup
screen is there so the user will be
logged in and they can ask any question
like we can send hi over there to the
chat bot and the chatbot will come up
with an answer like hello how can I
assist you today and if the user
refreshes the page so the user session
will be active till 7 days so user does
not need to log in again you can see now
we have a message of loading chats so on
every refresh all of the chats of the
user would be restored and the users
have the functionality of clearing the
conversation as well so with the help of
this they can clear the conversations
and it's completely responsive so you
can open it in any
device like this you can see you can
open it in any device you can see it
will work perfectly fine over there and
then the user can move on it is
completely secure and it is completely
responsive over there they can click on
the login as well so you can see as for
the design it is completely responsive
and it is completely secure and you can
check the cookies as well for the user
so once the user locks in so the cookies
would be stored there you can see now we
have the authentication token so these
cookies are HTTP only cookies so they
cannot be accessed by the JavaScript so
this is a complete demo for this
application and now we will be moving on
into the
project so have a cup of tea or a coffee
and let's start building this project
and yeah I know now you want to build
this project but before that I want to
introduce you to my YouTube channel so
if you are new here this is my YouTube
channel and I create the videos on the
web development so I request you to
please like this video and please
subscribe to the channel as well because
it keeps me motivated to create the
videos like this and it helps me now
that's enough for the introduction and
now let's move on into the
project hi everyone and I welcome you
all to the course so in this section now
we'll have a deep introduction that what
exactly are we going to do and what
technologies that we'll be using
and we'll be having the technical
overview of the concepts as well so
let's start so what exactly are we going
to do so we are going to build our own
AI chatbot with the help of open AI so
it's a AI chatbot so that's why we are
using the open aai and we all know about
the openai platform so almost all of the
modern AI applications are built and
hosted on the open AI so we are also
going to create around chatbot it is
similar to the chat GPD so we are going
to create that with the open Ai and it
is a full stack application so each and
every record would be stored inside the
database and it can have the correct
operations of the database as well so we
are going to create a chat gbt type
application with the open Ai and now
let's just move on let's just understand
the technical overview of the course
that what technologies we'll be using
that why should we use the Technologies
if we have other Stacks as well so let's
just understand about these so now let's
move on and let's just understand that
what exactly is the month stack so mon
stack is a comprehensive and Powerful
web development framework that combines
four key Technologies the mongodb
express react and the node so it's not
exactly the framework but it's a
collection of JavaScript technologies
that work together to make a full stack
web development environment so mongodb
serves as the database system allows the
user for the efficient data storage and
retrieval Express is a backend web
application framework that manages the
routing the server aspects the metal WS
throughout the nodejs application we
have a react which is a front end
library that enables the creation of
dynamic and interactive user interfaces
and we have the nodejs which is used on
the server site to execute the
JavaScript and to handle the request and
manage the applications backend
operations so it all includes the
mongodb express react and the node and
it creates the full stack web
development environment and the
integration of these Technologies
enables the developers to construct
modern full stack applications
effectively and efficiently with using
the one single code base which is the
JavaScript so all of these Technologies
uses the JavaScript as their internal
code base so we'll be using JavaScript
only to create a full stack application
with using the mon stack so now let's
just understand that why should we use
the mon stack so we have other
Frameworks as well that can be the nexts
T3 stack it is currently in the demand
as well like the mon stack we have the
lamp stack as well with using the PHP
and we have golang as well so why should
we use the mon stack so let's just
understand that why should we use this
so first option that we have is the full
stack compatibility so mon stack offers
you the full stack compatibility so it
covers both front-end and backend
development using the JavaScript and
this leads to a consistent code base and
it makes it easier to collaborate and
switch between different parts of the
application whether that's a front end
or whether it's a back end and now let's
move on so we have the modern web
application development so it's a
completely modern development with using
the react which allows the creation of
dynamic and responsive user interfaces
while the Express and the node handles
the backend operations and it's a high
performance backend services with using
the node and the express and currently
mongodb is the most used database for
now so it's a modern fullstack web
development and we have the scalability
as well so nodejs which is used in the
monack is known for the scalability it
can handle a large number of
simultaneous connections efficiently
with using the event Loop and and it
makes it suitable for applications with
growing user bases and same with the
react so you can create any type of
application with the react and now let's
move on so we have the realtime
applications as well so Monch offers you
the realtime applications as well with
using the sockets with using some chat
applications and all so we have a
completely real-time application so we
are not going to use the socket inside
this application but I'm just explaining
you the examples that why should we use
the monack and now let's see we have the
crossplatform so monack can be used to
develop web applications that works
across different platforms and devices
so you can also use the monack with the
mobile devices as well what you can do
so instead of the react you can use the
react native for building the UI part
and now we have the open source so this
is the last feature that should be use
the mon stack so all components of the M
are open-source Technologies so you do
not need to pay anything because the
mongod DB is like a premium purpose so
if you want to use the mongod DB then
there's a very nominal charge but but
only in the production and during the
development you do not need to pay
anything to the mongod DV and you have
the react which is open source the node
and the express they open source
applications and you have the access to
their source code as well so these are
the options that help us to understand
that why should we choose the mon stack
over other different
Frameworks and now let's move on and
let's just again have a very deep
introduction about this course so what
we are going to do so we'll be having a
modern a project which will use the open
a API so we are going to use the openai
API to create an AI and realtime chatbot
and it is similar to the chat GPD so the
application is a full stack application
which stores the users chats in a
database to keep track of the
conversations but a user can delete them
any time so we have a CED functionality
of the users as well in which we'll be
having the users we'll be having the
chats of the users and user can delete
their chats as well anytime and the UI
is capable of showing the the code
blocks as well if requested by the user
so as you saw in the demo so we can also
show the code blocks to the user as well
with this project so it's a modern AI
project and we'll be using the advanced
authentication and authorization system
with the realtime chatbot so we'll be
using the JWT tokens the HTTP only
cookies and these cookies would be
stored inside the users browser but they
won't be able to access that and they
need to send those cookies once they
request for a new chat so it's a
completely secure and modern application
with the modern a platforms so now let's
move on and let's just see that how we
can start building this project and now
we can start building the back end of
this project so now let's move on so
first step that we have is to set up the
note express application with the types
script so this is our first step for
building this application so now let's
move on to the coding part so for quick
start for this course so I'm going to
provide you the link inside the
description so it's a GitHub link so you
can directly move on to the GitHub link
and then what you can do so you can
download this source code and then you
can paste that into your folder so you
can move on you can just copy all these
files and then you can paste them into
the visual studio code so I have opened
the folder in the vs code which is a m
opening I chatbot so let's create
another folder that can be the quick
start for the back end then we can paste
all of these files
here so now I have these files over
there and let's start building this
project so this is a overview so now
after just pasting all of these files
now you can move on you can press contrl
and J on your system if you're on the
Windows you can press control and J so
you need to just open the terminal so
you can move on to the back end folder
over there and then you can press the
command of the npm install so it will
install all of the dependencies that are
required so let's start moving on so
here we have the source file and inside
that we have the index.ts so here inside
that you can see we have a lock
statement like this is a starter kit for
this amazing project with love binding
encoders then we have the envirment file
as as well and inside there we have a
couple of Secrets couple of the we have
the database URLs as well we have the
cookie secret JWT Secrets then we have
the package.json as well and inside the
package.json it contains the information
about our back end you can see the name
of the application we have the back end
over there we have the main we have the
index.ts it is there inside the source
with the type of the module then we have
the scripts as well so we have the dev
command and we are going to use the
concurrently package so it's a open
source npm package that we can use so it
allows you to run multiple commands
inside the scripts inside the terminal
so first we are going to compile the
typescript to the JavaScript in the
watch mode then we are going to run the
compiled version of the JavaScript then
we have the build command as well so it
is currently same so after the build I
think that could be the Run command so
it's a run command or it can be the
start command over there and for the
build command I think we can move on we
can have a new command that could be for
the build so we have the build command
over there and inside the build command
now what do we need to do so build
command will be just having the TSC
which will compile the Javas which will
compile the typescript to the JavaScript
so here we have the build command over
there and that's how it's going to work
and after that you can see now we have
the start command which will start the
production ready application which will
start the compiled version with the note
index.js then we have the test command
as well and this is not required so what
we can do so we can remove the test
command over there and after that you
can see there are a couple of
dependencies that we'll be using the
first one is the BP which is used for
the password encryption and comparing
the decrypted password then we have the
concurrently package which is used to
run multiple commands concurrently with
have the cookie passer which is used to
set cookies directly from the back end
to the front end we'll be using the
course package which enables the cross
origin resource sharing which means like
you can make a request to a different
server and there won't be an issue we'll
be whitelisting that thing over there we
have the EnV to use the EnV files over
there we have the express application
over there we'll be using the Express
package we have the validator for the
express so it means now we'll be having
the data validation checks as well
before moving on to the database we have
the Json web token for the JWT tokens we
have the mongos which uh which is a
package which is used to work with the
mongod DB we have the open AI Library so
we have the open a library to work with
the open a systems and now let's move on
let's have the configuration file of the
typescript so here we have the
configuration file and here we have the
error we can just move on we can have
the es I think we can have the node next
to over there like this so I think we
can move on we can have the next so the
error would be gone and now you can see
inside this we include all of the files
for the typescript which are into the
source folder so inside source inside
any of the subfolders so if you find an
ATS file so it would be compiled inside
the build directory and this is the
build directly which is the disc and
this is a build directory which is a
disc so you can move on you can create a
new folder that could be for the disc
and inside this file the new compile
file would be created so that's how it's
going to work and after that what you
can do so you can just run the npm Run
Dev so first time you should get an
error your compiler would not find the
dis index.js file but after you compile
then it would create the index.js file
then you can again move on you can clear
the screen then you can again press npm
run Dev now you will see the lock
statement over there which is this is a
starter kit for this amazing project
with law ban coders so with the help of
this now we have created the very basic
setup of our application and now we want
to move on so you can see now we just
have the lock statement now we can
remove the lock statement and now before
moving on to the next steps what I'm
going to show you is I'm going to show
you that how to create the basic node
and express application with the
typescript so we are going to create the
very basic node and the express
application so we'll be using the
routing with the express so we create
the very basic application so let's move
on so how we going to do that so first
we want to import the express so we can
import the express directly from the
Express package so that should be from
the express then we can move on what we
need to do then we can just provide the
const we can have the app variable so
that should be equals to the express so
now the app variable holds the
functionality of the express application
and now what do we want to do so after
that we want to open the development
server as well of the application we can
have the app we can have the listen we
can have the app. listen and inside the
first parameter we need to provide the
number of the port so on which Port we
are going to create the application
server so suppose that can be the 5,000
so it would open on the Local Host Port
of the 5,000 and then we would be having
the call back as well after that so
inside the call back what we going to do
so we can have the lock statement we can
have the console dot we can have the log
so that should be equals to what we can
use over there we have the console.log
that should be we can have the server
open so we have the lock statement as
well so you can see once we save this
file so node modon would dedu the code
changes then it will automatically rerun
reopen your development server you can
see now you see a file which is a server
open and everything seems to be working
perfectly
fine so this is a very basic application
but this application does not accept any
of the route so let's create the routes
as well and some middle Wars as well so
what we're going to do here so first we
need to register a new route that should
be we can have the app. get request so
if you want to create a get request so
if you don't know about this type of
requests like the get post patch put
delete so I'm going to show you as well
so there are four type of requests which
are mainly used inside the backend
velopment so there are four type of
requests which are mainly used inside
the backend development so these four
request are so first request that we
have is the get request it means like we
want to get some data from this backend
or from the database so that's why we
send the get request and then we have
the put request in which if we want to
update or modify or mutate some data
then we use the put request and there
are are post request as well like if you
want to send some data like if you want
to create a new blog post or something
so that's we use the post request and
there's delete as well so we have the
delete so I think the spelling is wrong
so we have the delete request as well so
inside the delete request if we want to
send some data to delete something so
that's why we use the delete statement
over there so these are just the HTTP
verbs for incoming request so these are
the major four HTTP verbs that we'll be
using and after that now what do we want
to do so now we want to have some routes
over this application so now we want to
generate some endpoints in which we can
make a new request so first endpoint
could be we can have the app do we can
have the get so get directly you can use
directly the app.get over there then you
can provide here the URL so URL can be
slash it means the Local Host 5,000 SL
nothing and if you provide the hello
over there suppose that going be the
hello it means now you want to make a
request on Local Host 5,000 /hello and
after that what you need to do so you
can move on so you can have a call back
function so inside the call back
function you have the three parameters
the first is the request second second
is the response the third would be the
next so these three are the call back
parameters that you get over there and
these three call back parameters have a
reason the first is the request object
so if the front end or client has
requested you something so it is there
inside the request and we have the
response as well response means if the
client has requested something then it's
a duty to send back some response so
that's why we use the response over
there and we have the next as well so
next is used to move on to to the next
available middle WS so all of the middle
WS that we Define so these are just the
middle WS inside the express so Express
handles it as a middle W so if you don't
know about the middle W so after this
chapter now we'll be having the deep
understanding that what is the middle
wave so middle W are just the functions
which handle the request so this is also
a middle W so next is used to move on to
the next middle W this is a simple route
and you can see suppose you make a
request on/ and if you want to send
something to the client then you can use
the the return statement then you can
have the response then we can have the
send you can have the response. send if
you want to send some static string over
there that can be weaken at the hello it
means once you make a request to app.get
/hello it means now you will be
receiving the hello over there and for
testing that you can move on you can
download the postman so Postman is a API
testing platform for testing any type of
API that could be the graphql API that
could be the normal API so you can use
that over
there and after that now what do we want
to do so let's make the request so we
can add the
HTTP that could be the Local Host the
port of 5,000 SL we can the hello so
let's see what happens if we make the
get request on this Endo so let's just
click on the send so now you can see now
you received the hello over there so it
means everything seems to be working
perfectly fine you can see now you are
making the request to the hello it means
now you are getting the response as well
so you can say this is a get request but
if you send the post request over there
now you won't receive anything if you
click on the send you can see error
cannot post this because now this route
is not registered over there so you are
registering only get route so it will
only work with the get and now let's
just use the post as well suppose I
change this to the post over there
suppose that could be the post and
mainly the post is used to send some
data along with the request so we send
some data with the help of the body so
inside the body we can send these data
like the form data if you want to use
the forms we can have the binary data
the raw data and here inside this
application we'll be using the raw and
we'll be using the Json object we'll be
using the Json so for the input output
for this application we'll be using the
Json type of data so let's just send
some Json data like that can be the name
so name can be that should be equals to
we can have the Nik over there it's my
name so let's just click on the send so
you can see if you just click on the
send of the hello so you can see if you
will move on if you will just click on
the send you will receive the hello over
there because now you are doing so you
can see you are just returning the
response. send which is a hello but if
you want to read this data like whatever
data that the front end or client is
sending so if you want to read this data
you can move on so you need to add
another middleware of the express you
need to add another middleware so which
is we can have the app do we can have
the use so we can have the app do use so
app. use is used to define a middleware
and the middleware that we use to define
is the express we can have the Json so
it tells this application that will be
using the Json for the incoming and the
outgoing requests for this application
so it will pass all of the incoming data
to the Json so after that you can move
on you can just lock something like you
can have a log that should be equals to
we can have the request so you are
sending the body so you are sending the
body over there right so you can have
the request do we can have the body and
you are sending the Json data it will be
passed to the Json then you can just
directly access the key of the name you
can have the response body do name if
you click on the send so let's see what
happens this time so if you move on if
you just click on the send you can see
now you see the nickel over there inside
the terminal so everything seems to be
working perfectly fine so this is a post
request and now let's just understand
the put request as well so put is also
same that you send some data directly
from the front end so put is just a verb
in which it is used to modify something
into our back end suppose that can be
the database operation modify some
socket and all so it is used for the put
so it works same so if you use the put
over there it also accepts the data as
well if you click on the send then still
you will see the nickel over there and
that's how it's going to work and after
that let's move on let's have a delete
as well so we can have the delete so
delete also works same so you can send
along some data as well with the delete
if you click on the send if you just
click on the delete if you just click on
the send now you will be seeing the Nik
over there so it is same but the put and
the delete and the get there is some
something so you can say this was a
static route it means now that's a
static route that can be the hello but
what if there are millions of users
inside the database and you want to
access only one users record then how
can you do that so there are two options
first you can send some data so inside
the data you can send the ID of the user
inside this and then you can fetch the
user directly from the database then you
can send the response but the second
operation would be instead of sending
the ID into this you can send the ID
into the URL so that would be a dynamic
route so inside the URL you can send the
ID so suppose that can be SL hello
suppose that can be slash we can have
the user that can be/ ID of the user
that can be 1 2 3 4 5 it means now you
want to fetch the record of the user and
the ID of the user is 1 2 3 4 5 that can
be the ID as well that can be the
username as well so let's move on so if
you want to accept the dynamic route it
means now we don't know that what would
be there after the user then there is
one thing inside the express which is
known as the dynamic routing so that
could be app. delete SL we can up the
user because the base URL structure has
a user then you can declare a parameter
inside the endpoint that could be colon
that can be the ID so this is the
parameter now so after the user if
there's anything in so after the user if
there is anything inside the URL then it
would be stored inside the ID so this is
a variable now so now what you need to
do and to access this ID you can move on
you can have the request
to we can have the params and inside the
params you will get the ID over there so
you get the ID over there inside the
params so let's just see so if you just
click on the send you can see now you
got the params ID which is you can see
now you got the 1 2 3 4 5 and there you
can see this is the ID you can name it
whatever you want but if you name is
like user ID or anything like that so
you need to accept same thing over there
you need to accept the same thing
because this is a variable and this
cannot be renamed here so we have the
request. ps. idid if you just click on
the send you can see that's a dynamic
request so you can see this was a very
simple application and this was a very
basic tutorial of using the express with
the nodejs you can see we created a
couple of routes we created Dynamic
routes and you can see we got the param
ID we got the data as well directly from
the client so you can see that's how we
can create the applications with the
monag with the nodejs and now let's move
on so now this was a very basic
application and now we are going to
remove that so what we're going to do so
we we going to remove this request over
there and we want to remove this as well
so you can see now we just have the app.
use we have the express. Json we have
the middle be over there we have the
middle
be and you can see that's how it's going
to work and there we have the
connection we have the connections over
there and listen
n we have the connections and we have
the listen not over there and that's how
it's going to work you can see now we
have the connection and listeners now we
have this now we have the Edition and
now let's move on let's just create some
folder directories as well inside this
application so inside the source now
what do we need to do so first we would
create the folder for all of the models
inside this application so what models
do we'll be having so we'll be having
the models over there so we can have the
models over there we have the models and
then we can move on so after the models
then we want to create another folder
for the routes so instead the routes
we'll be having all of the routes of
this application then we can move on
then we can have the controllers as well
so here we have the controller functions
so these are the functions which are the
Handler functions so we create the
functions so we create the route end
points inside the routes and the
controller functions would control all
of the incoming API request then what do
we need to do then we can create another
folder that could be we can have the
utils over there so these are the
utility functions and then we would
create another folder that could be for
the config as well which is used for the
configurations inside this course so you
can see now we have created the very
basic setup of this application so if
you see the first step over there we
have created uh we have seted up the
node express application with the
typescript and everything is going to
work perfectly fine and now we want to
move on to the next step which is
integrate the mongodb database
connection inside our application so it
would be so it would be very simple so
what we need to do so after logging on
into the mongod DV now you can move on
you can just open this drop down you can
move on you can click on the create
project so with the help of this you can
create a new brand new mongodb project
with this and after that you can see now
you want to name your project as well so
what would be your project name so you
can have the M we can have the AI we can
have the chatbot over there so we have
the name of this project then we can
click on the next and after that we can
just uh skip these things then we can
just directly click on create project so
it will create the brand new mongodb
project for us and after that it will
ask you for a couple of questions as
well after that so first you can see
first we have a screen of the deployment
so now we want to deploy a database so
here we'll be using the Cloud version of
the mongodb so we won't be installing
the mongodb and Compass over there to
create the CMS type but here we'll be
using the cloud version so we can just
directly click on the
create and after that you can see there
are three options for us we have the M10
option which is 0.08 per hour and you
have the storage of around 10 GB you
have the 2 GB of RAM the memory then you
have the two virtual CPUs then you have
the serverless approach as well which is
$0.10 per 1 million RS then you have the
storage uh sorry it's a type of scalable
database you have the storage of up to 1
TV you have the auto scalable Ram Auto
scalable virtual CPUs then there is free
version as well which is the m0 which is
used for Learning and exploring the
mongodb in a cloud environment so we'll
be using the m0 as well and I will keep
these settings as default now we will
just click on the create so now we'll be
creating around mongodb Cloud deployed
version database and it is asking for a
couple of things over there we can just
click on the verify so let's see what
happens bicycles we can click on the
verify now we are verified now we can
move on so there we have a security
quick start as well so inside this it is
very required thing you can see now you
want to provide the username in which
now we want to connect to this database
so username can be we can have the
anadani over there we have the anadani
for the username then we can click on
autogenerate secure password so it will
just generate a secure password for us
then we can copy that password somewhere
so we can copy that password where
inside the EnV so for a temporary now
I'll be using this password over there
now you can see now you can just click
on create user so with the help of this
now you'll be creating your brand new
user and after that you can see now you
have the my local environment Cloud
environment so what you need to do so
after that you just need to click on
finish and close and then you can move
on to the go to
overview and after that again you can
move on one time to the network exess so
only from this IP address so this is
your IP so only from this IP address now
you are going to connect to this mongod
database but if you want to allow it
from anywhere you can click on this
button allow access from anywhere then
you can just click on the confirm so
with the help of this you can have the
allow access from anywhere so now you
can connect to the mongodb database from
any network from any IP address now you
are set it up and ready now you can just
click on the database and then you can
see now if you click on the connect and
there you can see after clicking on the
connect then you can move on you can
click on the drivers and then you can
just copy this URL so here you have the
connection URL and from this URL now you
are going to connect to this mongodb
database so you can move on you can just
copy that URL over there and there's a
note as well you need to replace the
password for the anadani user so you can
see we have copied this password and do
not use my password because I'll be
changing this password after creating
this video so what you're going to do so
you need to copy this connection string
you need to paste that over there inside
the mongodb URL so now you have the
connection string over there and instead
of this password you need to use this
password over there so you can cut this
and you can place this password in place
of that and then you can see now you
want to provide the database name as
well so after this slash now you need to
provide the database name that could be
we can have the test or we can have the
we can have the chatot over there we
have the chat bot like this so this is a
mongodb URL it is set it up and ready
and now to use the environment files and
the environment variables inside our
application so there's one thing that
you need to do so you need to import
something from the en EnV import
something from that should be from the
EnV and the something that you want to
use would be we can have the config so
you need to import the config and then
you need to run the configuration of
this so you just need to run the
configuration and with the help of this
now you can connect to the mongodb
database securely and everything seems
to be working fine and after that inside
the source you can create another folder
that could be we can have inside the
source you can create another folder
that could be we can have the DB and
inside the DB you can just create a new
file that could be we can have the
connection do we can have the TS and
after this now what do we need to do so
here we want to use the package to
connect to the mongodb database and if
you don't know about the mongus you can
just directly move on to the mongus so
first I'm going to use the test profile
over there so that should be we can have
the mongus over there so it's a odm
which is object data modeling with the
mongodb so elegant mongodb object
modeling for the nodejs so you can see
it is used to write the mongodb
validation casting creating business
logic B plate and all the things you can
see first you need to require the mongos
this is a complete setup of the mongos
you can say in just five lines first you
want to require the mongos then you want
to connect to mongodb URL you can
provide the connection string then you
create a model that could be const Cat
that should be mongos model the name of
the model and then it will be created a
collection so the collection would be
created as a cat then you have the name
that should be the string
and then you can see now if you want to
create a brand new cat you can have the
const you can have the kitty over there
that should be a new cat and then you
can provide the name inside this because
the name was required you can see the
name was there so now you can see after
that you can have the KY do save so you
just need to call the save function
directly from the mongos to save a
record inside the database and it is
completely open source and it completely
free and it is very easy to work with so
now let's move on so here we want to
just export a function from which we can
connect to mongodb database and after
that we have the connect to database and
this is an asynchronous function so we
need to write the async over there and
that's how it's going to work because
it's a database operations so we need to
wait for this task and after that we
need to import something from the mongus
to connect to the database so you can
move on to the top you can have the
import statement you can import
something from we can have the mongus
over there we have the mongos and
something that you want to use would be
we can have the connect so connect
function is there inside the mongos to
connect with the mongodb
database and after that now what do we
want to do so you can move on so inside
this what you need to do so you can move
on so you can have the track catch block
over there you have the track catch
block and there you have the error and
after the try now what do we need to do
so we just need to await for this we
need to await for a task which is we can
of the connect so inside the connect you
need to provide the URI as well so the
URI is already there inside the
environment you can just grab this
mongod URL you of the process the
current process of the nodejs dot we can
have with the environment so envirment
variables of the current process dot we
can have the mongodb URL so it will help
you to grab the mongodb URL and the
connect function will connect to the
mongodb database and after that you have
the catch error so if you get an error
then you can have the throw we can have
the new error so you can have the throw
a new error or that should be equals to
we can you can use anything like we can
have to throw new error that should be
equals to we can have we cannot
connect to
MB like this so we can have the Mong TB
like this so you have the new error over
there like that and everything seems to
be working fine and you can log this
error as well that what was the error so
you can have a console.log that should
be the error so that's how it's going to
work and I think what you can do so
instead of the default export you can
remove the export default from there now
you have this function we can create
another function if you want to
disconnect from the database and it will
help us inside the error handling so we
can create another function we can have
the sing we can have the function we can
have the
disconnect we can have the disconnect
from we can have the DB as well and we
do not need any param over there and
this will also be an a synchronous
function and after that now what do we
need to do here so inside this we need
to move on we can have the try catch
once again so inside the try now what we
need to do we can add the weight and we
want to import another function from the
wongus that could be we we can have the
disconnect and it is also a promise I
think right then we can have the await
we can have the disconnect so if
anything wrong happens within our
application inside our application then
we'll be disconnecting our application
from the database as well and that's a
secure approach because we want to
create a completely secure application
so we want to take care of the security
parameters and after that if we get an
error again we can just move on we can
just have these errors over there we can
just log the error connect to mongodb
and these are the functions that we want
to use and after that what do we want to
do so after that we can just export
these functions so we can export these
functions directly from here we can have
the connect to database then we can have
the disconnect from database so that's
how it's going to work and after that
now what do we need to do so I think we
can just manage this application folder
structure once again so this is a root
file of the index.ts now we can create
another file over there that could be we
can have the app dot we can have the TS
and now all of the applications code
would be then handled inside the app TS
so let's move on so let's just copy all
of that and let's just paste that inside
the appts so only this only till this
the app. use so all of the middle and
all would be defined inside the app. TS
and then we'll be having the export I
think we can have the export we can have
the default and that should be we can
have the app over there we have the
export default app and then we want to
import the app directly from here we can
have the import I think we can just
directly use the app so we'll be using
the import app from app and there you
can see now we have the lock statement
over there and that's how it's going to
work and then you get an error so you
need to write the GS over there you uh
you need to write the GS like this and
you can see now your application server
is over open and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine so you can see
now we are managing our application code
now we are dividing the code to increase
the readability of our code and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine and now we only want to open the
application server once our application
is connected to database so first we
need to have the connect to database
over there connect to to database and
after that only now we want to open the
development server so we can move on so
we can have the app. listen over
there app. listen over there then we can
have the catch as well so we can have
the catch if we get an error then we can
move on we can have the console do we
can have the log we can have the error
over there and after that in the end
we'll be having some error handling as
well that will be stopping the terminal
as well so we need to use that as well
so you can see now our application is
connected to database and you can see
now we do not have any
and after that we have the server open
and we can have the
connected so I think we can use this
string over there you can see now we
have the string over there we have the
server open and connected to database so
you can see now we have the handshake as
well so that's how we are going to
working so you can see now we have
defined the port number as well so
suppose if this port is not available
inside this so we can move on to the
application inside the invironment we
can Define the port over there as well
we can have the application Port so that
should be we can have the 5 ,000 for the
port and then we can use the port as
well so inside the index.ts once again
so we can use the port as well so before
this we can have the const the port and
that should be equals to we can have the
process we can have the environment do
we can have the port over there and if
the port is not available then only we
want to use the 5,000 over there so we
can have the port instead of the 5,000
directly so that's how we are going to
working so that's how we'll be working
with the node and the express
application and there you can see now we
have the message of the server open and
connected to database and everything
seems to be working perfectly fine so
now we have connected the MP database
inside our application and it is working
totally fine and now we want to see The
Next Step which is now we want to
register or login on the open portal and
we want to get the API Keys directly
from the so you can see now we'll be
creating the application from open we'll
be using their API so we want to get the
API keys for that so what we need to do
so you can move on to the openi platform
you can move on to platform. open.com
you have the apps you can see all of the
modern apps are created on the openai
then you can move on you can just click
on the API because we'll be using the
integrating we'll be using the
integrating the openai models into our
application so let's click on this and
there you can see after that we need to
use that what type of API that we'll be
using and after that now you need to
move on to the personal section you can
move on to the profile and after that
you can just move on you can have the
view API keys and after that you can
create a new API key as well so you can
just click on create new API key you can
provide the name as well so we can have
the AI we can have the chatbot over
there we have the AI chatbot you can
just click on create a secret key so
after that what you need to do so there
would be the keys generated and you need
to copy this key because you won't be
able to view it again you can just copy
that and then you can just paste that
into your envirment file and do not use
my secret again because I'll be just
deleting this secret after recording
this video so that's my open a secret as
well and there you can see that's how
it's going to work and then you can just
move on and you need a paid account as
well for using this so you need to
provide a credit card or the debit card
but it is very nominal charge so you so
you hardly pay for this because it is
very nominal charge for using the chat
GPT over there and after that you can
just close that because now you got the
API key but you can move on to the
settings as well so you can get the
organization ID as well so you need this
as well you can just copy that you can
just again paste that over there we can
have the open AI we can have the
organization
we can have the
organization we can have the open
organization ID that should be this ID
over there we have this ID over there so
now we need this ID as well for
connecting to the open and that's how
it's going to work so we just need the
secrets and the organization ID and
that's it so now we want to move on so
now you can see now we have registered
and the logged in on the open AI portal
now we got the API Keys now we want to
move on to the development so now we
want to build a secure authentication
with the web tokens with the HTTP only
cookies and we want to create some end
points for us so let's move on and let's
just start building the CPI endpoints
for our application so let's move on so
here you can see first we need to move
on to the app. TS and here we want to
define the middle WS that we'll be using
so first you need to just stop the
terminal so either you can open another
terminal as well you can have the CD and
inside the backend folder you can
install a dependency which is a Morgan
so we can add the npm install we can
have the Morgan over there so what
Morgan package will do so it will just
dis so it will just uh give you some log
description that what type of request
was handled and what was the response
and what was the status code so we have
the Morgan as well so what we need to do
so we can import this we can have the
import we can have the Morgan over there
that should be from we can have the
Morgan like that we can have the Morgan
over there and here what we need to do
so after this Json then we can have
another middle that could be app. use
then we can the Morgan over there we can
have the
Morgan and after that now what do we
want to do so here we have the Morgan
over there so after the Morgan then we
need to provide a string that could be
we can have the dev over there we have
the Morgan that should be equals to the
dev and after that if we make an API
call to this back end then we'll be
seeing the lock message as well so we
want to remove it inside the production
so once we build this application we
want to remove this as
well
so we only want to use this inside the
development mode and once we enter the
production then we want to remove this
as well and after that now what do we
want to do now we want to generate the
middleware over there so now we want to
create the middleware for our
application we can have the first
middleware we can have the app. use that
could be we can have the API structure
for our application that could be Local
Host 5,000 or any domain slash we can
have the API over there SL we can have
the API SL we can have the version as
well we can have the API slash we can
have the V1 and after that we can create
the route Handler file which can be the
main route Handler so inside the routes
we can have the index so we can have the
index do we can have the TS over there
and set the routes and after that now
what do we need to do so we can move on
we can have the import we can have
something from we can have the express
and we want to import the routing from
the express so we can have the router
from the express to use the routing and
after that we can have the const we can
have the app we can have the
router the whole application rout AO and
that should be equals to we can have the
router from the express so now we have
the router Express and after that now
what do we want to do so now we'll be
having the export we can have the
default so that should be this router
sorry and that should be this app router
over there because now we want to export
this app router as well and now we want
to use this app router so after we make
a request on app so after we make a
request on/ API slv1 then it will be
handled to this app router so that's how
it's going to work so after this so
after the express will move on to this
endpoint so it will handle so the app
router will handle this type of endpoint
over there and after that now we want to
create the structure of our routes as
well so we can have the app router dot
we can have again the use we can again
use the use over there because here we
want to generate a middleware so on the
use if the request is made to/ user then
we'll be moving on and then we'll be
using the users's routes over there
let's create the routes for the user so
we can move on so we can have the user
SL we can have the routes dot we can
have the TS over there and after that we
need to Define these routes so again we
can use the import that should be we can
have something we can have the router
like this router from Express then we
can have the cons we can have the user
routes so that should be equals to we
can again use the router over there we
can have the router like this we want to
router class then we can have the export
uh we can have the default and that
should be we can have the user routes
over there
so then if we make a request to/ user
then we want the user router to handle
those incoming request and that's how to
handle those incoming request and that's
how it's going to happen and then we can
create another router over there for the
chats as well so we can have the chats
we can have the
routes dot we can have the TS and now we
want to follow the same thing for the
chats as well so we can move on we can
just copy that and then we can just
paste that over there so now we can have
the chat routes
so here we have the chat routes so you
can see I'm doing this because I want to
increase the readability of the code you
can see now we have the index.ts and
then we can again copy that we can paste
we can have slash we can have the chats
over there we have the SL chats then we
can have the chat router over there we
have the chat routes so it means now
once we move on to the domain
slash we can have the API slash we can
have the V1 because this is a version
one and then we can move on to the app.
TS you can see once we move on to this
API endpoint so then the request would
be transferred to this app router so
then we have this request and if the
request is to/ user then this user
routes would handle this request and if
this request is on the chat if the
request is on the chat over there like
this so if it is on the chat then the
chat would be handling that
so then we have the chats over there
like this so then the chat routes would
handle that request so the chat routes
would handle that request so that's how
it's going to work and now we can
finally move on to the user router and
now we can Define all of the HTTP verbs
that will be accepting inside this
application so you can see it falls a
bit complicated process but it increases
the readability of the code that we want
to use inside this application so now
you can see now we have the user router
let's just create the request over there
we can have the user routes or we can
have the get request so suppose that
could be get we can have the slash over
there and after this slash now what do
we want to do so after this slash then
we can have the controller function as
well so now we don't want to create all
of the controllers and the routes over
there so for the Handler functions for
handling this request we want to move on
to the controllers we can have the user
we can have the
controllers do we can have the TS so now
we want the users's controller to handle
the incoming requests for the users so
suppose that a get request so what do we
need to do so we want to create a
function we can have the export cost we
can have the get all we can have the
users like that so that would be equals
to a function like that so from this now
we want to get all of the users from the
back end so that's how it's going to
work and after that now what do we want
to do so now we want to get all users
directly from the database and then you
can see that's how it's going to happen
so we have the get route and after that
we can just assign this function over
there we can assign to get all users
directly from the controller so
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine inside our application you can see
now we have defined the routes as well
inside this application and everything
seems to be working perfectly
fine so welcome back and now before
moving ahead into the routes and all so
let's just Define the models that we'll
be using inside our application so now
we would be using some models as well
the database models which are the
schemas so we need to Define them as
well so for defining the model let's
just see that what will be the fields of
the user model so here comes a new topic
about the database models so we'll be
having the model of the user and after
that the model user will contain the
name we'll be having the email of the
model user we'll be having the password
as well and then we'll be having the
chats as well so chat will not be a new
collection or a new model so we'll be
creating a brand new object type schema
for the chat so all of the users chats
would be there inside the chat and this
would be an array of the chat schema so
these are the database models that we'll
be defining so let's just move on to the
application so inside the models what we
can do so we can create a new file that
could be we can have the user dot we can
have the TS and after that we need to
create a new schema so like we use the
mongus so like initially we showed you
the mongus that how The mongus Works to
create the schema so that's how you're
going to create that so we can have the
import we can have the mongos over there
we can import the full mongos library
and after that now what do we want to do
so we can have the const we can have the
user schema like that we can have the
user schema so that should be equals to
new instance of the mongus do we can
have the schema so we can have the
mongus do schema class so we can make an
instance of that and after that we need
to provide the schema definitions so
schema definitions can contain the first
field that we want to provide would be
the ID I think the ID would be
automatically generated from the mongodb
so we don't want to generate that so we
can have the name over there so we can
have the each user can contain a name so
for the name we can have the type for
the name so that should be at the string
over there and it should be a required
field for creating a brand new user so
we can have the required validation over
there and after that we'll be having the
email as well so it is same so we can
have the type that should be we can have
the string over there and then we would
be having the required property so that
should be we can have the true for that
and then the email should be unique so
for that we can have the unique as well
we have the unique so that should be
equals to the true so this is not a
validation but it creates some indexes
for the email to search quickly then we
can have the password as well so we can
have the password over there we can have
the password we can have the type over
there
like this so we can again have the type
of that should be inside the string and
then we can move on so it also required
so we can have required like this and
that should be to the true so these are
the three fields that we required for
the user schema and then the main field
is the chats over there the chats so
chats would be an array so it would be
an array of a new schema so we can
Define the chat schema as well before
the
user so we can have the cons we can have
the chat schema over there like that we
can have chat schema like that and that
should be again equals to new we can
have the mongus do we can have the
schema over there we can have mos.
schema and after that we can just create
the ID of the chat so mongodb provides
you the ID automatically so if you don't
want to provide the ID so it's up to you
but if you want to provide the ID then
you can just use the ID over there you
can have the ID you can again move on to
the ID you can Define the type over
there that should be inside you can have
the string over there inside the type
and then you can move on you can have
the default as well of the ID so default
should be you can import a package from
the nodejs so we can have import
something from we can have the crypto so
directly from the crypto you can get
something which is we can have the
random uu ID so it will help you to
generate a new ID so we can have the
random U ID for that so it will just
create a new uu ID for us and after that
what we can do so we can just define the
role so inside this now we want to
define the role so there are two roles
for using the open a platform that can
be the the AI chatbot that is a
assistant and there can be the user so
there are two roles for that so we can
have the type so that should be we can
have the string over there and then we
want to move on so that should be the
required property that should be the
required and that should be again equals
to the true because the role are
required and after the role there's
another thing which is a Content so what
would be the content content is actually
the message so it is also required so we
can move on we can just copy the type
required and we have the require we have
uh we have the type string we have the
required which is the true you can see
now we have schema for the chats so the
two main properties are the role and the
content role is the assistant of the
user the content is the message property
of the
user and after that the chats would be
the schema so we can have the chats
schema inside the array it means now the
chats would be having the array of the
chat schema inside that and that's how
it's going to work and you can see the
chat is not required the chats is not
required because some users won't be
having the chats over there and that's
how it's going to work and after that
the final thing that we want to do is
now we want to export this as well so we
can have the export we can have the
default that should be equals to we can
have the mongus we can have the model
over there we can have the mongus model
that should be we can have the user so
now we have the user model for that and
then we want to Prov the scheme as well
so we can have the user schema so that's
how it's going to work so now we have
the new model we have the mongos start
model that could be for the user and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine over do and if you want to add some
validations for the mongus do model so
like suppose like in the next year
applications what happens is sometimes
it creates multiple instances of the
mongus model so you can Pro the
validation like you can the mongus do we
can have the connections over there you
have the connections or you can the
mongos or we can the models over there
the models SL we can have the user like
that so if you have the mongus do models
user then you don't need to create a new
model but here inside the nodejs it
doesn't create that it only have one
single instance so there won't be an
issue and after that you can see
everything seems to be working fine over
there now you have the mongus model of
the user and now you will be having a
new collection inside the database of/
users so everything seems to be working
perfectly fine and now what we need to
do so now again we can move back to the
users controller and now we can close
this as well the PowerPoint because now
it will take some time to get back into
the PowerPoint again now you can see now
we have the get all users so now if
suppose make a request to get all users
now it means now we want to get all of
the users now we want to find all of the
users from the database it means now we
can again run the try catch block over
there so this is a very simple route so
we can have the try catch block and
inside the try now what do we want to do
we can have the const we can have the
users so that should be equals to the
weight then we can have the user model
we can just directly refer to the user
model so that equ to the find so we have
a function inside the mongus model which
is the find so it works on the query so
if we provide any query params if we
provide any query inside the find then
it will find out of the records matching
that specific query but if we do not
provide any query it will find all of
the records from the database and it
will give you all of that records so
that's how it's going to work and we
have an eror for the await because it's
not an async function let's just make it
as an async and after that now we have
the users then you can see now we have
the users over there and everything
seems to be working fine now we can move
on so we can have the return we can have
the response so we want to define the
variables as well the request response
and the next as we did inside the
initial application so the request is
actually the request object it should be
imported from the express the response
also should be a response type object it
should be imported from the express then
we have the next function we have the
next over there so we can have the next
over there like that and that's how it's
going to work and after that you can see
now we have the users that should be
equals to the await user. find and after
that we can just move on we can have the
return we can have the response or we
can have the status over there that
should be we can have the 200 which is
okay then we can send the Json message
over there we can send the Json over
there so that's how we can send the Json
response first we Define the status or
status is optional if you want to Define
then you can just directly refer to the
Json you can Define the message like
that you can have the message that could
be we can okay then we can send all of
the users like that so that's how it's
going to work and if you get an error
you can again send a customizer response
for that you can just copy that over
there you can just paste that over there
you have the message we can have the
error like that and then you have the
users so instead of this you can send
the error message like you can have the
message error and then what you need to
do you can have the cause over
there cause and that should be we can
have the error dot we can have the
message over there so you uh so you have
a message property inside the error so
you will be getting the cause over there
and now you can just log the error as
well you can just log the complete error
and that's how it's going to work so you
can see this was our first API request
for getting all of the users from the
database and let's just test it out so
we can move on to the postman we can
create another collection over there we
can just click on that we have a new
collection so we can have the name of
the collection that could be uh we can
have the M AI we can have the chatbot
over there m at chatbot and after that
let's create another request click on
that click on add a request so that
would be a new request that would be get
all we can have the users like that that
would be a request of get all users and
inside this we have a get type of
request we can provide the parameters
HTTP Local
Host the port of 5,000 slash we can have
the API slash we can have the V1 slash
we can have with the users so instead of
writing the Local Host 5000 API what we
can do is we can make this as a variable
we can have API V1 so we can make this
as a variable I think we can make this
like this so you can see now we have
this set a variable so we can have the
set a variable it means now we want to
have the back
end Base address we can have the back
and Base address like that so we can
have the Local Host 5,000 over there we
can I think we can just copy full string
over there like that 5,000 SL
API 5,000 API then we can just click on
create a variable that could be set a
new variable the variable name could be
we can have the
backend base we can have URL like that
backend base URL and we can have the
scope as well or I think we can just
Define the base URL over there the base
URL and we can Define the scope that
should be we can have the local inside
just the collection of the money chatbot
we can have the/ API SL we can have the
V1 as well so that was my mistake
because I didn't add the V1 over there
so that was the values over there we
have the API / V1 and after that we can
just click on this save and now we can
move on to get all users so now we have
the base URL SL we can have the user
over there SL we can have nothing
because we don't have anything after the
user so let's just click on the send and
let's see what happens so you can see
now we got something we got the message
that is okay then we got the users as
well which is an array but you can see
we do not have any any value inside the
array so because now you can see now we
do not have any record inside the
database and there you can see that's
how it's going to work and you can see
you got another lock statement which is
you can see now you got the get and the
and sorry the API end point was API /v/
user and then you can see the status of
the requests was 200 and you can see the
response the time it took for the
response you can say it is just around
so we have 323 milliseconds for that and
you can say this is a unique number so
it is coming via the Morgan package so
we have added the Morgan over there if
we move on to the app. TS so it is
coming via this and that's how it's
going to
work so now everything seems to be
working perfectly fine and now we need
to move on to the next things so here we
have created the very first request
which is a get request and now we want
to create another request of the user
sign up so now let's create that request
as well and that would be a post request
so what we can do so here we can just
write the user routes dot we can have
the post over there because that's a
post route and then the URL can be we
can have slash we can have the sign up
so it means/ user SL sign up and now we
want to create the controller function
as well again so we can move on to the
users controllers and what we can do so
we can just copy this and then we can
just paste that over there and here
instead of get all users it could be the
user slash we can have the sign up we
have the user sign up and after that
again we can move on to the user routes
and that could be we we can have the
user sign up like this so everything
seems to be working perfectly fine so
now we have the user sign up request and
if we will make the user sign up request
then this function this controller
function is going to be executed and now
let's move on so in the user sign up
what we will do so we'll send some data
along with the request as well so we'll
move on to the postman so from the
postman we will be sending some body
data along with the request because we
need some data so for creating a new
user we need need the user's email name
and the password so we need that data
directly from the client so what we can
do so here we have the user sign up so
here first we will get the data and how
we can get the data so as you know that
we'll be sending the data along with the
body so we'll be sending the body and
we'll be sending some raw Json along
with the body so let me create another
request for the Post sign up as well so
let's move on so inside this you can
just right click on that you can have
the add requests and that could be you
can rename that and you can rename you
can have the new user or you can have
the user like this you can have the user
you can have the sign up like this so
here we have the user sign up requests
and now let's move on and this could be
the post request so the URL should be
the base URL for this should be the same
like this API V1 and after that we'll be
having the user slash we can have this
sign up like that we have the user sign
up like this so now we have this request
and now we need to send some body data
along with it so we can move on to the
body we can click on the
and then we can send some Json data
along with it so inside the Json data we
need to send the name of the user the
name could be we can send my name as
well like I will send my name like we
can have the N we can have the Tani over
there then we can send the email of the
user as well so that could be the email
like that and email should be we can
have the
anadani at theate we can have the test
dot we can have the com then we can move
on we can have the password as well so
that could be the password password and
it could be we can send any password
like 1 2 3 4 5 so this is my password so
we'll be sending these details by the
postman or any client and now we want to
get this data as well inside the back
end and how we can get that so we are
sending from the body so we need to
extract that directly from the body so
instead of get all users it means now we
want to create the user sign up and this
could be we can have the const we can
destructure all of these properties like
the name email and the password directly
from the body of the request
we can destructure this directly from
the request. we can have the body and
now inside the destructuring we can
destructure the name the
email the password directly from these
things so we have the name email and the
password and now what do we need to do
so here we have three requests over
there and now what do we need to do now
we need to create a brand new user so
for doing that so we can have the const
we could have the user we can create a
new instance so we can have the user
that should be equals to a new user
models instance so now we need to create
the instance and we need to provide the
fields that are required that could be
the name that could be the email and
that could be the password so we can
send the password along with it but this
is the same password that the user is
sending so inside the back end we don't
usually store these passwords which the
user directly send so we don't store the
same strings that we get directly from
the front end so we encrypt the
passwords and there are many security
reasons that we should always encrypt
the password before storing into the
database so that if an employee so I'm
giving you one example so suppose if an
employee is working inside the database
company so they can see everyone's
password inside the database so before
that inside the backend so back end has
the responsibility to encrypt the
password before storing it into the
database so we have the password and for
encrypting that password now what we
will do so we'll use a package which is
a bcrypt so we have already added that
package inside the package.json so if
you move on to the package.json you will
find the BPT package over there we have
the bcrypt and the bcrypt is used for
encrypting the user string it so sorry
it can be used to encrypt any string and
then we can compare the string with the
original string if that string same or
not so let's encrypt the password before
storing it directly into the database so
we can have the
import something from we can have the B
Crypt over there and something that we
need to use is uh we need to use us the
hash so hash is used to Hash a password
is used to encrypt a password and now we
have the con new user and for before and
before creating a new user what do we
need to do so we can have the const we
can have um we can have the hash
password like
this and that should be equals to what
we need to do so we can have the hash
over there that could be the hash and
the first parameter that we need to
provide would be the data and that could
be a string or a buffer so we have the
same string of the password we we can
use the same string so we can have the
password and inside the second parameter
we need to provide the rounds like how
many rounds they are used with the
encryption so as many rounds as you
provide here the more encrypted password
you will get so here we need to provide
here the 10 because now this is are
default rounds as well so you can
provide any number of rounds so it has
some techniques to generate the hash
password with the rounds and now we have
the hash and that's a promise so we need
to await for this task as well so we
have here the await over there and
instead of storing the same password
directly receiving from the user we can
just store your the hashed password as
well we have the hashed password and
that's our it's going to work and after
that the new instance of the user would
be created and now the final thing that
we want to do is we want to move on we
can have the a wait we can have the user
do we can have the save so now we want
to save the user so for creating and for
saving a new record inside the database
we use the user do we can have the save
over there to save a record and after
after that we have the return statement
as well so inside the return statement
we have the message okay and then we can
send the brand new user or we can send
the email of the user we can or what we
can do we can send the ID of the user
like we can have the ID that should be
we can have the user do we can have the
ID like this we can have the underscore
uh we can have the underscore ID of the
user and Dot we can have the two string
over there because the ID is in I think
the object ID format so before uh
directly giving the response to the
front end we should use the two string
to convert that into a string and now
let's move on so now we have these three
Fields the name email and the password
and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine so now let's wait till
the database is connected and let's move
on to the postman once
again so the server open and database is
connected and now we can move on to the
postman let's just click on send so
let's see what happens so there you can
see now we have the ID there so you can
see now we have the ID it means now the
user is already created in inside the
database and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine and now let's
move on to the get all users so let's
see that what is happening over there so
if we just make a new request to the get
all users so now we should be receiving
one user yes so here we are receiving a
new user we have the side of the user
650 or anything we have the name email
and the password and you can see this is
the password which the BP has generated
so that's how it creates the encryption
of the passwords so now the user has
signed up successfully and there you can
see now we have a post request as well
we have the 200 and everything seems to
be working perfectly fine but there you
can see now before sending all of these
fields to the database so we should have
some uh so we should have some
validation checks as well so suppose if
the name was empty so suppose if the
email was not exactly the email or it
was the incorrect string or if the
password was not following the length of
the password like the modern password
should have around six num should have
the length of around six so if they do
not follow all of the validations then
it would could create some errors inside
the database so what we need to do so
before coming to the user signup
function so we could add another middle
whe inside the user routes inside this
request so before directly jumping into
the user signup request we should have
the validation check of the data so that
would be our approach so we'll be using
the concept of the middle WS to do that
so that would be a middle W for checking
the data validation that will send
directly from the front
end and before doing that I want to
introduce you to a topic which is a
middle W so what are the middle wers so
the middle WS are just a functions and
they get executed before a request is
processed so between the request and the
response it acts as a bridge between
them to modify request to modify
response into them and inside the node
and the express so middle can be used to
check the Json Vol validations the
tokens or sending some cookie
validations directly from the front end
the parms of the the request because we
are using the rest API there can be the
data validation checks and more
according to the requirements so how the
middle work so let's move on to the
paint and let's just identify so here
suppose that's a request oh sorry there
should be the square box so suppose it's
a request that the user is sending
directly from the front end so this is a
client so let's move on so that's a
client over there and the client is
sending some requests along with some
data and now it sends a new request to
the backend so suppose it is sending a
new request to the back end so I'm not
using any illustrations over there so
this is just the normal pin tool and now
suppose that's a backend right so this
is a back end and the client
communicates to the back end and the
back end communicates to the database so
that's how the structure works and now
let's move on so inside the back end
suppose the client sends a sign up
request so it's sign up and inside this
sign up we'll be sending some data along
with it so there there could be some
data like there can be the name email
and the password because it is there
inside the signup and before moving on
directly into the database and store
that data we should add we should add
another middle in which we need to
verify the data like this can be the
middle function in which first we need
to verify all of the data so we can
again move on we can have a
verify all data before just moving on
and before just saving the record of the
user and then let's move on and and then
let's create another middle W so there
can be another middle W in which the
user should be stored inside the
database so let's move on so there can
be another middleware over there so that
could be the final middle ware in which
now we want to store the user inside the
database so let's move on let and that
could be uh we can have the final middle
ra to store users
information we can have the users
info like this so we can have the users
info like that so we need to store the
final users information into that and
that's how it's going to work so first
if it will move on to this so I'm using
a pencil so first the client makes a
request to the back end so first the
request would be moved on to verify all
data right so the request would be moved
on to verify all data and if the
verification is successful of the user
then only it will be moved on to the
next middle W and if the validation was
wrong if there was some errors during
the data inside the data then it will
just move back to the client and it will
send them that the data is incorrect and
you need to send the exact data that we
required so that's how it's going to
work if the data is not correct and if
the data is correct then we'll move on
to the final middleware function to
store the information of the user so
this is the concept of the middleware
and you can take the screenshot of it as
well because this could help you if you
do not come about the middle inside any
application so inside web development
this is a concept of the middle W so
whether it's any framework like the node
it can be the C as well ASP as well Java
as well so this is only the concept of
the middle WS so let's move on so now
let's use the middle WS for the data
validation checks and now let's move on
so we will be using the express valid
dat package for using the middle and
this has a set of Express GS metal WS
that wraps the extensive collection of
validators and sanitizers offered by the
Val data.js so it adds some middleware
between the request and the response
that we can use so it has already
included in our package so now let's use
it and now let's move on so we'll be
having the validation chains and we'll
be having a customized validator
function so we'll be having the
validation chain inside the validation
chains we'll be having multiple
validations like if there is a sign up
request then we need to verify the email
we need to verify the name of the user
we need to verify the password so there
are three functions that we need to
verify name and the password and then
there could be the final validator
function so it will check all of those
validations and if there was something
wrong during the validation check then
it will just send back the response to
the client that there was something
wrong with the data and it will send the
exact error message as well and if
everything was successful then we'll be
moved on to the final function then
we'll be moved on to the final
middleware function to execute and to
store the users information so let's
move on uh so what we can do so inside
the utils let's create another file that
can be we can have the
validators do we can have the TS so
that's a validators dots and here first
what we can do so we can Define some
validators for the sign up so we can
have the con we can have the sign up
valid data like that sign up valid
data so that could be an array so inside
the array now we want to store a couple
of validation checks so inside the sign
up validator there can be three fields
that are required the first would would
be we can have the body we can import
the body directly from the Express
validator and the body should contain
the name right so a name is a required
field so it should contain the name so
then we can have the name do we can have
the not empty like that it should not be
empty and then what we can do then we
can have the required like this so we
can have is required I think so if it is
not empty so I think required B like
that uh let's check that
so I think the required is not there so
I think the not empty would work
perfectly fine so name should not be
empty and then let's move on so we can
add the uh response message as well if
the name was empty then we can have the
function which is with message we can
part A customize error message if the
name field was empty we can have the
name is required like this so this is
our first function of the body then we
can use that two more times for the
email and the password so we can have
the email then then we can have the
password over there like that that could
be the password like
that and inside the email we can first
trim the record of the email we can trim
we can remove the white spaces from both
uh front and the back from both front
and the rear and then we have the trim
then what we can use so after the trim
we can just use your is email like this
so we can have the is email so it will
verify if the email was actually the
email or not and then we can again use
the with message over there like this so
so we can finally again move on we can
have a width message like that we can
have the width message and after that we
can have the email is required so we can
have the email is required then the same
should be used for the password so first
what we can use so we can again use the
triam over there and then we can use
another function that could be we can
have the is length something we can have
the is length so it will verify if the
password has the desired length or not
so we can have the minimum so we can
provide the minimum length to the
password and that could be somewhere
around six so if the password length was
not matched then we'll be having the
error inside the response then we'll
send back the same response to the
client so we have the with message over
there then we can have the
password should
contain at least six
character so we can have this string
over there and that's how it's going to
work so now we have defined the
validator function and everything seems
to be working perfectly fine but now we
need to see that how we can verify these
functions how we can verify so we can
create our customized function we can
create a customized validator function
in which we will verify all of these
details so what we can do so we can have
a function we can have the cons we can
have the validate over there like this
valid date and that could be equals to
we can have the arrow function over
there that could be the arrow function
it should not be the sync so we have the
Val so we have the validation function
over there and inside the params we need
to get the signup validator we need to
get all of the these validators whether
it's a sign up or there can be multiple
validators over there so we can have the
validations like this so we can have the
validations and the type for this is
already defined inside the express
validator the type is the validation
chain like this so we have the type of
the validation chain and that could also
be the validation chain over there and
that could be this function and now it
would be an array of the validation
chains because these are the chains and
now let's move on so you know that the
validate function so all of the metal
wheels inside the express are required
and they should have the request
response and the next inside that so how
we can do that so here we want to return
a new asynchronous function we can have
the return aing we can have the function
over there Arrow function that could
have the request and the request could
be the same request format that are
required from the express then we can
have the response the response should be
what we can do response can have the
response directly from we can have the
express JS and then we'll be having the
next function as well which is used to
move on to the next middle will we can
have the next function over there and
that's how it's going to work and that
could be an aror function over there and
now inside this now what do we want to
do so here we need to run a loop so
we'll be running a loop over there in
which we will verify all of these
conditions we'll verify all of these
conditions and if there was an error
then we'll send back the same error to
the client so let's move on so here we
can have the for Loop over there
directly we can have the cons we can
have the validation like that we can the
validation or we can have the
validations like that validation of
validations and then we can move on so
what we can do so we can have the await
over there or what we can do we can
verify the conditions from here as well
we can have the const we can have the
result and that should be equals to we
can have thewait then we can have the
validation so we can have this
validation
function validation like that dot we can
have the Run we have a function of the
run to run a validation and this should
have the request so we have the request
inside the validator of the express so
we'll so inside the middleware of the
express we have the request as well we
need to send the same request over there
that we received directly from the
client and it's an um it's a promise so
we should wait for this task as well so
that's why we have used your wait over
there and now let's move on so then we
can check another Val check that could
be very simple like if we have the
result we can have the errors like that
I think they have removed the property
so what we can do instead so we can
remove the result property as well or we
can have directly the errors like we can
have the if we can have the
result like that dot we can have I
think uh we can have the is empty so
result means this time the errors so if
the result do errors are not empty then
what we can do then we can break the
loop so that's what we need to do for
this for Loop and after that now what do
we want to do so after the for Loop now
we will verify if there was an error or
not so if there would be error so it
will automatically break the loop and
now let's move on so here now what do we
want to do so we can have the cons we
can have the errors so that should be
equals to we can have the validation we
can have the result so this is defined
inside the express
validator the validation result so this
is the final result of the validations
so it will give you the property of the
errors so we need to provide the request
as well here so that could be the
request and now the final thing that we
want to verify is if there was the
errors then we don't need to move on to
next middle Ware and if there was no any
error then we need to move on to next
middleware function which could be the
final middle W to store some data let's
move on so we can have if we can have
the errors like this if the errors to we
can have S uh what we can do we can have
the is errors do is empty it means
everything was working fine then we can
move on to next middleware function so
here the next means that we want to move
on to next middle that could be this
final user signup function and now let's
move on so if there was some errors if
we do not pass this validation check
then we can move on then we can have the
response do we can have the status over
there that could be we can have the 422
which is unprocessable entity it means
that data cannot be processed further
then we can have the Json over there we
can send the errors directly we can send
the errors and that could be we can have
the errors to we can convert them to the
array so that's how it's going to work
and we need to return that as well we
need to return this response so that's
how these things going of work so that
is the final validate function and now
let's move on to the user route and here
inside this so inside the sign up first
we need to add this we have the valed
function we can have the validate
function directly from the validators
and then what we want to validate is the
validation chain we can have the sign up
validator we can have the sign up
validator for
that
and that's how it's going to work so now
you can see everything seems to be
working perfectly fine and now let's
move on so suppose from the postman if
we move on to the user sign up once
again so suppose that's not an email
right so we have added that validation
check over there inside the validators
like if this was a email or not is email
so let's move on so suppose this is a
normal string I remove the adate and.com
over there let's just click on the send
and let's see what happens so there you
can see now we got the errors array you
can see we got the status as well we
have the erors you can see the type of
the field we have the value andani and
you have the message that email is
required you can see everything seems to
be working perfectly fine over there and
everything seems to be working fine you
can see and now you can see the minimum
length of the password is six so suppose
we send the five characters if we click
on the send so now you can see now with
the password should contain at least six
characters so everything seems to be
working perfectly fine over there
so let's create another record as well
so that could be name we can have the
James Marshall like that we have the
James Marshall and the M should be
Capital then we can have the email we
can have the James test.com we can have
the password of 1 2 3 4 5 6 so let's
just click on the send so now the new
user should be created and here we have
the ID of the user and everything seems
to be working perfectly fine and another
thing that I just noticed is now we can
move on to the controllers and if we
create a new user then the status should
be the 2011 so that is the status of the
created it should be 2011 like that and
everything seems to be working fine so
now we have completed the sign up
request and now we need to move on to
the login function as well so let's move
on to the user routes let's create the
similar type of request for the user
router do post that could be we can have
the login we have the validate and this
time there could be different functions
for the validator let's just copy and
let's just paste before that and I will
and I will tell you about this that why
before that so that could be we can have
the
login we can have the Valor so now you
can see inside the login and inside the
sign up so you can see the email and the
password as similar Fields so right the
email and the password are similar
Fields inside both login and inside the
signup so what we can do so inside the
login what we can do we can remove the
name directly from here right we can
remove the name and from this sign up we
can remove the both email and the
password right and before the and after
the name now what we can do so we can
just use the login validator right so
because the login validator is just the
array of the validation functions so now
what we have so inside the sign up we
have the name then we have the email
then we have the password and that's how
it's going to
work and now let's move on to the users
controller so here let's move on to the
user routes once again so now it could
be we can have the login valid dat like
that and let's move on to the user sign
up again so inside this now what do we
need to do so let's create another
request for the user login so it could
be we can have the
user login like that and here now what
do we need to do so that's a sign up it
could be user we can have the login and
here there could be different fields we
don't need the name over there and the
the things would be different so let's
just remove all of that and let's just
see what happens we can Rec commend this
out as well and after we get the email
and the password directly from this
let's move on and here now what we want
to do so first we need to find the user
by its email so let's have this vage and
check we can have the con we can have
the
existing user like that or we can have
directly the user property we can have
the const user that could be we can have
the weight then we can have the user do
we can have the find one we can find one
user of the record and then what we can
do we can send the filter over there we
can send the filter of the email that
this email should match this email we
want to find one user that this email
should match this email and after
creating this so I have one thing in my
mind so let's move on to the user sign
up so before creating a brand new user
we need to also verify if there was a
same email inside the database if there
was a same user inside the database with
the same email so let's move on so
before even creating the hash password
let's move on so we can have the cons we
can have the user we can have the
existing user like this so that could be
equals to the await then we can have the
user so we can find a user again we can
you have a find one of the user then
what we can do so we can again provide
the email so that's our is going to work
so now we have the find one of the email
and then we'll verify if we have the
existing user then it means now the user
is already there with the same email
then we can again send the response to
we can have the status that could be we
can have have around 401 which is
unauthorized then we can send the Json
or we can just directly use the send
function that we can have the user
already
register we can send this validation
check so I missed this thing so now we
have added that and everything should
work perfectly fine now and now what do
we want to do so here first we'll verify
the user we need to verify if the user
is there or not so if there was the user
we can verify if there was no user then
we want to send the return message we
can have the response dot status that
could be 401 dot we can send here the
send over there and then we can have the
user not we can have the register like
that and now we have the user right now
we have the validation if we don't have
the user then we'll be sending this
response message but what if and what
after that when we have the user now we
want to verify the password of the user
for the authentication purposes now we
want to verify the password but let's
move on so how can we do that so from
the bcrypt we have a function of the
compare as well so we cannot directly
decrypt the password of the user and
then we can verify because it requires a
lot a lot of calculations so either what
we can do so compare is very easy so we
can compare the password with the actual
string so let's move on so we can have
the cons we can have the is password
correct and that should be equals to we
can add the a wait then we can have what
was the function name so it was a
compare so we can have the we that
should be we can have the compare over
there and inside the compare we need to
provide the data which is the string
which is the actual string so actual
string is the password and then the
thing that we want to compare is with
the encrypted string so from the
encrypted string now we want to verify
encrypted string is there directly
inside the user object we have the user
dot we can have the password over there
so that's how it's going to work so this
will give you a Boolean value you you
can see the Promise resolved with a
Boolean and then we'll verify that if
the password was correct or not let's
move on so we can have if we can have is
password correct we can have if the
password was not correct then what we
can do we can have the return response
we can have the status that could
be and that could be we the 403 which is
forbidden then we can send a new message
we can have the send and inside this we
can have the incorrect password like
this
we have the incorrect password and
that's how it's going to work and after
that now what do we want to do so once
the password is correct once everything
is fine then it means now the user has
successfully authenticated so let's move
on so after that now what do you want to
do so after the password is verified
after the user's email is verified then
we know that the user is the actual user
then we can send the response. status of
that should be 200 we can send the
message of the okay then we can send the
the ID of the user and that's how it's
going to work so let's just try this
login function so you can see we created
this signup request over there the James
Marshall James test.com with the email
with the password let's move on let's
create another request over there let's
click on ADD request that could be we
can have a a
login and I will share you the postman
collection as well don't worry so here
we have the user login we can move on to
the body inside the raw inside the Json
now we want to provide the fields like
the email and the password we can copy
from this we can paste that directly
inside the login over there so we have
the email and the password and now we
want to send the URL as well so the URL
could be again we can copy that we can
paste and instead of the sign up that
could be the login and the request is
the post so let's just try it out let's
just click on this end so let's see what
happens so now we have a
message so
why this message is coming so let's move
on to the user routes so there you can
see that is an error because here you
can see the user is already there the
email is already there so we cannot
create this user so you can see what we
can do so instead of the user sign up
that could be we can have the user login
I made another mistake with that so this
could be the user login over there now
let's move on let's just try it out once
again click on the send so now you can
see message we have the okay it means
everything is working perfectly fine and
there you can see if the password was
incorrect if we send another string over
there like the one so let's just try it
out clicking on the send so you can see
now we got the message like incorrect
password and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine over there you
can see now everything is working
fine so with this stab you can see now
we have completed the basic user
authentication system with the mon stack
we have created the sign up request the
login requests and everything seems to
be working perfectly fine so this was
the basic things of creating the some
requests of the authentication of the
user user management now we want to move
on to the authentication right now we
want to move on to the authentication
systems like now after the user has
logged in or the sign up then we want to
generate a token for the user a token
can be the ID card for the user to show
something to access some resource so
let's move on and let's just understand
that and now let's learn that how we can
authenticate the user inside this
application so let's learn that what
exactly is the authentication first so
what is the user authentication as you
know the user authentication is a step
in which the user needs to verify their
identity so user needs to verify their
identity and user can verify the
identity by providing the same
credentials that the user used during
the registration process and for this
application as well the user needs to
provide the email and the password and
if the email and the password are
correct it means the user is
successfully authenticated and
everything should work perfectly fine
but what after the authentication so
authentication is just step one of the
user authentication so there a complete
package of the authentication so
providing the email and the password is
just a very first and very simple step
of creating the authentication but now
there will be another step in which the
user would be provided a token so
suppose you joined a company right so
you joined a company you correct the
interview and now you joined a company
so after joining a company you will be
provided an ID card right so suppose you
are the suppose you are a database
developer so you have provided the ID
card and after that you will be
allocated a seat and now you want to
show the ID card at the time of sitting
into a seat so for accessing the
resource you need to provide the ID card
and the security guard will verify if
you are entitled to sit in that seat and
you need to show the ID card to the
security guard and if you are accessed
and if you're entitled to access a
particular resource it means now you are
authorized so now we want to move on to
the process of authorization so the user
will be provided a token after the
authentication process and here comes a
new chapter of the authorization now
after the user needs to sit on their
bench now user needs to show their ID
card which has provided so in this
application we'll be using the token so
to access a resource the user needs to
show a token that was sent during the
authentication so this ensures that the
user is entitled to a source so that's
the complete package of the
authentication and authorization so once
the user authenticates he's provided
token and now to access a resource the
user needs to show the same token that
was sent during authentication so this
ensures and this means now the user is
entitled to a particular resource that
can be protected or a particular
resource and in this application so we
have a chat based application so for
sending and for accessing any chat the
user needs to show back the user needs
to send back the same token that was
provided to the user and now we need to
provide the token so we'll be using the
JWT so JWT is a library it's exactly the
library which is built by the ozero so
JWT means the Json web token so there's
a token which has the Json encrypted
data into it so it is used to encrypt a
payload into a signed token so there's a
signed token in which all of your
payload would be converted into a signed
string that has the permissions or
authorities or some data of the user so
in this application we'll be having a
different requirements like we can send
the ID the email the permissions or
authorities of the user so we'll be
using that but how we need to send the
token to the user so we'll be sending
the token to the user with the help of
the HTTP only cookies so HTTP only
cookies are a type of web cookie that
comes with a special security attribute
so they are same like the web cookies so
you can move on to the browser
application tab to see all of these
cookies but the HTTP only cookies comes
with a special security attribute that
restricts the cookies from being
accessed by the JavaScript so you cannot
access those cookies by the JavaScript
code inside the web browsers and this
prevents the xss attacks as well so what
are these attacks so suppose you have a
form inside a web application so suppose
there's a hacker and it moves on into
your form and it enters Some Like It
enters some script into your form so
that string would be then validated by
the JavaScript so the JavaScript doesn't
have full security so it gets validated
by the JavaScript so suppose the hacker
add the alert statement so then you will
be seeing an alert statement on the top
of the window through the form and
that's how if the user or like if the
attacker can show the alert they can
also steal your JWT token from the
cookies so that's why we use the HTTP
only cookies so these are not visible by
the JavaScript so these are only enabled
by the exos with credentials property so
once we make the HTTP request so these
cookies are automatically sent to the
backend and once the backend receives
the cookie it will validate the cookie
like it will validate if the token was
valid or not and that's how we can
prevent this attacks and that's how we
can create the fully authenticated and
authorized
application so let's move on and let's
just Implement all of that so if I want
to summarize that what exactly will be
happening so this is the authentication
process the user would be authenticated
and then he would be provided a token
right so we'll be having the token with
the HTTP only cookies so these are the
signed cookies and then the user would
be provided the HTTP only signed cookie
along with the jwd token so we'll send
the exess token directly in the form of
cookies and then the user would be
having those cookies now the user have
the cookies and the user have the token
inside the cookie and and now let's see
that how to access the protected
resource over there and to access a
particular resource or a protected
resource so the user send back the same
cookie and then we verify like if and
then we verify like if the cookie
matches and if the token is validated or
we can check if the Cookie doesn't
matches or if the token is invalid and
on the basis of that we'll be moved on
and we'll provide and process the
request and that's how the
authentication design works so user
needs to send back those cookies and if
the token is valid then we'll process
the request for further requirements
suppose like sending the chat to the
user but if the token was not valid if
the token was expired or if the Cookie
doesn't match then what do we need to do
so we need to the operation of the
user so that's how it's going to
work and now we want to implement that
as well so let's move on and let's just
Implement that so here after the user is
logged in then we want to send those
cookies and then we want to send the jwd
data inside the cookies let's move on
and let's just create a new file inside
this inside the utils so we can move on
into I think inside the utils folder and
then we can create a new file that could
be we can have the token we can have the
manager dot we can have the TS so we
have this file over there which will
manage all of the tokens so here we'll
create a function that will create a
token from the data so let's move on so
we can have the export we can have the
create we can have the token over there
so that should be equals to a function
and inste this we'll be requiring the ID
of the user we can have the ID that
should be in the form of the string we
can have the email that should also be
in the form of the string and then we'll
be having another property which is
expires in so after how much duration
the token would be expired so we can
have the expires we can have the inov
there and that would be a normal Arrow
function so this is a normal Arrow
function then we can create a new token
so first we need to get this data the ID
and the email so what we can do so we
can have the cons we can the payload
over there so that could be an object
and the object can have the ID the
object can have the email
and after that let's move on so after
that we need to move on so we can have
the cons we can have the token so now we
want to create a new token so con token
would be equals to now we want to use
the jwd package so it's already there if
you have followed my tutorial so let's
move on to the top we can import JWT
directly from we can have the Json web
token and then now what do we want to do
so here we can have the JWT Json web
token dot we can have the sign so now we
want to sign a token and we want to send
the payload so payload that could be we
can have the object so here the payload
would also be required so we have
already declared the payload so that
could be a payload and now we want to
move on so after the payload the second
parameter that we want to Define is the
secret key so there's a key required
inside the hashing algorithms so now the
secret key should be there to sign a
token to encrypt a token so secret key
is like a private key which is used to
encrypt something so we'll be using that
secret over there so we need to move on
to the environment and here you can see
you can already see the JWT secret so we
need to provide the secret over there so
the secret can be any string like that
so it can be any string so this is my
JWT secret and this should not be
shareed to anyone because if anyone has
your JWT secret it means now they can
access your payload data over there now
you have the payload data and inside the
second parameter you can provide the
process over there so inside the second
parameter you can again use process
do we can again use the environment over
there process. environment do we can
have the JWT underscore we can have the
secret now you have the JWT secret and
at the time of verifying the token as
well still you need the same secret
which was used during encryption because
only one private key can be used to
encrypt and decrypt something and then
inside third parameter there are some
options that we want to provide so third
option that we have so the main option
that we want to provide is expires in so
after how much duration the
the token would be expired so it can be
any string so if you hover over the
expir thing you can see you can provide
like suppose that can be 2 days 10 hours
or 7 days so the chat gbt how the chat
gbt works so it moves on and it expires
in 7 days so we can provide the same
validity we can have the seven days and
after the 7 Days the token would be
expired and that's how it's going to
work so now we have the token and now
the final thing that we want to do is
now we want to return the token over
there so now we have the token inside
the string you you can see now we the
token as the string now we can just
directly move on to the users controller
over there right and here now what do we
want to do so here we need to follow
process so after the password was
correct then what we can do we can just
create a new token over there so we can
have the cons we can have the token over
there so that should be equals to what
we can do we can have the create
token we can use the create token we can
provide data so like we can have the ID
we can provide the ID of the user that
could be the user dot we can have the ID
over there like we can have the
underscore ID dot we can have the to
string over there and after that the
second property that want to provide is
the email of the user so we can have the
user dot we can have the email property
then inside the third parameter we need
to provide the 7D so that could be the
7D over there so now let's move on to
the create token so here you can see we
haven't used the expir in so that could
be the expires in only like that and I
showed you just for the example so now
we have the expir in and everything
should work perfectly fine over there
and it is of type of this string over
there let's move on to the users
controller so now we have the token
inside this format inside the string now
the final thing that we want to do is
very very simple and now we want to send
the token in the form of cookies so
that's how it's going to work so let's
move on so here you can see after we
have the token over there we want to use
a cookie and how we can set the cookies
directly from the back end to front end
we need to use a package which is a
cookie passer so it is already there
inside the package.json so cookie passer
is used to send the cookies from the
back end to the front end let's move on
to the appts which is the main file and
here we want to add the middleware for
using the cookies as well so after the
express. Json we can have the app dot we
can have the use so that should be
equals to we can have the cookie passo
so here you can see now we have the
cooki passord and here you can see now
we want to provide the secret key as
well for the Ki so we can use the secret
key
again we can move on to the environment
we can provide the secret key of the
cookie that could be again any secret
that we want to provide so here we have
the cookie secret now we want to provide
the secret to this as well we can have
the process do environment dot we can
have the cookies secret over there we
have the cookie secret and now you can
see now we have the cookie secret as
well and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine over there like this now
we have the cookie secret and now we
want to move on again to the users
controller
and now to send the cookie to send the
cookie from the back end to front end we
use the response variable we can have
the response and in set the response we
have the cookie over there we have the
response. cookie to set the cookie right
and now we want to provide the name of
the cookie name can be we can have the O
we can have the token over there we can
have the Au token and then inside the
second parameter we need to provide the
value so value could be the same token
that we have so value should be the
token so if you just use the respon
cookie now what will happen is the
cookie would be created inside the
browser and then we want to provide some
options object as well so inside the
third parameter there are the options
that we want to provide so first
parameter that is we want to provide the
path so where could be the cookie stored
so the path should be weaken of the
slash so inside the root directory of
the cookies we want to show the cookies
then we can move on the second parameter
could be weaken of the domain so as of
now we are working inside the Local Host
so we'll be using the Local Host over
there like this we can have the local we
can have the host because our front end
would also be there inside the local
host for now but if you deploy this
application then this could be your
domain like suppose that can be my
domain like indian.in that could be a
domain and now let's move on let's
provide the third parameter which is the
expires so when the cookie would be
expired so we so you can see the token
validation is around 7 days so cookie
should have same type of validation so
let's create a validation for the 7 Days
let's create the time for that so we can
have the const so we can have the const
we can have the expires that could be
equal to the new date then we can have
the expires to we can have the set date
and that should be equals to first we
need to grab the current date so we can
have the expires to we can have the get
date like this expires. get date after
that we can use plus 7even so after this
date plus 7 days now we'll be having the
expires property and the same property
could be used here instead of the
expires over there inside the expires
and that's how it's going to work and
after that we need to add the HTTP on
flag so we can have the HTTP only that
could be equals to again that could be
the true then we can use the signed as
well so one so now we want to sign the
cookie as well so we can sign the whole
cookie so we can have the sign that
should be equals to the true so the sign
would again reencrypt the cookie inside
the sign format so now we have this
cookie and everything should work
perfectly fine this time and now what do
we want to do as the next step so after
creating these cookies so now once the
user moves to the login now we want to
remove the cookies of the user as well
so suppose if the user logs in again so
now first we want to remove the previous
cookies of the user and then we want to
set the current cookie so for that we
can have the response or we can have the
clear cookie like this we can provide
the name of the cookie we can have the
name like this we can have the JWT we
can have the aut token over there and we
should store these names inside the
constant so we can move on to the util
let's create a new file that could we
can have the constants like that
that could be constants TS so that could
be equals to con we have
your cookie we can have the name over
there we have the cookie name that
should be equals to we can have the Au
token like that and we should export
that as well we have the export con of
the cookie name so now let's move on so
we have the users controller now that
should be equals to the sponsor. cookie
we can have the cookie name over there
like that we have the cookie name and
the same should be used here as well
inside the token it should be the cookie
as well we have the cookie name and now
that's how it's going to work and that's
how it's going to work now we have the
clear cookie and and here we need to
provide additional step as well and the
additional step that we want to provide
here that could be we can move on we can
have the HTTP only that should be again
equals to the true then we can move on
we can have the domain that should be
again we can just use some same
properties like that we can use same
properties like the domain and these
things over there we can use these
things over there like this so we have
the HTTP only true expir is not required
the domain and the local host and the
sign are required and we want to part
the path as well so we can have the path
that should be equals to slash so it
will clear the cookie of the response of
the user and that's how it's going to
work and after that now what do we want
to do so we want to do same thing once
the user signs up as well we can copy
and then we can paste that here as well
after the user has been saved and that's
how it's going to work over there we can
add the comment as well we can have the
store
we can have the create token and store
cookie so we can have this code over
there and that's how it's going to work
over there you can see this was very
simple for creating this cookies and
that's how it works inside the modern
application and inside this application
we are not required to use the refresh
token as well because here the cookie
can be stored for 7 days and after 7
Days the user needs to relog in and
that's how it
works so now let's try it out in the
postman as well well so in the postman
the cookies can be visible but only in
the browsers you can see those cookies
that the cookies are being set or not so
after this Postman testing of this login
function now we'll be moving on to the
front end so now before doing anything
else now we want to move on to the front
end and now we want to design the login
system of the front end as well so let's
move on so here we have the James
test.com let's just click on the send
and after that you can see the message
is we can have the okay but inside the
cookies we have one parameter you can
see now we have the O token over there
we have the O token we have the value so
you can see this is the value of the
token you can see that was our token
over there you can see it is encrypted
in a string we have the domain of the
Local Host we have the path of the slash
we have the expires as well you can see
current date is 15th of September and it
will be expired in Friday 22 September
hi everyone and welcome back so now we
have completed the login controllers the
signup controllers over there you can
see now the authentication functionality
is working fine and we have tested that
in the postman as well and now before
moving directly into the back end into
the chats and all we want to create the
front end as well in which first we'll
be having the login system so that the
user can be logged in and then we'll
dive into the chat B into the chat GPT
apis so let's move on so here we have
the back end folder now what we can do
so first we can move on to the terminal
and we can stop this terminal over there
you can press controll C on your system
and command C on the Mac OS and now you
can move on you can create a new folder
that could be for the front end over
there so we can have the front end and
after that we can have the CD into we
can have the two dots over there to move
back to the root directory then we can
have the CD change directory and it
should be to the front end and after
that we can just move on and we can
initialize a new react application and
for using the react application here
what we will do so we'll move on and
we'll use the V so this time we'll be
using the V over there and you can also
use the plane react as well the next JS
as well but here the V is super
preferred for our application so that's
why I will be using the V so after that
we need to move on and we can click on
the get started and it is completely
fast as compared to the normal react or
the nextjs application so wheat is very
fast so that's why I have chosen the
wheat for this application so we can
click on get started and after that we
want to create a new vat application so
you can use pnpm Yan or the npm so I'm
using the npm over there so what we can
do we can copy this command then we can
move on to the application or what we
can do so we can delete the front end
folder directly from this and we can
just create the front end application
directly from the whe so we can again
move back to the root directory and then
we can run the command of the uh npm we
can paste that command as well we can
paste that command so npm create V at
theate latest we can hit enter and after
that it will ask you a couple of
questions as well like what's your
project name and here we can provide the
front end so now we can hit enter after
that we need to select the template that
we'll be using so we'll be using the
react so we can hit on the react now we
can choose any framework as well so both
typescript and the JavaScript are
preferred so in this application we can
use the typescript as well and the S swc
is the latest in which we'll be having
the F reloading so we can hit on the
typescript plus s swc and then after
that now we can move on and then again
we can move on to CD into the front end
and now we can just install all of these
dependencies and as compared to the next
JS of the react it um what happens is it
has very less dependencies to work with
so you can see now inside this you have
a very less dependencies as compared to
react you can see you only have the
react and the react Dom inside that and
now let's move on so we can have the npm
install to install all these
dependencies on our end and now let's
wait till it install all that and that
we can get the overview of this app U so
till then we can get some overview as
well of the front end so in the public
directory we can uh provide some or we
can locate some assets which are
publicly available that could be some
logos that could be some images audio
files video files over there then we
have the source directory in which we'll
be having our code files we can have the
assets so in the assets you can also use
some images which are not publicly
available but you can use some assets
like SVG icons or you can have the
normal assets then you can have the CSS
file for a component you can see you
have the app. TSX which is the main file
over there and here you can see what you
have so you are just using the state you
have the count variable over there and
you can see this is a boiler plate then
we can move on to the index. CSS here
are some root stylings over there and we
can directly move on to the main so this
is the entry point of your application
of your V application and from this
application you create the root and if
you are coming from normal create react
app or the nextjs so this is a main app
file so in the app router we have the
page. T6 the main page and inside the
normal react application with the create
react app template it is the index. TS
file which is renamed as the main and
from here we are rendering the app
component and now let's move on so here
we have the app component and you have
some environment files over there and
you can see now we have the es link file
which allows you for the linting
purposes sometimes there are vulnerab Le
in your code so it fixes all of them and
we have the G ignore file in which once
we will publish our application to the
GitHub so once we will push all of our
code so this will just ignore all of
these files that could be some log files
some non modules some disc folder of the
build up application there can be some
envirment files as well so it just
ignores all of these files and it
doesn't include these files over there
and all of the files except this will be
pushed to the GitHub then we have the
HTML file in which we have the div ID
equals to the root and where all of your
react application converts to the
JavaScript and then inject it into the
root and there you can see now we have
the package.json which contains some
information about our application that
could be some commands like there would
be a Dev command there would be the
build command there would be the L
printing the preview and all then you
have the readme file which contains the
readme of your application you can also
change the readme as well then you have
the configuration for the typescript so
here you have some configurations over
there for the typescript and there we
have the TS config node over there for
running some backend quote over there
because it is made on the Node envirment
then we have the V configuration file as
well in which there are some
configurations to run the react over
there and now the packages are now
installed and now we can move back to
our application
so now we can run this application as
well we can run the command of the npm
we can have the Run we can have the dev
to open the development server and there
you can see in just 235 milliseconds now
your development server is open and it
is open on the Local Host Port of 5173
so we can control and click on that and
there you can see now we have the vend
react application ready and there you
can see it is very fast as compared to
the nextjs and the react and now let's
move on so here we have the ball plate
code we can mutate the ball plate code
code as well we can move on to the app.
TSX we can remove everything from it so
we can just remove the full fragment
over there we can just render here the
main over there like this we can have
the main and inside that we can render
the hello world over there to have this
starting project for us now we can
remove the state variables as well we
can remove all of these variables
because these are not required in our
application so let's save all of that
and let's move on to the application you
can see now we have the hello world but
maybe there are some CSS Styles over
there uh you can see inside the index.
CSS you have some CSS Styles so you can
remove all of these Styles and then what
you can do so you can provide the HTML
over there you can have the HTML and you
can have the body and inside that what
you can do is you can just provide the
margin that should be equals to we can
have the zero like this so there you can
see now you do not have any Styles
overridden into that and after that we
need a different font family for this
application so what we can do so we can
move on to the Google fonts over there
so we can move on to the Google fonts
and from there we can search some fonts
like what we can do so first you can
move on to the fonts and then you can
just search for the
Roboto slab over there so we have the
Roboto slab and then we need this Styles
over there we can choose the styles of
around 300 400 500 600 and we can have
the 800 so they are already there and
then what we can do so we can move on we
can have the work sense as well so we
can have the
work uh we can have the sense over there
so this is also great font for us so we
can choose them and we need the 400 for
the work sense and that's how it's going
to work and I think we can use the
normal 400 with that so we have the
regular 400 we can click on that and
after that you can see after you click
on that then you will be seeing the use
on web and then you can select the
import over there and then you need to
copy the full import statement you can
copy the import statement and then you
can move back to your application CSS
file the root CSS file then at the top
of your CSS file then you need to paste
that and there you can see that's how
it's going to work and I think the uh I
think the swap is there for this so
maybe something was wrong with that
display equals to swap maybe it's okay
and now let's move on so inside the root
CSS file now we can provide some more
classes like that so we have the margin
zero we can the padding that should be
we can have the Zero from all sides we
can have a different background for our
application that should be we can have
the 0 51 01 C we have a darkish
background for our application we can
have the color of the text and all of
the components that should be the white
we can have the font family the default
font family for our application could be
we can have
Roboto slap or we can have the siif if
we do not find that so that's how it's
going to work over there and now let's
move on so there you can see now what we
need to do so now if we move on to the
application once again you can see now
we have the hello world and we have a
different font family for us so let's
move on let's just select this element
you can see now we have the font family
of the Roboto and that's how it's going
to work over there and after that now we
want to install a couple of dependencies
as well that we'll be using so for
styling this application we'll be using
the material UI so we can move on to the
mui
docomo and library for with the react
for with the GSX so we can use these
components so you can see there are a
couple of components that are completely
free to use and if you write these
components directly from scratch it will
cost you a lot of time you can see there
are some accordian components the
temperature range you can have these
buttons layouts and all of the things so
you can say it has a great design
library and it is the most preferred
react Library anywhere in the world you
can see all of the major companies are
using that as well we can click on the
get started and then you can just move
on to the installation and after that
now what do we need to do so you need to
move on you need to copy this command
over there you can paste that here so
you can stop this terminal for a couple
of minutes you can add these
dependencies over there and after the
material UI after the styling then we
need the icons as well so for the icons
we'll be using the react icons over
there so here we have the react icons so
we can copy this over there so we only
need the name of the react icons that's
it we can paste that here and after the
react icons now we can move on so we
need the routing functionality as well
so we'll be using the react router Dom
for the routing we can move on and the
current version is 6.16 so you can use
that and after that now I think the
current version is 6.4 now let's use
that so what we need to do so we can
just have the
react router that should be we can have
the Dom we so here we have the react
router Dom and I think we need some
notifications as well within this
application so that should be we can
have the react
hot toast so that's a lab ready for the
notifications so you can move on to
their website and there you can see
there are two options so if you click on
make me a toast you can see you will be
having this type of notifications as
well so let's move on and let's just use
all of that so here you can see this is
the name of the package react H toast
then you need to enter that as well so
there you can see there are a couple of
styles over there there are a couple of
dependencies that we'll be using so now
we need to hit
enter and after that now let's move on
so now let's move on to the main. txx
and have some like a couple of theming
as well for the material UI so let's
move on let's create a new theme for our
material UI so we can have the cons we
can have the theme and you can use the
pre- default theme of the material UI as
well it doesn't matter now you now oh
sorry here we'll be creating our round
customized theme so we can have the
create
theme so we need to use the create theme
directly from uh imported from the
material and here we only want to use a
theme for the typography so we can have
the typography over there and inside
that inside we can use the font family
and that should be we can have the
Roboto slab over there and after that
we'll be using the siif as well after
that if we do not find that so we can
have this s and after that we have
multiple variants for the typography and
for all of these variants so we can use
a color and that should be we can have
the white over there so we have a white
color for all of these variants and now
we have the customized theme for the
material UI uh and now we need to move
on so here after this strict mode then
we can just render theme as well for
this so we can use the theme provider
directly from the material UI so here we
can use a theme provider like this so we
have a theme provider and then we need
to use the theme provider over there to
wrap the app component with the theme
and let's wrap it up and let's provide
the theme as well so it needs a theme
object and that's a theme and after that
now let's move on so let's set the
routing functionalities as well within
this application so you need to import
something from the react router Dom so
you can import something from reactdom
and something would be equals to what we
need to do so you need to use the
browser router which adds the
functionality which adds the wrapping
functionality inside the browsers to use
the routing over there inside the react
application and it should be there
inside the top again so we can have the
browser router and everything should be
wrapped between them over there from the
theme provider till here so you can wrap
all of that so that's how it's going to
work now we have the browser router and
then we have the theme provider and
after that now we need to move on so now
we can move on to the app. TSX so here
we can just register some of the routes
of the application as well so let's move
on so here we have the main tag over
there and after the main now what we can
do so we can remove all of that and then
we can just render here the header of
the application so what we can do so
inside the source we can create a new
file that could be we can have the
components over there and inside the
components we can create a new component
that should be header. TSX over there we
can rent the RF fce for the default
setup and default ball update code for
that we have the RFC and after that
let's create another folder inside the
source that could be we can have the
pages so this should contain all of the
pages all of the routes of our
application so let's have the home as
well we have the home. TSX over there
and we can again use the RFC for the
default B plate code then we can move on
so after that we can move on we can have
the chat do we have the TSX over there
chat. TSX and it also contain the ball
plate code then we can move on and then
we can have your the login page as well
login do we have the TSX over there that
should contain the normal login page we
can have the sign up as well we can have
the sign up do we have the TSX over
there sign up. TSX it should also
contain the RFC for the default ball
plate code then I think there could be
another page in which if their
application so like suppose if the user
enters a route which is not registered
inside the this application so we need
to register that route as well so that
we can show a not found page so we can
have the not found do we have the TSX
over there in which we can show to the
user that this route is not registered
inside this application so we have the
RFC for the default bate
code and now we can move on so again we
can move on to the app. TSX so here we
have the main and inside the there would
be very simple things so first we need
to renter the header of this application
here we have the header over there so
inside the header after so that should
be a self closing component so here we
have the header and after that now we
need to register all of the routes so
first we need to import something from
the react rout Dom so we can import
something from we have the Rea rout Dom
and something that we need to import
would be equals to we need to import the
routes so all of the routes should be
there inside the routes so that is a
container for all of the routes and to
enter each route and to register each of
the route you need to use a route
component so it's a container and it's a
route so let's move on let's add these
things over there so here we have the
routes over there that's a container and
that should be equals to we can have the
route and inside that we can provide the
path so path of this should be we can
have the Slash and we can have the
element as well element should be we can
have the homepage so we can have the
home so home should be the inside the
slasher out and after that let's copy
let's paste it so that should be we can
have the login as well we have the route
of the login and the element should be
there for the login here and then we can
again move on we can again copy that we
can have the route SL we can have this
sign up and this signup should contain
this sign up route over there sign up
page then we can again move on we can
register a new route that should be we
can have slash we can have the chat so
this should have the chat page and the
element that we want to render should be
the chat over there the chat component
and if there is any route which which
are not there inside these routes which
are any route after that so that's how
it's going to work so there you can see
now we have a couple of routes inside
this application and that's how it's
going to work we have around six routes
over there and that's how it's going to
work and now let's move on and now let's
move on to the header and now let's
build the header of this application as
well and for using the header we'll be
using the component of the material UI
so inside this we should be using the
app
bar we can have the app we can have the
bar and we can import that directly from
mui as well we can import app bar over
there directly from we should have the
mui SL material SL we can have the app
bar like this so here we should be using
the app bar over there like this and the
app bar is just like a basic nav tag
with some predefined Styles and after
that below that we can use a toolbar as
well so we can have the toolbar we can
again import something from mui and that
should be equals to we can have the
toolbar like this so that should have
the toolbar and it should should also be
imported directly from the toolbar
package so here we have the toolbar over
there and if you don't know about these
components you can always move on to the
material UI you can just search like
what is the app bar over there so there
can be the app bar API you can move on
to the demos as well so here you can see
that's how you can use the abar over
there you can just directly import it
from the mui material or you can use
that with this as well and if you want
to see the demo you can see that is the
app bar you can see some predefined
styles are there that could be some M
Bar and inside that you have some tool
bar as well to add some structure of all
of these elements you can see these are
the basic navigation bars inside modern
world applications so let's use that as
well so after the app bar we have the
toolbar and after that now let's move on
so inside the app bar now what we can do
we can provide some customized Styles as
well we can use the SX prop for that we
can use the SX props and before
providing the customized Styles let's
just run this application and let's just
see all of that in action as well we can
have the NP PM run we can have the dab
over
there and after that let's move on so
you can see it is again there inside
this you can see now we have the app bar
and that's how it's going to work so if
I open the 110% over there you can see
that's how the app bar is going to look
and after that you can see there are
some predefined Styles let's provide
some Styles so what we can do so we can
have the BG color for providing the
background color and that should be we
can have the transparent then I think we
can Pro the position so position should
be what we can do so we can have the
static over there of the top then we can
have some shadows as well I think there
are no many Shadows with that yeah there
are some Shadows so what we can do we
can also remove the shadows as well if
you want to remove that so you can have
the box shadow that should be you can
have the none over there so now there
won't be any Shadows over there inside
the top and after that let's move on so
inside the toolbar you can provide a
couple of styles once again you can
provide the SX prop and that should be
you can have the dis display of The
Styling that should be equals to the
flex so that's a container and it should
have the display Flex to render all of
the items over
there and the first thing that we going
to do is now we need to render the logo
of this application so here what we will
do so we will provide our own logo so
we'll use our own logo with that so
let's move on and after that now let's
move on so inside the components let's
create a new folder that could be we can
have the shared like that we have the
shared and inside that we can use the
logo do we have the TSX over there and
let's design the logo as well so inside
the logo it should always be like a link
so once we click on the logo now we
should be moved on to the homepage and
for that we need some images as well so
we'll be using the images for the logo
as well so let's move on so from my
GitHub repository you will find the
images as well so you can move on to the
public folder and there you can see you
have some images of like the robots the
nuclear openai robot and the vvg so you
will find these images as well and now
let's move on so here you can see now
for providing the logo let's move on to
the shared logo component and here let's
just use something so here what we can
do so we can just use the div here
directly we can provide the style over
there so we can have the style prop for
the div we can provide the display that
should be we can have the flex over
there we can have the flex for the
display we can use the margin from the
right that should be we can have the
auto over there like this so we can have
the margin that should be from we can
have the right over there that should be
Auto then we can have I think we can
have align the items that should be we
can have inside the Cento then we can
have the Gap and that should be we can
have something around we can have the
five or we can have the eight pixels
over there for the gap between them so
first we'll be having the like we can
have the link and inside the link we'll
be having the image then we'll be having
some text so what we can do so we can
use a link directly from the react a Dom
so we can use a link component from the
re Dom we can import that import the
link from we have the re Dom so that
should be we can have the
link and we can render it over there and
we can provide the two prop as well for
the link so where it's going to navigate
so we can have the two that should be
equals to we can have the Slash and
after that let's move on so inside the
link we can first render the image over
there the source should be we can have
the open AI do have the PNG over there
we we can have the alt that should be
again we can have the open a like that
so credit goes to the open a and after
that let's move on we can provide some
width as well width should be somewhere
around 30 pixels would be enough for
that I
think and after that we can have the
height as well height should also be
somewhere around 30 pixels over there
then we can have some class names as
well we can just invert the color of
this we can have the image inverted like
that we can have the the image inverted
over there so we'll be having the
customized classes as well and after
that now we have the link over there and
after that let's move on let's have the
typography as well so we'll be using the
typography so it is a component of the
material UI so you can get this directly
from the mui you can import the typ of
graphy from you can have the
mui mu materials SL we can have the
typography like that and you can render
that over there you have the typography
and inside that you can provide some of
the customized styling like you can have
the SX prop that should be what you can
do you can have the display so inside
the display what do we need to do so we
need to provide some responsive sizes so
what we can do so we can provide an
object inside the display so inside the
display for the MD screen sizes like for
the medium screen sizes we want the
display should be we can have the block
the normal display but for the small
devices for the small screen devices we
can have the display for the none and
then we can have for the extra small
devices as well for the extra small and
that should be what we can do so we can
have the none over there so only for the
medium and upper devices there should be
the display and inside the small and the
extra small the display should be the
none so it should not be visible and
after that what we can do so after this
display then we can provide some classes
like we can have the margin from the
right so you can use the short end
property of the Mr and that should be
you can have the auto over there for the
margin right then you can have the font
weight as well so weight of the font
should be you can have the 800 over
there for the weight then you can have
the text Shadow as well Shadow should be
somewhere the shadow should be somewhere
around you have the two pixels 2 pixels
20 pixels of the blow and you can have
hash tri0 color for the shadow so these
are some customized styles for the
typography and insert that now what you
can do so you can render this pen so
first letter of your or like the first
word of your logo should have the
different styles so you can have the
style over there and that should be you
can have the font size that should be 20
pixels over there 20 pixels so first
letter should have a different styles
you can have Theon like that you can
have Theon and then after that you can
use the GPT you have the GPT like that
so that's how you can provide some of
the Styles over there so first let's use
the logo over there so let's use the
logo inside the header so here we have
the logo over there and that's how it's
going to work so there you can see now
we have the logo then we have the M GPD
and that's how it's going to look and
after that let's move on let's just
provide some of the classes for this as
well for the images and all and after
that and after providing the Styles I
think the typography should be there
after the link so it should be there
after the link like that and that's how
it's going to work so there you can see
now with the man GPD and that's how it's
going to work and after that now what do
we want to do over there so you can see
now we have the classes for the image
inverted so we can move on we can uh we
can enter this class as well so we can
move on to the index. CSS we can provide
this class like the image inverted and
then now what we can do so we can use
the filter for the images we can have
the invert for this so if you provide
the invert of the 100% now if you move
back to the application you can see now
it looks great so here you have the M
GPD and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine and instead of providing
the 8 pixels for The Gap let's use this
for the 15% and that's how you can see
now it looks great over there so now it
seems working fine and now we and move
on to the next things and now we need to
render the navigation links over there
but there would be some conditions for
rendering these links so conditions can
be when the user is logged in then we
want to show the link for go to chat to
show the chat window to the user and
there would be the link for the log out
and if the user is not logged in then we
want to show the links for the login and
the sign up so there are two scenarios
and we also need to handle these two
scenarios as well because inside
multiple parts of this application we
need the user is logged in or not so for
that we need a overall State Management
inside our application so that in any
children component in any component we
can get the state like if the user is
logged in or not so what we can do so we
need a state management so we need the
overall State Management which can wrap
the full application with the state so
either we can use the Redux so Redux is
a great choice for that but there's also
alternative with the react itself which
is the context API so context API is
very handy and it's very easy to
implement as compared to the Redux so
here we'll be implementing the context
API and it is currently most easy thing
that you can do so what we need to do so
for implementing the context inside our
application so it will benefit like you
can get the state you can call some
functions from the context from anywhere
within this application so inside the
source you can create a new folder that
could be you can have the context over
there so here we have the context and
inside that we can create a new file
that could be we can have the we can
have the
context do we have the TSX so from the
context there would be multiple
functionalities like what we will do so
we'll provide the whole user object in
which if the user is logged in then
we'll be receiving the details of the
user like the email the ID the name of
the user and then we'll be having the
logged in property like if the user is
logged in or not so we can store a
Boolean variable so that we can identify
if the user is logged in and then we can
have the functions as well for the login
and the log out to identify or just call
the functions directly from the context
of the user from the authentication
context so from this context now let's
define all of that so first thing that
we want to do is we want to just move on
and we want to import
something is we want to import something
that should be equals to from and that
should be equals to the react and
something that we want to import would
be the context so now let's move on so
we need to import a function which is a
create context so let's move on so so we
can have the cons we can have the O we
can have the context over there so here
we have the O context over there and
that should be equals to we can have the
create context over there so it should
be equals to the create context and now
what do we want to do so initial value
that we can provide should be equals to
the null but here we are using the
typescript so we should provide the
value as well so what we can do so we
can Define the type for it as well we
can have the type that should be we can
have the user off like that and that
should be equals to a normal type and
here what do we want to do so first
property would be is logged in that's it
and that property would be a Boolean
property so we can have the Boolean like
that then we can move on we can have the
user property as well so we can have the
user and that should contain a separate
user type so we can have the type that
should be we can have the user and we
can also declare these types in a
separate file as well so right now I'm
just using it inside a context so here
let's just use that and let's just
Define that here so after the user then
you can move on so type user user should
contain the name of the user that should
be you can have the string user should
contain the email as well that should be
again the type of we can have this
string and the user type should be
having the type of the user and
sometimes if the user is not there then
the user could be equals to we can have
the null oh sorry it should be only the
single string so now that should be
equals to the null after that there
would be the functions for the login and
the log out let's define the function
for the login so that would be a normal
function but here uh we would be having
the promise for that so here we would be
returning the promise over there and the
promise could be we can have the void
because we don't want to return anything
from the promise so that's why it should
be the void but inside the login
function there would be parameters like
we can have the email so email could
have the type that should be we of the
string the password that should be we
can of the type of like it should be the
string and then we have a login function
we can have the sign up as well so we
can have the sign sign up over there
like this and sign up should also have
something around we can have the name we
can have the
email we can have the password over
there so we can have the password as
well like this we have the password that
should be in the string format and then
finally that will be having the log out
function as well so we'll be having the
log out and it should also be the
promise because once we move on to the
log out now we want to remove the
cookies so if the cookies are being set
by the back end and if the cookies are
the HTTP only cookies it means those
cookies can only be removed by the back
end so once we click on the log out
we'll be just uh clicking a button of
the log out and then the back end would
remove the cookies like the
authentication cookies with that so that
should again be we can have the promise
that should be we can have in the white
State because we don't want to return
anything over there and now the create
context should have the property so
create context should have the user o
like that the type of the user or like
this or it should be the user o or it
could be the null like this so now we
have the O context and now what do we
want to do now we want to create the
provider for this context as well so we
can have the const we can have the O
provider like this so we have the O
provider and the provider would wrap all
of the childrens's inside that so we
have the O provider that should be
equals to a normal react component and
inside that we would be accepting the
children property we would be having
some children over there CH run over
there like this and it should have the
type the type should be we can again
have the react node like this we have
the react node like this for the type
and after that now let's move on so
after this now we want to handle a
couple of States as well within the
provider so how we can do that so first
state that we can have is the U state so
we can have the snippit like first we'll
be having the property of the user uh we
should be having the property of the
user I don't think what happened to that
we have the user then we have the set
user like this and the state should have
the value of the user property like this
the user or it could be the null as well
so we can put the user or the null
should be there in set the state and
initial value should also be we can have
the null like this so it should be the
null and after that now let's move on so
after that let's have the state for the
authentication oh sorry we can have the
login as well so we can have the logged
in over
there like we can have the
is logged in like this and we can have
the set is logged in and we can provide
here the state that should be we can
have the false and after that now let's
move on so now we have the is loged in
property as well now after we refresh
this application so after once the user
moves on into the application so we
should run effect code as well we should
run effect code we can run a function
and we can verify if the user's cookies
are still there and if the cookies are
valid then the user doesn't need to be
logged in so we can Define the effect
function for that as well we can have
the effect so as of now we won't be
implementing that so first we need to
implement the login functionality then
only we want to do that so this effect
function has only to do that what do we
need to do inside that so we can have we
can have the fetch if uh if the
users cookies are
valid then um we can have to then skip
login so we should have this code inside
the fact so we would be writing the
logic after we write the implementation
of the authentication then we can move
on so then we should be having the
functions for the login as well so we
can have the login like this so that
would be equals to a function and it
could be asynchronous as well so we
should write the asyn over there and we
need the parameters as well so we need
the same parameters like the email and
the password we can copy we can paste
now we be having the email and the
password so as of now we just need the
definitions now we have the login then
we can have for the log out as well or
we can have the sign up like the sign up
it should contain in this properties
like we can have the name email and the
password let's Implement that over there
name email and the password and now we
should be having the log out function as
well so we should be having the log
out uh log out and here we won't be
requiring any properties over there we
don't need any variables over there and
that's how it's going to
work and here it should be the email
instead of the emay and then here is it
should be I think the email over there
like this and now we have defined all of
these properties and now now you can see
now we have created the provider and now
the provider needs to set those values
as well which should be used by the
children's so for that let's define the
value cons we can have the value like
this so that should be an object it
should contain the properties like user
we can have the is logged in over there
it's logged in then we should have the
properties of the login function as well
the log out function as well the regist
or we can have the sign of function as
well so there could be a couple of
functions and now the final thing that
we want to do is now we want to return
all these state code over there now we
want to return all of the states to the
children components so we can have the
return we can have the Au
context dot we can have the provider so
now we have the Au context do provider
and that should contain the value so
value is wrapped within this component
the value should be equal to the value
and after that now we want to render all
of the children's inside that so which
should be the children like this so
that's how it's going to work so you can
see it was very simple so Redux
implementation looks a bit complicated
like sometimes you need to add the
middle WS for these functions like the
asynchronous code you need to add some
middle ws and all but you can see it was
very simple and it contains and the
context contains the definition with the
react itself not anything else so you
can see now we have created the provider
now we have the context now you can see
we have the type definitions as well and
now the final thing that we want to do
is now we want to create a variable now
we want to create the context that
should be used by The Childrens so this
is just the provider now we want to
create the context that should be used
by The Childrens so we can Define any
names like we can have the cons use or
or anything like that we can have the or
directly as well so that should be
equals to now what do we want to do we
can have the use context we can have the
use context directly and the context
should be the Au context and that's it
with that you can see now we have the
context oh sorry it should be function
as well it should be a use off that
should be a function which can contain
all of these properties like this and we
should export it as well we should have
the export cost we can have the use all
and now we want to just export this as
well we want to export the
authentication provider as well so what
we can do we can have export cost we can
have the Au provider so that's how it's
going to
work and after that let's move on so you
can see now the initial property of the
a logged in is false now let's move on
to the the main file the main. TSX now
just render all of that so first at the
top we would be having the Au provider
we should be having the Au provider and
now all of the child components so the
main component the main children is the
browser router but the properties and
values from directly from the auth
provider directly can be used in any
component in any child component now
let's move on so if you want to see the
demo you can move on to the app
component you can have the lock
statement or either you can have the use
o like this you can have the use O then
you can have the loog lock should be we
can have the use o dot you can have the
is logged in property like this do is
logged in like this so use do you can
have is logged in like this so suppose
if you save and if you move on to the
application if you move on to the
inspect now you will be seeing three
infos like you have the false over there
because now the authentication is false
now the user is not there inside this
but if we switch to the true if we
switch it to the true like this this so
you have the true over there you can see
now you will be having the true over
there and that's how it's going to work
uh sorry and it can solve a couple of
problems like the prop dring as well so
suppose if you create the authentication
here directly uh inside the app. TSX
then you need to send it inside all of
these children components so it can
create some issues because there can be
a uh there can be very difficulty to
manage all of these props and data over
there so that's why we can use the
overall application state within the
context or we can also use the Redux as
well so they are all similar and now
let's move on so now we can have a
conditions like if the user is logged in
or not so we can again move on we can
switch this to the false and now we can
move on to the header so let's close all
of these files Let's Move On Again into
the component slh and here now what do
we want to do so here we want to render
all of these links and for rendering the
links we can create a separate component
for that so we have the shared link we
have the shared for the link as well
like this so we can have the link dot we
can have the TSX over there so I think
we can change the name we can have the
nav link like that we can have the
navigation link over there and that
could be a separate component now we can
just render the RFC for the default uh B
plate code now inside the nav link we
should accept a couple of properties
like where the user want to go so we can
Define all of the types as well so we
can have the type for this we can have
the props and that should be equals to
we can move on we can have the two that
should be inside the string we can have
your the background as well we can have
a a different background suppose the
button uses this link we can have the
background that should be inside the
string and what we can do and after that
we can use the text as well so the text
should also be inside the string that uh
that what we want to wrap between the
link what the text should be visible in
the link then we can have the text we
can have the color as well we can have
the text color and that should be the
text color again should also be inside
the string format so we need the string
and after that we can also require the
on click function as well so we can have
the on click over there like this so it
should contains if someone wants to
define the on click some can use this as
a button as well so we can have the on
click function as well and this is
basically used for the log out as well
suppose we want to remove the state as
well so that should be for the log out
and after that so that should be for the
logout and after that we can use the
promise here as well so that should be
promise in a white form so we don't want
to return anything and after that we
should render here a link so we only
need to return the link component
directly from we can use from react. Dom
we can import the
link directly from we can have the Rd
react rou Dom slash I think the link is
named export so we can use the link over
there and now we want to return the
link so here we have the link over there
and inside the link we can have the two
prop so we haven't defined the props
over there so which should contain the
props like that should be equals to we
can have the props type over there the
two should be equals to we have the
props or you can have the two then what
you can do then you can move on you can
Define here I think you can that's it I
think then you can move on and what you
can do you can provide the text between
them so the text between them should be
what you can do we have uh props do we
can have the text and then we can
provide the customized Styles as well we
can have the style so that should be
equals to what do we want to do so we
can have the background like this so
background should be we can have the
props do we can have the BG then we can
move on then we can have the color as
well the text color that should be again
we can have the props or we can have the
text color like this we can have the
text color and that's how it's going to
work so here you can see now this is a
customized component of the navigation
link and it would be very useful now
let's move on to the header so here you
can see now we have we have the toolbar
sorry now we have the toolbar over
there so here it would be very simple so
now let's move on to the so what should
we do now so now we should have a
condition so after this now what we can
do so after this we can renter a box or
we can rent a normal div from the mui
and after that what we can do so inside
this div we can just wrap a condition so
first we need to define the reference
for the authentication context so that
we can get if the user is logged in or
not
we can get the cons we can have the O so
that should be equals to use o so now we
have the reference now what do we want
to do so here we should have a condition
like if the O DOT we have the user or we
can have the O do is logged in it means
now the user would be logged in then we
can render a different styles over there
and if it is not logged in then we can
do different things so that would be a
GSX tag the empty tag and here as well
will be having the empty tag so once the
user is logged in then what we can do so
we can just use here the navigation link
inside the shared components so that
should have the navigation link so there
should be two links over there so both
should have the first one should be
having the BG so if the user is logged
in then we can provide a customized
background color that should be we can
have the hash d0 we can have triple FC
we have the background color then we can
move on so we can have the two that
should be we can have slash we can have
the chat then we can move on we can have
the text then we can have go
to we can have the
chat then we can move on we can have the
text color so that should be again I
think we can have the black for the text
color for this we can have the
black and after that now we have the
second navigation link as well so we can
put the BG so here BG would be different
so we can have has we can have the 51
538 f for the background color we can
have the foreground color as well so for
the foreground color we can just use the
text color as the
white then we can have the two that
should be what we can do so we can have
the log out
here we can have the log out over there
then what we can do so we can have the
text as well that should be a ween of
the log
out and two should not be the log out
two should be the home page because once
the user locks out now we want to move
on to the home screen as well and now I
think that's enough but here we would be
having the on click function as well so
inside this navigation link we would be
having the on click and here now what do
we want to do so we can have the o. we
can have the log out so we will be
referencing the log out function
directly from this and after that if the
user is not logged in then again we can
render a different links we can just
copy this one we can just paste that
over there think what do we need to do
so now we can remove that so I don't
have any code with me right now so what
we can do so we can just copy these two
n Tex once again so the color
combination should be same so now we
have these things over there so we can
remove that and that's how it's going to
work and now what do we want to do so
now you can see now we have the
background should be same the two should
be equals to now what we can do we can
have the login and the text should also
be we can have the
login
text should be the login the text color
should also be the black and here we
would be having the same background and
the forground color the two should be
equals to we up this sign up and that
should be we can have the sign up again
like this we have the text of the sign
up and that's how it's going to work I
think that's enough for that right
that's enough but if we move on to the
application once again you can see now
we have all of the data you can see now
we have the login and the sign up but
now we want to provide couple of Styles
as well to the navigation link so let's
move on let's just Implement that so we
can move on to the nav link we can
provide the class names for that we can
have the class name and we can use a
customized class name we can use some
CSS styles with that so what we can do
so here so we can have a style that
should be we can have the nav link over
there like we can have the nav link so
let's Implement these Styles as well so
we have the nav link let's Implement
these Styles so we can move on to the
root CSS file or or sorry if you want to
create a customized CSS file then it's
up to you but I would be defining it in
inside the index so that should be we
can have the nav link and inside there
know what do we want to
do so it should contain I think the font
weight that should be somewhere around
600 we can have your the text transform
that should be upper case then we can
move on we can have the margin right
that should be somewhere around 10
pixels margin from the left as well 10
pixels we can have the padding that
should be 8 pixels top and bottom the 20
pixels from left left and right then we
can have the Border
radius that should be somewhere around
10 pixels with that so we have the 10
pixels then we can have the text
decoration that should be we can have
the none over there then we can have the
font family I think font family is
already defined in the typography then
we I think yeah it is defined then we
can have the lettera spacing as well
that should be somewhere around one
pixels that's enough now we have the
naving and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine over there now
let's move on to the nav link so now
let's move on to the application you can
see now it looks like this now we have
the login we have the sign up we can
click on the login now we are into the
login page we can click on the sign up
we are into the sign up page and if the
user is logged in so we can move on to
the context so suppose that's the
true so there you can can see now we
have the go to chat and then we have the
log out and it means everything seems to
be working perfectly fine over there
once we click on the log out we enter
the home once we move on to the go to
chat now we into the chat page so
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine and now what do we want to do is
the next step so now we are moving very
fast I know but let's move on so we can
have the false again we can move on to
the login now let's define the login
screen as well so now let's design the
login screen as well so let's move on so
I'm into the paint and now we want to
see that how it's going to look so let's
move on so suppose it's a web page so
suppose it's a web page so inside the
left corner of the web page inside the
left side so there would be two sides so
inside the left side there would be an
image so we can render the image of a
robot and inside the right side we can
just render here the form so inside the
right side sorry we can render here the
form here so we can just render the form
so there can be some items onto the form
so that could be the login and the sign
up as well so we can have name email and
the password for the sign up but if
there are the mobile devices so inside
the mobile devices the style will look
different so inside the mobile devices
what we're going to do is we can just
Rend so suppose that's a mobile device
so it's a mobile device so we only need
to render here the form so we need to
make the responsive designs so we'll be
only be having the form over there and
that's how it's going to look so let's
move on so insert the login now what do
we want to do so first I think we just
focus on the
design so here inside the return what we
can use so we can just use the box from
the material UI so box is just like a
component of the material just like the
div so we can import something that
should be at theate M material and it
should be we can have the box over there
so we have the box and inside that what
we can do so we can Pro the SX prop or
what we can do so the SX is not required
we can give the width that should be we
can have the 100% for the width we can
have the height as well and it should
also be we can have the 100% and what we
can do so we can have the display as
well display should be again we can just
use the flex so we can just put the
display Flex we can have the flex that
should be one as well and now what we
can do so we'll be dividing the flex
into two parts so suppose that's your
another box so we'll be using the box
for the image and there could be another
box for the form so both will be having
the display of the flex so the first box
let's move on so we can have the padding
that should be eight we can have the
empty margin from the top that should be
again uh it would be the eight we can
have the display as well so display
should be we can give the responsive
designs we can have for the MD screen
sizes for the medium the display should
be we can have the flex but for the
smaller devices for the SM the display
should be we can have the SM the display
should be we can have the none and same
happens with the extra small devices as
well suppose that's a device Maybe it
has very low width we can give the
display that should be we can have the
none and after that let's move on so
here we have the box and here you can
see inside that we can just render an
image so there would be an image we can
give the AI robot. VN PNG AI robot dot
we have the PNG over there for the
images we can get the alt we can have
the robot over there like this and the
credit goes to the respective owner so
we have this image then we can move on
we can have this style that should be
around 400 pixels would be enough for
the style over there for the width so
let's move on we can give the width that
should be 400 pixels that's how we want
to do that so you can see now you can
see it's looking great you can see now
it's looking great and now you can see
it's working fine so there you can see
if we have defined the padding G it
means 8 into 8 times so if we Define the
padding of the one over there in the
material UI the by default spacing is 8
pixels so 1 is equals to the 8 and if
you have defined the 8 it means it is is
8 into 8 which is 64 pixels for the
padding and all and now let's move on so
here you can see the first one has been
completed now let's move on to the
second box as well so inside this box
there would be a normal things and this
box would contain the form so let's move
on so here we can Pro the display that
should be again we can use the flex over
there I think we can put the flex
property as well so inside this Flex
what we can do so for the extra small
screen devices we should have the full
Flex which is the one which we have
defined over there
and for the medium devices we can have
the flex that should be somewhere around
we can give the 0.5 so that's how it's
going to work and after that let's move
on let's provide a couple of more props
like we can move on uh we can Prov the
justifi content that should be inside
the center of the screen we can Pro the
Align
items that should be again inside the
center of the screen I think that's
enough then we can move on we can put
the padding as well that should be
somewhere around two over there we can
have thek margin from the left that
should be we can have the auto over
there like this we can have the auto we
can have the margin from the top and
that should be somewhere around 16 so we
have these designs over there and now
inste that now we can render a form so
let's move on so we can just render here
the form directly from the HTML tax and
here now what we can
do so here we can provide a customized
styling for that so styling could be we
can just for the margin that should be
we can have the auto from all of the
sides then we can have the padding as
well so we can the padding that should
be around we can give the 30 pixels of
the padding from all of the sides the
Box Shadow should be there somewhere
around we can give the 10 pixels
horizontally 10 pixels for the vertical
Shadow 20 pixels we can give for the
blow we can give hash triple 0 for the
color of the Shadow then we can get the
Bott radius so that should be somewhere
around 10 pixels would be enough for
that and then finally we can give the
Border here so we can have the border
that should be we can use the none so we
don't need to use the Border and after
that now what can we do so inside this
form we can just renter another
container so we can have a container
over there like suppose that could be
equal to box and here we can provide a
couple of more styling like again we can
have the display like this so we can
have the
display again we can use the flex then
we can move on we can have the flex
direction that should be we can have the
column over there and final thing that
we can use so we can move on we can have
the justifier to the content that should
be inside the center of the screen so
that's how it's going to work and after
that let's move on let's just add the
elements over there so the first thing
that we want to add over there that
should be equals to the typography so we
can the typog graphy over there because
we want to add a so what we can do we
can add a login text over there as well
we can use the import something that
should be from we can have the material
and I think we can just use the
typography directly from this as well we
can use the
typography and then here we can again
use the typography over there we can
provide a Styles like we can give the
variant that the H4 so with the variant
you can provide like what variant do you
need of the HTML so here we would be
needing the H4 we would be having the
text align that should be inside we can
have the center over there so I think we
can give the padding as well padding
somewhere around two would be enough
font weight that should be
600 and that's it I think we can give
the color color is already defined
that's it now what we can use so we can
just move on we can just provide the
login like this so if you save and if
you move on so let's see how it looks if
we move on so there you can see now we
have the login and that's how it's going
to work and now after this typography
now we can move on and we can define an
input tag so we'll be using a customized
input tag for this application because
if you move on to the mi.com so if you
move on to the material UI so they
provideed different type of input
components you can move on to the
material UI you you can just search for
the text field so this is the text field
API so you can see if you move on to the
demos of the text field so they provide
similar type of text Fields you can see
you have the color of blue around that
so it is based on the material design
and now let's move on so we'll be using
this type of text Fields as well but we
need to just remove and we need to just
modify the root classes of the text
field so let's move on to the API
section of the text field so let's move
on to the API so you have your I think
uh let's move on so here we have the
text field so we want to move on to the
base classes and here we want to just
customize the base class so that we
should have the white color as per the
theme of our application so let's move
on so I'm going to show you that how you
can do that so here we need to move on
to the components so inside the shared
the text field would be shared so we can
have the
customized input so we have the customiz
input over there dot we have the TSX
over there and now let's define the
component over there like this so we
would be having a different props for
that so we can have the props so that
should be we can have the name so we can
have the unique name for the text field
unique name we can have the type over
there so we can have the type like this
that should be again inside the string
and I think that's enough I think we can
have the label as well yes we can have
the label and that should be equals to
we can again have the string like this
so we have these props for the
customized input so we can also have the
props like this and that should be
equals to the props and now here we want
to return the text field from the
material UI so we can use the text field
we can just move on to the top we can
have the import the text
field uh from we can have from mui
material like this we can have mu
material SL we can have the text field
like this so we can have the text field
over there like this we have the text
field and from there now what we can do
so we can have the name so the name
should be equals to what we can do so
here we can just provide the props
do we have the name over there we can
provide here I think the label as well
the label should be what we can do props
do we have the label for this we can
provide the type as well the type should
be again we can have the props to we can
have the type start we can have the type
over there and now let's move on let's
move on to the login component and let's
just see that how it looks if we do not
provide any style so we can have the
customized input so we can use the
customized input two times over there
and let's provide some props as well so
we can give the type as well so the
first one should have the type of the
email the name should be again we can
have the email then we can have the
password as well sorry we can have the
label as well that should be again we
can have the email over there like this
and after that let's move on to the
second the type should be we can have
the
password we can have the name that
should be equals to the password over
there we should have the same thing for
the label as well so we can have the
label that should be equals to we can
have the password
so if we save and if we move on so there
you can see now we have the email then
we have the password and that's how it's
looking over there so if you move on
again so you can see now if we remove
all of these uh inputs over there so we
have the email then we have the password
so now we want to change that as well so
let's move on and now we want to just
what we need to do so we want to just
inject some classes some styles to the
root classes of the customize input so
we can move on to the text field so what
we can do so it is very simple with the
material UI so first we can Define the
props for the label so we can the input
label props we can give some props that
should be now what we can do we can have
the style so I think the label already
have the Styles like this so you can see
if we move on to the password you can
see now we have the blue color for that
so we can give the style that should be
we can have the color that should be I
think we can give the white so now you
can see now it has resolved the issue
and that's how it's going to work and
after that let's move on so you can see
now we have some outlines as well so
let's move on so now we can have the
input props as well so we can have the
input props and inside this now what we
can do so we can again use this style
and we can provide a customized style
for that we can give the width of this
that should be we can have the 400
pixels or if you want to accept the
width then you can use that as well so
here we have the 400 pixels then we can
move on we can the Bott radius that
should be somewhere around I think 10
would be enough for that then we can
move on we can have the font size
so that should be somewhere around 20
would be enough for that and now the
final thing that we want to do the color
should be what we can do we can use the
white so there you can see now we have
these things over there and everything
seems to be working fine over there and
we can also provide some margin between
them as well you can have the margin
that should be to the normal so now you
can see now we'll be having some margin
between them and that's how it's going
to work and now the final thing that we
want to change is we want to change the
outline so for changing the outline now
we want to move on we can move on to the
expect and there now what we can do so
we can move on we can just see this that
what exactly are the class names over
there so let's just search with that
over there so um so we would be having
the label as well I think the label has
already fixed that so there is this
class name like mui outlined input not
outline so what we can
do
uh so we have your
mui input base rout
mui so I think we are using the outline
so what we can do so mu input base mu
input form control input tag as this so
you can see we have the mui outline
input so we can copy this class name mui
outlined
input so we can copy and we can move on
to our CSS file index. CSS we can paste
this file over there now we have this
class over there outlined input we have
here the root class as well so we can
move on we can have the root like this
we have the root dot we can have the
mui / the focus here so we have the
focus over
there so this is for the focus and let's
move on so we have the notch outline as
well so you can see you have the notch
outline so let's move on let's copy that
as well till here and M your input again
we can provide the same style for this
as well mui outlin input we have the
notch outline so here now what we can do
so we can the Border color so that
should be we can have the white like
this and it should be important so let's
see how it looks uh you can see now we
have the B color of the white and that's
how it's going to look you can see now
it's looking great over there now we
have the email now we have the password
and there you can see it's looking
great and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine so you can see how we can
just customize the CSS classes of this
as well and the final thing that we want
to do inside the login is now we want to
create a button so let's move on to the
login here so let's create a new button
over there and the button should also be
imported from Material UI so which
should be we can have the button and
after that let's move on so here we can
just render here the
button so the button should be there we
can provide the type for the button that
should be we can have the submit then we
can move on we can provide the SX prop
SX prop should be having we can have the
padding from the X that should be we can
have the two padding from the Y that
should be I think we can give the one
over there we can provide the margin
from the top that should be we can have
the two over there we can provide the
width should be same as the form 400
pixels then we can move on WE the Bott
radius so that should be somewhere
around two enough two is enough for that
we can have the background color as well
so we can give a different background
color we can have hash we can have Z we
can have Tri f see as the background
color as we used inside the navigation
bar as well so after that I think we can
put the hover class as well so for
providing the hover you need to wrap it
inside the strings then you can search
for the hover and then you can provide
the classes so you can have the BG color
that should be we can have the white and
you can have the foreground color color
of the foreground that should be equals
to we can have the black and here now
what we can do so here we can provide
the login like this so we can have the
login do and that's how it's going to
look so you can see now have the login
and if you want to provide an icon as
well after the end of the button it is
very easy so you can just search for the
react icons over there so here so you
can have the login as well here you can
have the login and there you can see
there are a couple of login icons that
you can use and here now what we'll be
using so we can use this as well it is
looking great and now let's move on to
the top and we can import this as well
we can import this icon from react icons
over there slash we can have the io so
here we can use this icon iOS login
let's move on and inside the button
props let's create another prop over
there so that should be End Icon and
that should be equals to this icon over
there we have the
io I login like this and that's how it's
going to look so if you save and if you
move on so there you can see now we have
the login button and that's how it's
going to work so you can see now it's
looking great now we can move on so now
we can move on and now we can handle the
form data as well so let's move on so to
handle the form data what you need to do
so you can see you have provided the
name as the uh you have provided the
name and the password over there email
and the password as the name now you can
create a function and you can use the
form data to get the values without
using any state so you can have the
const you can have
your handle submit like this so that
should be equals to you can have the
function over there there and inside
this you can get the event and to get
the type of the event you can move on to
the form you can have the on submit over
there you can provide this so you can
see you have the event like this you
have the react. form event HTML event
like this HTML form event so let's move
on so let's just use that over there
like you have the reactor form event and
this is the type of the event then first
thing that you want to do is you want to
prevent the default Behavior so that the
browser should not be refreshed
and you can provide the classes over
there like you can have the handle
submit now after that now you can just
create a new form data so you can have
the con you the form data over there so
that should be equals to a new form data
so you have the form data and you need
to provide the target of the form so you
can have the event dot you have the
current Target and that's how it's going
to work and after that you can get all
of the values for the form as well so
you can get the cons email like this so
that should be you can have the form
data dot you can have the get that
should be equals to we can have the
email because you have provided the name
as the email so it works on the name
basis and same for the password as well
so you have the
password and that should be equals to
form data doget that should be equals to
the password now you can log all of
these values as well you can log the
email you can log the password as well
and that's how it's going to work so if
we say if we move on if we move on to
the inspect panel if we move on to the
inspect if we move on to the console so
there you can see if we provide the
Styles over there if you click on the
login then you can see now we got the
Styles over there we have the anadani
test.com then we have the password and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine so now we have the data of the form
and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine and now the final thing
that we want to do is now we want to
login so after we click on the login now
we want to make the API request to the
back end so for making the API requests
we need a package so what we can do so
we can move on to front end once again
we can install a package which is the
exos so exos is used to send the API
request it is used for the communication
with the back end and the front end so
let's install the exos and with the help
of exos we'll be just um exchanging the
API tokens with the back end and with
the front end so let's move on so here
we have the main. TSX file over there
and here now we can set some default
properties of the xos as well so we can
use the xos dot we can have the defaults
dot we can have the base URL so we can
Prov the base URL for this as well so
what's the base URL for the back end we
can have the HTTP we can have the Local
Host the port of we can have the 5,000
SL we can have the API SL we can have
the V1 so that's the base URL and after
that we need to set the base
configurations as well so we can have
the exos dot we can have the defaults
dot we can have the width credentials so
if you use the width credentials so it
will allow setting the cookies directly
from the back end and just exchanging
the cookies with the back end so with
the help of with credentials it will
help you to exchange the cookies so with
credentials that should be equals to the
true so with every request this would be
attached and now let's move on let's
move on into the source folder let's
create a new file for the helpers so we
can have the helpers over there like
this we can have the
helpers and here we can create a new
file that should be at the
API communicator. TS so from this file
we'll be just defining some functions
that can be used to work with the API so
let's move on let's just have the first
function so what we can do so we we can
have the ASN C of function so we can
have the cons we can have the login user
so we can have the user login like this
so from here now we can just Define the
functions which can be used for the
communication so let's move on so we can
have the export course we can have the
login user like this login
user and that should be equals to we can
have the asynchronous arrow function
over there we have the async arrow
function and the param are required like
we can have the email the type should be
we can have the
string password then we can move on so
we can have the cons response so that
should be equals to we can have the
await then we can use the xos package so
we can move on to the top so we can
import the xcos as
well we can have the xcos over
there and it should be imported directly
from the xos package so we can have the
xos like this so await it should be
equals to xos xos start we can have the
post as well so that's a post request
and the URL that we want to Define
should be/ user SL we can have the login
over there like this so that would be
our URL and after that now what do we
want to do is the next step so that's a
post request so inside the second
parameter now we want to provide some
data as well along with it so we can
send some data so we need to send the
email then we need to send the password
as well so these are the data that we
want to provide and now let's move on so
after we get the response then what we
can do so we can move on we can verify
if the response dot we can have
response. status is not equals to we
have the 200 it means if it is not okay
then what we can do so we can return or
we can have the throw new error and we
can send the error message suppose that
could be we can have the unable to login
so that would be error message but if
the response. status is the 20 it means
if everything is successful then we can
grab the data con data and that should
be uh equals to that should be equals to
what do we need to do so it should be
the response do we can have the data so
it should be the weight because that's a
promise so it should be the response.
data and after that the final thing that
we want to do is we want to return the
data over there and that's how it's
going to work and now let's move on to I
think inside the O context over there
inside the Au context so we have the
login function so here we need to use
this function as well so what we can do
so we can have the return or what we can
do so we can have the cons we can have
the data so that should be equals to
await and await it should be equals to
we can have the login user like this we
have the log Lo user and from this we
would be having the data so login user
should be equals to we can have the
email then we can send the same password
over there and after that we will get
the data so we can have verification
check if we have the data then only we
want to do something then what we want
to do then we can move on so we can have
the set user so that should be equals to
what do we need to do so user should
have the email that should be data do we
can have the email and the user would be
having the name as well so we can have
the data do you can have the name like
this so we will be having the set user
like this and then we will be having the
set logged in property as well so we
have the set is logged in and that
should be equals to the true so that's
how it's going to work and after that
you can say everything seems to be
working perfectly fine and after that
now we can move on to the main file
which is a form so let's move on to the
page so what we can do so we can make
this function as an asynchronous
function and after we get the data then
what we can do so you can see uh if you
remember we have installed a library as
well which is uh toast bar so we can
show the toast notifications so let's
move on so again we need to move on to
the main. TSX so we can import something
from that Library so we can import
something from that should be equal to
react H toast and we can import the
toaster so we have here the toaster so
toaster should be there at the root of
your file so here we have the root so it
should be there at the top hierarchy of
your file so that it can add some CSS
and all of the things required to make
the toast so let's move on so after the
Au provider or after the theme provider
then we can use the toast bar over there
like this so here we have the toas like
this and if you want to style some
positions as well you can use the
position so you can have the top right
you uh you can have the top Center like
this so I think we can use the top right
here and everything should work
perfectly fine and now let's move on so
now let's move on to the login and let's
just use a function of the toast so we
can import something that should be
equals to from it should be equals to
react hot toast and now what we can do
so we can have the try catch block so
inside the try now what we can do so we
can first have the const or what we can
do so we can directly use the weight and
here we need to use the context here so
we can have the con we can have the O so
that should be the use Au over there now
let's use the context we can have the O
DOT we can have the login so we can have
the au. login after that we can provide
the email we can provide the password as
well we have the au. login email and the
password and that's how it's going to
work and uh I think there some type
errors like that could be null as well
so yeah this can be null so what we can
do so we can have the S we can have the
string so we can just skip the type
checking we can Pro the S string over
there and after that it will be logged
in so let's use the toast over there so
you need to import this thing over there
you you have the toast so I think you
need to import the toast directly from
the reactor toast so you have the toast
so toast is a function which creates the
toast so you can have the toast do you
have the loading so first we need to
show the loading state so we can have
the U we can have the signing
in like this so we can have the signing
in and after that let's move on we can
provide the second argument that's the
ID so we want to provide only one toast
bar inside this one component inside
this one page so we need to provide a ID
so ID should be same inside all of the
toast that can be for the login as well
that can be for the success as well and
for the error as well so it should have
the ID so we can have the ID that should
be equals to the one like this or if you
want to change the ID that should be for
we can have the login over there like
this so we have the toast. loing after
we are successfully logged in then we
can again use a toast and this time it
should be the success we can have the
signed and we can have the successfully
like this and we can have the same ID
and then if we get any error then what
we can do so we can have the toast to we
can have the error we can have the sign
in again we can have the signing and we
can have the
failed so that's how it's going to work
and we can also log the error as well so
we can have log the error over there
like this so that's how it's going to
work so now we have these things and now
everything should work perfectly fine
but now we want to move on to the back
end as well so if you move on to the
back end so I want to show you one thing
if you move on to the users controllers
you can see you are just sending the ID
over there inside the response you are
just sending the ID so instead of the ID
now what you can do you can just move on
so you can just provide the name of the
user that should be you can have the
user dot you can have the name you can
send the email as well so that should be
we can have the user do we can have the
email so that's how it's going to work
and same thing should be there with the
sign up as well so we can move on to the
sign up that should be the same thing
over there like this and now let's move
on and let's just open the development
server of the back end as well so here
inside this terminal let's move on to
back end so when we can have the npm Run
we can have the dev so now let's move on
so let's see what happens
now
so so you can see Server open and
connected to datab okay so let's move on
so now we want to provide the
credentials so what credentials did we
use so we have used the James at the
test.com we can use the password 1 2 3 4
5 6 so let's see what happens if we move
on to the network so if we just click on
the login so let's see what happens so
there you can see now we are getting an
error which is the course error you can
see it is uh expected because one server
because now you are in the server of
5173 and the back end is running on this
server of 5,000
so one server so if one server make the
request to another server so then that
Server doesn't allow any different
server to make the request so if the
5173 request some data or send some
requests to the 5,000 so 5,000 would not
allow the server to make an entry or to
do something with their server so that's
why we have the course error inside the
browsers and it's the security policy
that every browser has followed so now
we want to Whit list This Server we want
to Whit list around server around domain
with that server so that we should
interact with that API so let's move on
so we can move on to the appts over
there and there you can see we have
already added a package which is a
course you can see this is a course
which will bypass this error so let's
move on to I think inside the app. TS so
what we can do so inside the first
middleware let's just use the course
over there we can have the app. use that
should be we can have the course you can
import the the course as well you can
have the import we can have the course
that should be equals to from it should
be equals to the course like this so
that's how it's going to work and after
that you need to use the course and here
we need to provide some options as well
because here we are using a couple of
security attributes as well so now what
do we want to do so here we want to use
the origin first so what we can do so we
can have the origin we can provide the
origin and the origin can be ar as well
so we can provide the string so that
should be we can have the HTTP Local
Host
the port of we can have the
5173 so this is where our react
application is hosted now and then
inside the second parameter we can
provide the credentials because here we
are exchanging the security attributes
like the HTTP only cookies so we want to
set the credentials that should be
equals to we can have the true so with
the help of the Cod now we can access
This Server only from this domain right
so let's just test it out once again so
let's move on let's just click on the
login again let's just remove everything
remove the console window as well so
let's see what happens if we click on
the login so there you can see now we
have the status of 200 you can see now
we solve the message as well and another
thing that you can see now we are into
the go to chat window and we are into
the log out as well so everything seems
to be working perfectly fine over there
you can say this was okay we have the
200 of the okay request you can see we
are having the cookies as well so if I
want to show you the cookies you can
move on to the application you can move
on to the cookies and from there you can
see now you have the cookie you have the
Au token over there and there you can
see you have the domain of the Local
Host you have the path of the slash you
have the expires property as well and
there you can see you have the size and
there you can see you have the HTTP only
flag as well you have the HTTP only flag
and that's how it's going to work and
after that let's move on and let's just
try to get the cookie you have the
document. cookie so let's see what
happens so you can see document. cookie
is empty string because it cannot be
accessed by the JavaScript but there's
one thing if you just remove the HTTP
only attribute double click on that and
let's just remove that and there you can
see if you run the
document or you can have the
document of the cookie then you can see
now you can get the cookie so you can
see that's not secure so that's why we
use the HTTP only cookies like this so
that it cannot be accessed by the
browser so everything seems to be
working perfectly fine so let's close
all of that and now you can see after
completing the login functionality now
you can see inside the header as well it
has been updated now we can go to chat
and we have the log out functionality as
well and now let's complete the
authentication workflow and let's just
quickly start the chat GPD apis and now
it seems to be working fine and after
that now again we want to move on to the
context of the authentication and if you
remember that we have created an effect
code there it means once the user
refreshes or once the user opens this
application so if the user has the
cookies and if they are valid then we
don't want the user user to be logged in
once again so let's move on so here now
what do we want to do so here we want to
make another request inside the backend
in which we can verify the token of the
user and if the verification token is
successful and if the token is verified
then the user doesn't need to login
again so let's move on so what do we
want to do so we can move on to the back
end and we can move on to the controller
sa so inside the users controller sorry
we can move on to the user routes over
there and here now what we can do so we
can create another route that should be
a post request or that should be a get
request over there and that should be we
can have the login or we can have the O
status like this we have the O we can
have the status over there we have the O
status and here we do not need any data
because here we won't be sending
anything so here we would require a
function so here we require a middle we
function which will be used to verify
the token if the token verification
would be successful then we'll again
move on to the different middleware
function to just validate the record and
to send back the the credentials so
let's move on and it would be very very
easy so let's move on to the utils once
again so inside the utils we have the
token manager so here if we can create a
token we can again create a new function
in which we can verify the token of the
user so let's move on so we can have the
export cost we can have the
verify we can have the token like
this we have the verify token and that
should be a n synchronous Arrow function
and this would be a middle W because now
we would be using the verify token here
inside this routes inside this of status
so let's move on so we can have the
verified token like this so it should be
used here so that's why it would be
requiring a couple of parameters as well
directly from the express it could be
the request that could be the request
object we have the express it should be
the response that should be again we can
have the response over there directly
from the express once again
response uh it should be the response
like this and it should be the next
function as well so that we can move on
to the next function so it should be the
response it should be the next to move
on to the next function over there like
this and now after that now what do we
want to do so now we would be sending
some cookies along with the request so
we would be sending some cookies along
with the request so cookies would be
stored inside the signed cookies so we
can the cons we can get the token like
this so that should be equals to what we
can use so we can have the request dot
we can have this signed cookies because
here we are signing the cookies and we
need to provide the variable name over
there the signed cookies so signed
cookies is an object which can contain
all of the cookies data and again you
can move on to application so you can
move on to the application you can see
here we are storing the O token so we
want the O token cie over there so what
we can use over there so we can move on
we can use the template also over there
and that should be we can have the
cookie name like this so we already have
a parameter so we can get the cookie
name so now let's move on and let's just
log the request over there let's just
log the token but before moving on into
this request so now we should create a
new request inside the front end as well
so let's move on so inside the Au
context or we can move on to the API
Communicator let's create another
request over there it would be a
different request it could be we can
have the check Au we can have the status
like this it could be this request here
we do not need any parameters so this
would be a get request and it should be
user SL we have
the we can have the O status over so it
has the O status over there and after
that now let's move on we don't need to
send any data because it's not required
who and if the response. status not
equals to 200 then we can have the
enable to what we can do we can have
authenticate like this unable to
authenticate and if everything is
successful then we'll be sending the
same data along with the request so
let's move on to the context as well so
inside the context now what we can do so
here we have the use effect code and
inside this what we can do we can Define
another function that could be a SN
function that could be we can have the
check
status and inside this we won't be
requiring any parameter over there let's
remove that and here what we can do so
we can have the cons we can have the
data that should be equals to a weight
and that should be equals to we can have
the check out status over there like
this check out status and now we want to
follow the same steps over there now we
want to follow the same steps like this
same steps like this let's move on if
you have the data then do this or else
what we can do so else it would be same
like what we can do so we can provide
these properties over there and we can
set it over null so we can set as the
null over there so I think it's not
required over there because it would be
run on because it will run only one time
so it's not required over there if you
have the data than this then we want to
do this thing and if we have the data
and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine so now we have this
logged in set user two and everything
should work perfectly fine so now again
we can move back to the users or we can
move back to our token controllers so
now let's make a new request so if we
just refresh the page so let's see what
happens if the request goes or not if we
refresh the page
so let's see what
happens so no the request was not
processed so let's see what has happened
over there let's move on to the homepage
as well and let's remove that let's
click on the refresh once again let's
have I think we can have the fetch
xhr so yes yes yes there was an error
because we haven't called this function
so now we need to call this function as
well so we can have the check status
over there we have the check status over
there like this we have the check status
and let's see what happens if we move on
so there you can see now instantly we
got the token right right so now there
you can see instantly we got the token
and that's how it's going to work so you
can see now everything seems to be
working perfectly fine and now let's
move on to the Token manager so now we
have the token and now the last thing
that we want to do here is now we want
to verify the token so now we want to
verify the token so we can verify the
token by just checking that if the token
has the data if the token is valid then
we can move on to the next metalware but
if the token is not valid then what we
can do so then final thing that we we
can do is now we can just stop this
request we can avoid the request and we
can send the return message and now
let's see that how we can just verify
the token of the user so we can have the
return we can have the new promise so we
can return a new promise uh so here we
are using the promise and it's a void
because we want to verify some
parameters like we can resolve the
promise or we can reject the promise as
well we can have the reject like this so
let's move on so we have the resolve and
the reject and after that now what do we
want to do so here we can also return
one thing we can return the JWT do we
can have the verify so JWT has a
function of the verify which can verify
the token so we need to provide the
token string over there so we can have
the token like this and then the second
thing that we want to do is now we want
to provide the secret key so we can
provide the process. environment. JWT
secret once again so we have the secret
key and after that there is a third
parameter as well which is a call back
in which we will get two parameters
first there would be the error if we get
any error then it would be stored inside
this error and if everything is
successful then we would be getting the
success inside that it would be the
success so now let's move on here so now
let's just verify once again so now we
can verify just simple thing like if
there is an error it means now there was
an error with the request then what we
can do so we can have the reject we can
reject the promise we can have the error
dot we have the message as well but I
think the promise is void so we don't
need the message as as well but it's up
to you then we can move on we can have
the return response or we can have the
status that should be 41 which is
unauthorized then we can move on we can
have the Json over there we can have the
message over there like this or we can
have the
Json we can have the message like
this we can have the JWT or we can have
the token expired we have the token
expired like this if we get an error but
if the error is not there if if we are
successful then we can provide the else
case insert the else now what we can do
so we can just so what we can do here so
it would be very simple so we can set
some parameters in this function we can
set some local parameters for this
request in this function and then we can
use those parameters inside the next
request so it is possible with the
express so what we will do so we'll send
some local variables over there so first
let's have the lock statement we can
have the token
verification
successful we can have the successful
over there like this so
verification like this token
verification successful and then now
what we can do so after the lock then we
can move on so then we can just have the
resolve so we need to resolve the
promise as well we can resolve the
promise and then we can move on then we
can have the response so from this
middle web so this middle W can set some
local variables from the response and
then we can use them from the next
middle wave soch technically it is
possible with the express because you
are setting the local variables directly
from this function and then you can use
that inside next middleware as well so
now we can have the response dot we can
have the locals dot we can send some
data like we can send the JWT data like
this and that should be equals to we can
have the success so all of the data
should be there inside the success so we
will be setting that and then what we
can do so we can just return to next
middle wave so that was the last thing
that now we want to return to to the
next midal W so you can say this was the
final code for this and we want to use
another thing over there like if we
don't have the token like this if we
don't have the token and if the token
dot we have the trim like this we can
have the token do trim is equal equals
to we can have the empty string so then
what do we want to do so now we can just
move on we can just return the response
to we can have the status that should be
again we can have the 41 once again we
can send the Json message once again we
can send the message over there then we
can have the
token
not received like this so we can have
the token not received so that's how
it's going to work and if we have the
token then only we'll be having this
return statement so now let's move on so
here you can see it working great it's
working fine now let's move on to the
user routes once again so we have the
user routes and here what we can do we
can Define another middleware function
in which we can check the authentication
status we can have verify something so
we can have the
verify we can have the verify user like
this so we can have this function over
there and now inside this function now
what do we want to do so here we would
be getting some local variables as well
right because we have seted some local
variables so they can be accessible over
here now inside this now what we can do
I think so first we can verify if the
token was malfunctioned or not so let's
move on so inste the try now what we can
do so so first we can try and get the
user so we can remove this we can have
the await user. find one so now we can
find the user email so email should be
equals to we can have the response do we
can have the locals JWT data like this
do we can have the email so we can find
the user or what we can do so we can
have the find by ID as well because we
are already encrypting the ID as well so
we can have the find by
ID and that should be response. locals.
jwd data that should be equals to the ID
like this so that should be the ID and
after that we can check if we don't have
the user then we can send this message
as well like the user not register or
token or we can have the token wall
function and after that if we have the
user then we can verify like if the
user do we can have the idore ID do2
string if the ID is equals to the same
of the idid that we are getting inside
the response to we have the locals JWT
data like this do we have the ID then
only we want to move ahead so what we
can do here so we can just move on so
then if we are getting this ID over
there so I think we can just use here
this like this if it is not okay if it
is not matching then what we can do we
can send the response. status 401 then
we can send the token and user like we
can send here
permissions didn't match
match like this so we can the
permissions didn't match and you can
also store these strings inside a
separate variable as well and it's also
good option but here let's just complete
this application so now we have two
string and if everything works fine then
now what we can do so if we pass this
validation check if we are coming here
it means everything is working fine then
what we can do so then you can see now
the token should not be created again so
we can remove the token creation code
over there let's remove that and let's
move on so now we can just send the
details to the user so now let's see
what happens so if we move on to the
application if we refresh so now we
should be completing all of that if we
refresh if we move on to the network so
now we are getting the 401 inside the
preview we are getting the user not
registered so that's okay let's just
check but you can see the token
verification was successful let's see
that what exactly is
happening so now here what we can do so
we can lock something we can log the
user dot we can have the underscore
ID dot we have the two string and then
we can just log the response to we can
have the locals do JWT data like this do
we can have the ID so let's see what
happens so let's see what happens here
inside this lock statement so if we
again refresh this you can
see uh what happened with that user not
registered
so that was the error because you can
see now we are running the user login so
now let's move on and that should be
equals to what was the function so we
can have the verify I think we can have
the verify like this so we can have the
verify user like this so let's see what
happens now so that was the error so
let's see what happens this time so
let's move on so if we again refresh you
can see now we are getting the 200 and
there you can see now we are getting the
details as well so everything seems to
be working fine you can see now it is
working great you can see now the IDS
are same you can see everything seems to
be working perfectly fine you can see
now we are coming ahead you can see
everything seems to be working fine and
that's how it's going to
work so you can see now it's working
great over there so you can see
congratulations on completing the secure
back end as well so now let's move on to
the Token manager and remove this logs
as well so just remove these logs over
there because blocks should not be there
inside the production so that's how it's
going to work so now you can see now you
completed that and everything seems to
be working perfectly fine and now if we
refresh the page you can see instantly
we'll be moving on to go to chat and now
finally now let's work with the open and
let's create the chat gbt type
application this
time so the authentication seems to be
working perfectly fine and now we want
to move on and now we want to build the
chat functionality for this application
so before that I want to move on to the
open a platform so now you want to move
on to this and there you can see you
need to click on the GPD so now we'll be
using the GPT models for it so there are
a couple of models for the GPT GPT 4 GPT
3.5 turbo so here what we'll be using so
we'll be using the GPT 3.5 turbo and
there you can see how the chat
completions API work with the open AI
you can see this can be a response you
have the Open chat completion. create
and there you can see that's how it
works so first there would be a role uh
you can define a role of the system that
you are this this you can Define the
name of your model you can Define
anything and then after that you have
the role so first the user so first the
role would be the user and user will ask
a question and we have a question inside
the content property content is actually
the message so we have the content like
who won the World Series in 2020 then
you have the assistant that the Los
Angels and dash dash dash and he has
come up with an answer and then again
you have the role like this you have the
user and then you have the content so
that's how the API works with that and
you need to store all of these messages
to keep the context of the conversation
the context means suppose you ask a
question like who won the World Series
in 2020 and there you can see it has
come up with an answer and now you ask
that where it was played so you need to
store all of these conversations so that
the open AI knows that on what topic you
are discussing with me something so
that's how it works so you need to just
store all of these messages so that the
open AI sees that what exactly the user
is talking about and then give that
answer accordingly so now let's move on
and we have already created the
collection of the user and inside that
we have the chats as well so now let's
work on them so now I want to move on so
we can move on into I think first we can
move on into the back end so inside the
back end we can move on so here you can
see inside if we move on to the
controllers so now we should move on to
the routes and there you can see now we
have the chat routes as well now let's
create another route as well for the
chats so that it should work accordingly
so here now what do we want to do so
here there would be a new route for the
chat so we can have the chat routes
start we can have the post so that would
be a post request in which now what do
we want to do so we'll be having a chat
SL we can have the new like this so we
can have the chat SL new and after that
this would only work so chat routes is a
protected API so we can add that as well
and only the authenticated and
authorized users can access that so what
we can do so after we move on to/ new
API chat slne then we can move on so we
can have the verified token so we can
have the verified token so that we
should uh verify the token of the user
and then only we want to move ahead and
then what we can do so we can define a
controller function from which we can
generate the chat completion for the
user so let's move on to the controllers
let's create a new controller that we
can have
chats controllers like that chat
controllers do we can have the TS and
after that let's define the controller
function for that so we can have the
expert cost we can have the uh we can
have the
generate chat we can have the
completion so that would be equals to we
can have the asynchronous errow function
over there and it would be same like the
users controller so the parameters would
be same like the request response and
the next it should be same
so we have the request it should be
imported from the express response
should be imported from Express the next
function is there in the express and
that's how it's going to work and after
that now what do we want to do so first
now we want to configure the open a so
for that we want to use the open apis so
first we want to configure the open API
with that and for configuration let's
move on so we can define a function as
well inside the utils or we can have the
config we can Define the opening
i p config dots and here we can Define
the function we can have the
function configure we can
reopen hey I like this so we have this
function over there so after that now
what do we want to do so here we can
have the cons we can have the config
like that so that should be equals to we
can have a new configuration over there
a new configuration like this and that
should be we can have the object over
there and now we want to provide a
couple of keys like first we want to
provide the API key for that API key
should be equals to begin of the process
do begin of the environment dot you can
move on to the environment as well you
can see here we have here the API Keys
as well open I secret so let's just use
that so you can copy that and then you
can paste that over there and after that
let's move on so we can have the API oh
sorry we can have the organization ID as
well we can have the organization so we
can have the process do we can have the
envirment dot we can have the open AI I
think we can again move on to the
envirment so that should be open a
organization ID like this so we have
this thing over there it should be event
like this environment like this so now
we have the configuration with that and
everything should work perfectly fine so
here we have the configure of the open
Ai and we can export this function as
well so we can the export const we have
the configure open a that should be
equals to function like this so now we
have this function of the configure open
Ai and now we want to move on and after
that so here inside the generate chat
completion now what do we want to do so
here we need the message from the user
so we want the message from the user so
let's get that so we can have the con
something that should be equals to we
can have the request or we can have the
body like this so from the body we'll be
accessing the message property directly
from the user and now you can see now
what do we want to do as the next step
now we have the message so we should add
the validation as well so let's just
complete one by one so let's move on to
the validations as well inside the util
inside the validators let's copy that
the sign up and let's remove all of that
so we can have the message over there
like this so we can have the message not
empty and we can have the message so we
can have this function over there the
chat completion validator so let's just
copy and let's just use that inside the
chat routes as well so after coming to
the new let's have the verify token so
first verify the token of the user and I
think before verifying the token let's
have the validation so we can have the
validate over there and that should be
equals to we can have the chat
completion valid dat like that then we
should be having the verified token and
then let's move on to the final thing we
can have generate chat completion so
there are a couple of middlewares for
this request because it's a protected
API now let's move on to the chat
completion so here we have the message
now and after that first thing that we
want to do is now again we want to
verify the details of the user so we can
have the cons we can have the user like
this that should be equals to your
weight and that should be equals to the
user we can uh access the user model dot
we can have the find by ID we can find a
user by its ID and directly from the
response dot we can have the locals JWT
data like that dot we can have the ID so
with the help of this now we'll be
getting the ID now we'll be getting the
whole user object and again we can
verify if we don't have the user then
what we can do we can have the return
response to we can have the status that
should be 41 to we can have the Json
like that message like that and that
should be the same message that we have
created so we created the same message
inside the users controller and I think
you should store all of these uh static
strings inside inside something like
inside the constant TS so it's a good
practice so now what we can do so we can
just copy that over there like the user
not register or the token Mal function
we can have the message over there and
after that after we have the user then
what do we need to do is the next step
after we have the
user so then we want to just grab all of
the chats of the user to get the context
text of the conversation so first now
what we will do grab chats of user like
that so grab the chats of the user then
the second thing would be send all chats
with new
one so we'll be sending all previous
chats with the new one to
API so that's how it's going to work so
there are three simple steps for that
send all of the chats with new one to
the open API and then we'll be getting
the
response so there are three steps that
we want to do so now what do we want to
do so first we need to grab all of the
chats of the user so we can have the
cons we can have the chats like that and
that should be equals to we can have the
user dot we can have the chats dot we
can have the map so we can map through
all of the chats of the user so inside
each chat there would be a role property
so there would be a role and there would
be a Content as well like this so there
would be the content like that and you
already know that how the role and the
content works because each chat message
has a role and the content property so
we have the role and the content after
that now what do we want to do and we
can just return the same thing over
there like this the
role and we can have the content so with
the help of this now we'll be having the
array of the messages with the role and
the content inside that now we have all
of the messages of the user and then now
what do want to do so this is the static
message of the chats okay then we can
have the chats like that we have the
chats do push the latest message so
we'll be pushing the latest message to
the chats and inside that we'll be
having the content and that should be
equals to we can have the message like
that the latest message received from
the user and the role that we'll be
having should be we can have the user
like that so the role should also be the
user should always be the user and we
have the chats like that and then now
what do we want to do so here we are
just storing all of the chats inside the
static array as well inside the static
array inside just and this array is just
for the memory purpose so now we want to
store the chats inside the main user
object as well so let's move on so we
can have the user model dot we can have
the chats like that we have the chats
dot we can have the push like that so we
can have the push so we can have the
chat. push and now what we can do so we
can have the content that should be
equals to we can have the message and
then what we can do so we can have the
role as well so we can define the role
so that should also be we can have the
user like that so we can have the role
of the user so that's how it's going to
work so now we are grabbing all of the
chats of the user and there you can see
we have the chats and now the Second
Step would be now we want to move on so
now we want to move on and now we want
to send all of the chats to the open API
so let's move on so now we have the
configuration of the openi right then we
can have the cons we can have the config
like that so that should be equals to we
can have the configure open a like that
so we'll be having the configuration
with that and what we are sending from
it so we are not sending anything so we
should send here the config like that so
we should send the configuration
directly from it now we can move on into
the chat controllers once again now we
have the configuration over there and
after that let's move on into that so we
can have the
const opening I like that we can have
the const open Ai and that should be
equals to we can have the new open AI
like that the new open AI like
that so now we want to use the open a
API so let's import that so import
something from that should be open a
like that and import you need to import
the open a API like this so this is a
class for the open API you need to
import that so you have the open AI like
this API and now we want to provide the
config object so now we want to provide
the configuration over there and now we
would be grabbing the open a complete AP
AP with that so with the help of this
now we have the complete open API and
now the final thing that we want to do
so now we can make the request to the
open AI so we can have the cons chat we
can have the
response we have the chat response and
that should be equals to now what do we
want to do so we can have the await then
we can move on so we can add the open AI
like this we have the open AI I think we
can have the create chat completion so
we have the create chat completion and
instead that we want to provide an
object so now what do we want to do so
we want to provide the model so which
model do we want to use so we'll be
using the model of we can have the GPT
and make sure you have the same spelling
so GPT we can have the
3.5 we can have the turbo like that so
we can have the GPT 3.5 SL we can have
the turbo and then we can move on so we
can have the messages like that so we
can have the messages so that should be
equals to the chats array so that would
be equals to the chats over there and
that's how it's going to work and now
you are getting the type error as well
so what you need to do so the chats are
so after that you can provide the type
and donation as well you can have the as
you can have the chat completion like
that you can import type as well so you
can have the chat completion so you have
the request message like that and that
should be equals to you have the same
thing over there chat completion request
message array like that and now you can
see now you won't be having any type
error because now the messages knows it
is accepting the same type of arguments
like that and now after that now what do
we have so after we get the chat
response then we would be getting the
full chat the latest chat as well and
the latest chat is being stored inside
this so if you move on so you can see
response choices zero message and the
content so that's how you can get that
so you can have the note JS as well
completion. choices z. message. content
so let's move on so what do we want to
do so we can have the user dot we can
have the chats dot we can have the push
so we can push to the chats of the user
and that should be equals to we can have
the chat response dot we can have the
data dot we can have the choices dot we
can have the latest which is the zero
and Dot we can have the message like
that so that's how it's going to work
and the message contains the completion
response message it means role and the
content so that's how it's going to work
and after that the final thing that we
want to do is now we can move on so now
we can save the users chat array as well
so we can have the weit over there that
should be we can have the user dot we
can have the save so we can save the
user so that's how it's going to work
and let's move on so we can have here
like this and now what do we want to do
is the next step so now after we have
all of the chats of the user then we can
again we can have the return response we
can have the status that should be we
can have the 200 it means everything
worked successfully then we can have the
Json messages over there the Json it
should contain the chats like that the
chats should be we can have the user to
we can have the chats like that and now
that s is going to work and there's
another thing you can see and that s it
will work and everything should work
perfectly fine and there's another thing
that we haven't used the TR catch block
over there and it's very important here
so what do you want to do so we can have
the try catch block so all of this code
should be there inside the try so it
should be there inside the try block and
inside the catch if we get an error then
what do we want to do we need to send
the response back to the server to the
front end so inside this we'll be
sending the message we can have the
message we can
have we can have this something when we
can have the wrong like that and we
don't know that what exactly is the
error so we can provide this as a Servo
error over there we can have the 500 for
that and we can log the error as well
inside this so we can log the error and
that's how it's going to work over there
so now you can see now the backend
operations with the chat completion is
completed so trust me it is completed
and now we need to move on to the front
end and now we need to design the UI for
this and after we build the front end
now we'll be testing this API directly
with the front end so let's move on so
here now what we can do so now we can
again move back to the front end over
there let's just close the back end
let's just move on again to the front
end so let's move on so here you can see
now what do we have here so inside the
chat page now we want to design the chat
page so now let's work on the chat for
end so let's move on so here you can see
now we enter the chat. TSX and here now
we have discussed about the layout now
we want to design that so first thing
first now what do we want to do so first
we can just provide here a box so we can
just use a box from the material UI so
we can have your box
and it should be imported directly from
the mui so we can import something from
we can have from mui material over
there like that and now that should be
equals to we can have the box and now we
can provide a couple of styles using the
SX prop so the display could be we can
have the flex over there we can have the
flex that should be we can have the one
over there and then we can move on we
can have the width that should be we can
have the 100% of the width then we can
move on we can have the height as well
that should be 100% so it should have
the full width and height we can have
the margin from the top that should be
three and I think the Gap should also be
the three between them so that's the
parent container of the div so that's
the parent div over there and now what
do we want to do here so it should
contain the sidebar it's not exactly the
sidebar but we'll be showing some
details of the user during the sidebar
now let's move on so we can have another
box container over there it should again
contain the SX prop then we can have the
display so here the display should be I
think for the medium devices what we can
do so we can have the flex and for the
small devices we can remove that so for
the small devices we can have the excess
that should be we can have the none and
same for the MD as well that should be
we can have the none over there and
that's how it's going to work and after
that I think it should be the SM so for
the SM as well it should be none so
after that this box should be there and
inside that we can again use here I
think a box over there inside this so we
can have another box for containers then
we can have the SX prop for that then we
can use a
display that should be we can have the
flex then we can move on we can have the
width that should again be the 100% of
the parent container the 100% of the
parent then we can move on we can again
have the height so this time the height
should be somewhere around 60 viewb
height and that should be enough then we
can have I think we can have the
background color as well so we can
provide some background color and that
should be we can have the RGB that
should be 17
29 then we can move on so we can have
with it 39 like that so we have this
background C for that so if we save and
if we move on to go to chat so here we
would be having that window over there
and now after that now what do we want
to do so inside this box uh I think
after that we can provide some border as
well so we can have the Border radius
like that and that should be somewhere
around what we can do so we can have the
five for the bottle radius and then we
can have the flex Direction sorry so it
should be inside the column basis
because there would be a couple of items
then we can have the MX that should be
we can have the three like that MX
should be three from all of the sides so
this is the container in which we'll be
displaying the Avatar of the user so we
can the Avatar like
that so Avatar should be imported
directly from the mui
material so here we have the Avatar and
after that let's just use it over
there and inside the aatar now what do
we want to do we can have the SX prop we
can have the MX that should be we can
have the auto over there so it should
contain inside the center and then we
can move on we can the margin from the Y
that should be somewhere around two BG
color that should be begin at the white
over there and then we would be having
the foreground color that should be we
can have the black over there and the
font weight should be we can have the
700 so that's how it's going to work and
inside the aatar now what do we want to
do so here we would again be getting the
user profile user o profile so let's
move on so we can have the cons o so
that should be equals to what we're
going to do so
here so here sorry what we have we have
the use Au over there like that and here
now we want to grab the first and the
last letter the first word of the first
name and first word of the last name so
we can have the O DOT we can have the
user dot we can have your the name dot
we can have the zero
so let's see how it looks so if we save
and if we move on if we refresh the
page I think there was an error with the
back end so let's run the back end as
well and
PM run we can have the dev so let's see
how it looks
now so let's move on again let's just
refresh it once again so there we can
see now we are getting the James and
after that now what do we want to do so
we can grab the last name as well so
here is the person name and then we can
add another string then we can have the
O I think we can have
a o dot we can have your the user
property once again dot we can have the
name dot we can have the
split dot we can have the split dot we
can have with the um with the space then
we can have the second letter and it
should contain the first word of that so
let's see how it looks now so so you can
see now we have the James and the
Marshall and that's how we can do that
so it's a temporary thing it's like a
jugar in Hindi so that's how it works so
now let's move on as the next step so
now what do we want to do so I think we
and I think we can just provide some of
the margins between them there should be
some margin between them so after that
now let's move on so let's just complete
that as well I think the RGB color is
not there it was not implemented so
that's why we were seeing that so you
can see now we have the color and that's
how it's going to look
and after that now what do we want to do
so after that we could have the
typography after the Avatar so we can
have the typography over
there so we can have the typography over
there so it should be imported directly
from this the typography and now let's
move on so inside the typography we can
provide a couple of more classes like we
can have the SX prop it should contain a
couple of things like we can provide the
MX that should be we can have the a over
there for the MX then we we can move on
then we can have the font family so here
we should be having the different font
family work sense like that and inste
this type graphy and what we can use so
we can use you are
talking to our chat
bar like that so now you have this thing
over there that you are talking to a
chat Bo and that's how it's going to
work and after this typography then
again you can move on you can create
another typography over there you can
have another typography you can copy and
paste but this typography would have a
different thing I think so we can have
the MX Auto it would be same then we can
have you I think we can have the margin
from the Y that should be somewhere
around we have the four padding should
be somewhere around three so inside this
what we can use so we can add a line so
you can add this line over there like
you can ask a question related to
programming uh you can have the
knowledge business advises education Etc
but avoid sharing the personal
information so that's how it's going to
work so you can see now it looks like
that and that's how it will work and
after that now let's move on so here you
have this thing over there so that's how
it's going to work and after that now
let's move on so now we have this
typography and after that below that we
would be having the button as well so
below that we would be having the
button I don't think what happen to the
Auto Imports over there because it's not
working for me so it should be the
button over there
so it's a button over there so now we
should be using the button from the
material UI once again so button could
be what we can use so we can have the SX
prop like that and here now what we can
do so we can have the width that should
be 200 pixels for that then we can move
on we can have the margin from the Y
that should be we can have the auto over
there so it should be the auto then we
can move on we can have the color of the
text that should be the white then we
can move on so we can can the font
weight like that and that should be
somewhere around we can have the 700
over there then we can move on the
bottle radius so that should be
somewhere around we can give the three
and again we can move on we can have the
MX that should be we can have the auto
margin from the X and I think that's
enough or we can have the BG color as
well so we can have the BG color and
that should be we can import the red
color from the material UI so we can
move on so we can import the color
Shades as well from the material so you
can import like that you can import
something from you can have the mui
material so mu material SL we can have
the colors and you can import the red
color over there like this or you can
just use the red directly like this so
you can have the red and you can just
use the red over there to save the space
inside the final bundle so we have the
red and inside the red now what we can
use so we can use the
500 color or we can use the 300 color
for the red so we can have the red do we
can have the 3 like that and after that
now what we can do so we can have the
hover as well so we can have the hover
State and inside the H now what we can
use so we can have the BG color that
should be we can have the red again we
can have the Red Dot we can have the a
140 I think we can have the A40 for that
so if we save it if you move on so there
you can see now we have the button and
after that now what do we want to do is
the next step then we can move on so we
can have the clear
conversation
because we were having a button as well
of the clear conversation now we have
this button and that's how it's going to
look and after this now you can see this
was supposed to be on to the left side
but now we will be adding another box
container over there so after this now
we would be having another box container
over there now we can have another box
so inside this box now we would be
having some Styles over there like
inside this box we would be having some
Styles like we can have the SX prop that
should be we can have the display that
should be we can have the flex over
there and then what we can use so we can
have the flex over there that should be
inside an object for the MD the flex
should be 0.8 and for the extra small
the flex should be somewhere around one
and same for the small as well the small
and after this now what do we want to do
so after this we can just write some
typography about the model name that
we'll be using the typography should be
there so I think we can again use the X
prop it should contain the text line
inside the Cento and then what we can
use so we the font size that should be
40 pixels of the font we can just use
the color that should be we can the
white over there then we can move on we
can the font family I think font family
should be default for that then we can
have the margin from the bottom should
be two like that so that's how it's
going to work then we can the model that
should be we can have the GPT 3.5 to
turbo like
that so if we save and if you move on so
there you can see now we have the model
GPT 3.5 turbo and that's how it's going
to look and after that now what do you
want to do so after that we can have
another box container so I think why the
styling has mismanaged so we need to see
that why this is happening over
there so I think uh inside this we can
have the display so after this we can
provide the flex properties for this as
well so I think yeah we should provide
the flex properties so after the display
then we can have the flex so that should
be somewhere around 0.2 for that we can
have the flex
direction that should be we can have the
column like that so now you can see now
it looks great over there now it's look
great and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine over there you can see
now it's looking great over there and
now you can see now with the model GPD
3.5 turbo I don't think why it's not
moving on into the center because now we
want to provide the
width that should be 100% like that
still so instead we can use the MX of
the auto and that's how it's going to
work so you can see now it's looking
great and after that now what do we want
to do after the typography now we want
to render the actual chats over there so
we can have the chats over there so
inside this box we can again render the
SX prop we can have the SX prop over
there and we can use the width
that should be again we can use the 100%
of the available space then we can have
the height that should be 60 viewport
height then we can move on so we can the
Bott radius so that should be somewhere
around we can have the three over there
we can have the MX that should be we can
have the auto over there for the
MX then we can move on we can have the
display that should be again inside the
flex box again we can have the flex
Direction over there that should be we
can have the column over there and then
we we can have the Overflow like we can
have the Overflow that should be equals
to Scrolls so we can have the scroll
Behavior but the Overflow X would not be
visible should not be visible so
overflow overflow wax shouldn't be
hidden like that should be hidden and
then we can have the smooth as well we
can have the
Overflow Behavior like
that we have the scroll Behavior that
should be equals to we can have the
smoooth like that and that's how it's
going to work again you can see now we
are coming with this site so we want to
fix this display as well after the width
so we can remove the width and instead
we can have a I think we can have the
flex
Direction inside it should be the column
we can have the padding from the X that
should be somewhere around
three so here's the error so we have the
error of the smooth so that's how it's
going going to work over there like that
so if we save and if you move on so now
we should be having the scroll Behavior
as well and that's how it's going to
work and then we can have the
Overflow why as well and that should be
be have the auto like that so now it
should not be visible on the initial
scroll and that's how it's going to work
you can provide the font weight of the
600 as well and it will look great and
after that now what do we want to do so
after that now we want to render all of
the chats of the user so inside this div
now we want to render all of the chats
but here we do not have any chats of the
user so we need to create that and how
we can create that so I think now what
we can do so as of now we can just
render some of the static chats over
there so you can get that directly from
the chat GPT as
well and I think now to render all of
the chats over there we can use the
static chats now to render all of the
static chats let's just move on to the
chat gbd and let's move on and let's
just create an array of all of these
chats so you can see now we can generate
the chats like this so we can have
create an area of static chats with the
assistant like the r string and the
content we have the message over there
and that's how we can use that so we can
just copy the array then we can move on
so for now we can just Define the
constant array over here so we can have
the const we can have the chat messages
so that should be this messages over
there so we can have the chat messages
like that and that's how it's going to
work so now let's define all of that so
here now what we can use so we can have
the chat messages to we can have the map
over there so we can have the map and
now what do we want to do here so now
after the map now we want to run a
separate component so now we'll be
creating a different component for each
chat item so there would be a different
component there would be separate
component for each chat item to show the
chats so here what we need to do here so
we'll be having the chat like that so we
can have the chat and then now what we
want to do so as of now we can just
render a normal div in which we can just
render something like we can just render
we can render the chat like that so we
can have the the chat do we can have the
message or we can have the content like
that so let's see how it going to look
so let's see how it looks now so what's
happening over there let's see what
happens so there you can see now we are
seeing all of the chats over there like
hello you and see this you can see I'm
in New York City and all of that and
let's just create the separate component
in which we can just display all of the
chats same like the chat gbd so let's
move on so inside the components let's
just move on so let's move on let's
create another folder that can be chat
and inside the chat we can have the chat
item like
that dot we have the TSX over there the
chat item. TSX and now let's just move
on to the chat item so inside the chat
item now what do we want to do so we'll
be accepting some props as well so we'll
be accepting the props like we can have
the
message then we can have the prop of the
role as well so instead of message we'll
be having the content over there content
and that should be equals to we can have
the role and then the content
should be inside the format of we can
have the string and the role that we'll
be getting so rle should be there should
be two roles only the role could be we
can have a suppose that could be user or
there can be the role of assistant like
that so the roles can have the user and
the assistant so that's how it's going
to work and after that we'll be having
if we move on to the paint so let's move
on again like how each chat item will
going to look so suppose that's a chat
item over there
so inside first corner like this so we
can have the Avatar of the user we can
have the Avatar icon like we can have
the user Avatar icon it can be the user
or it can be the chat gpts Avatar icon
that could be the open AI then after
that we would be having the message over
there like we would be having the
message like that so let's move on let's
just complete that as well so after this
now we want to render all of these
things according to the conditions so
inser the return statement now what we
can do so first we can check if the role
is equals to we have the assistant then
we want to perform different things and
if the role is different then we want to
perform different things so let's just
addite the Mt GSX TX over there like
that inside this as well and inside this
as well so if the role is the assistant
then what we can use so we can use the
box from the material once again so
let's import that as well we can import
something from we can have add the
material that should be we can have the
box like that so we can have the box and
here what do we want to do so here we
have the box and inside the box now what
we can use so we can have the SX prop we
can have the display that should be we
can have the flex over there like that
we can have the display Flex then we can
have the padding that should be
somewhere around two we can have the
background color as well so for the
assistant there would be different
background color for each chat item and
that should be hash we can have the0 4 d
5612 we have the background color and
then now what do we want to do so then
we can have the margin from the Y that
should be two the gap between the items
that should be we can have the two and
after that now what do we want to do so
first we need to render the Avatar so we
can have the Avatar like
that so we can have the Avatar like this
so we have the
Avatar and after this now we have the
Avatar over there and again inside the
Avatar now what do we want to do we can
have the SX prop we can have the margin
from the left that should be we can have
the zero for this because now the
assistant should start from zero again
and then inside the Avatar now what do
you want to do so if the role is the
assistant then we'll be using the image
The Source should be equals to open AI
dot we have the PNG over there and then
we have the alt of the open a once again
open a and then we can have the width as
well width that should be somewhere
around we can the 30 pixels for the
width like that so that's how it's going
to work and after that we would be
having another message as well so we can
have the message so inside the message
now what do you want to do so we can
just render the content directly so we
can have the typography for that so we
can have the
typography so we can just render all of
the content there inside the typography
over there we can have the typography
and inside the typography we can just
provide we can have the color over there
color we can have the white like that
the color should be white then we can
the font size so I think the color is
already white so we need we just need to
provide the
font I think we can have this size that
should be 20 pixels enough and after
that now what do we want to do so we
just want to render the content over
there like that so it is same like this
you can see now we have if the role is
assistant then we want to do this and if
the role is the user then we want to do
a different thing then what we can do so
we can again copy this box we can again
paste that instead of this now we would
be having a different type of styling so
we have the petting tube we have the
margin from the Y that should be I think
margin is not required so we can remove
the margin we have the Gap we have the
different background color that should
be what we need to do so we can have
the0 4 d 56 over there so that should be
the different background color and after
that now what do you want to do so we
can have the AAR so again we can use the
Au property of the user so we can have
the const
we can have the Au over that should be
equals to we have the use that should be
Au over there that should be use and
again we can grab this thing over there
like this so it's like a temporary thing
but still so let's just complete the
application then we'll change that so we
can just copy this thing over there
let's move on to the chat item and let's
render this thing inside the Avatar
instead of this let's just render this
thing and now what do we want to do so
then we have the typography and it
should be same I think but inide the
Avatar we can have the ml Z we can have
the BG color like
that black then we can have the
foreground color so we can have the
color that should be we can have the
white so if we save and if we move on to
the applications so let's see how it
looks so suppose we have all of these
messages like that and now we have the
chat do content but instead we want to
write here uh chat item component over
there chat item and now we want to send
the
data we can just for the content that
should be we can have the chat do we
have the content over there then we can
move on we can have the RO that should
be we can have the chat dot we can have
the rooll so that's how it's going to
work and I think the role is mismatching
maybe the user and the assistant so
that's how it's going to work so then we
can send the key as well so we can send
the key so as of now we can just send
index for the key so it's not like it's
not the accepted solution for the keys
because sometimes it can get worse so we
should provide a key for the ID for the
separate ID for that sorry now we are
seeing this thing over there hello can
you tell me this this this you have the
James so I think all messages are
directly from the user of the assistant
the RO of the
assistant so let's move on and let's
just see that what is happening over
there so that's the error because now we
have provided some extra space over
there so if you save and if you move on
so there you can see now it look looks
great you can see first the user sends a
message like hello can you tell me the
weather forecast for tomorrow sure I can
help you please provide me your location
I'm in the new Rox behav the behav the
message great give me a moment and then
there you can see now of the message the
weather forecast is we have the sunny we
have the dead sound perfect you can see
now we have created this type of
application you can see it's looking
great now the design looks great over
there so that's how it's going to work
and the final thing that we want to do
for the UI is now we want to add the
input box as well below that so let's do
that as well so what do we want to do so
again we can move on to the parent chat
and here we can provide the input tag
inside this container right inside this
container let's move on at the bottom so
after this let's add the input tag as
well so for this now what we can do so
we can just use I think we can directly
use the HTML input tag because it would
be more preferable HTM input and here we
can have the type text we can provide
the styling for that the style should be
what do we want to do so we can have the
width that should we can have the 100%
for the width then we can have the
background color like that we have the
background color that should be we can
have the transparent for that like that
then we can have the padding that should
be 10 pixels for
that then we can move on so we can have
the
Border
so that should be we can have the none
over there like that border none so we
don't need any border over there then we
can have the outline that should be
again we can use the none for that and I
think that's enough so we can also
provide the color I think yeah color
that should be we can have the white
then we can move on we can the font size
as well that should be somewhere around
20 pixels over there so these are the
styles for the input tag and now what do
you want to do so we can just provide a
different D for the input so let's move
on so in the end we'll be having the
icon as well so we can have the div we
can provide the styles for the div and
this should contain the width that
should be we can have the 100% of the
width then we can move on so we can have
the
pading so that should be somewhere
around 20 pixels over there padding from
all of these
sides and then what we can do so we can
have the bottle radius so what we can do
so we can wrap the input directly inside
this div so we can have a sty like input
so so we can move on to the input we can
have the Border we can have the radius
that should be somewhere around we have
the eight then we can move on so we can
have the background color so we can use
different background color for this that
should be RGB once again and that should
be we can have the 17
27 and that should be we can have the 39
so that's how it's going to look and
after that now what do you want to do so
after that I think that's enough for
that so
I think we can have the display as well
so display that should be we have the
flex because we want to render the icon
as well we can have the margin from we
can have your the right like this so we
can have the margin from the right that
should be we can the auto like that and
now what do we want to do is the next
step have the margin like that that
should be Auto like this and now what do
you want to do so after this input now
we can just render the icon as well to
send so that could be a button so we can
use the icon button directly from the
material UI so we can the
icon button so we can move on to the top
once again so we can have here the icon
button it is used to provide the hover
effects and all functionality The Click
effects functionality to a normal icon
so we can have the icon button over
there like that and then we can provide
the icon between them so first we can
provide the Styles a margin from the
left that should be we have the auto we
can have the
color that should be we can have the
white over there for the color
and I think we can move on we can import
one icon as well from the react icons so
we can
import we can import I think we can
import from the
react icons SL IO and the second thing
that we want to import should be we
should be importing the iomd icon like
IO MD we can have this
send so I just selected this icon so we
can use this icon and let's see see how
it looks now so we have thisd send icon
over there and that's how it's going to
look so if you same it if you move on so
there you can see now we have the icon
over there and you can see it's working
perfectly fine over there you can see
now we have the icon it's looking great
over there so there you can see it's
looking great over there you can see now
have the input as well it's working
perfectly fine over there like that you
can see it's looking great over there so
we have this input tag and there you can
see in the end we have the button to
send the chat as well and you can see
that's how it works and there you can
see the style looks great over there
like that so it looks
great and now the final thing that we
want to do is is now we want to
integrate this input and the chats to
the API so let's complete that as well
so there we go you can see now the
design looks great over there and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine and now another thing that we want
to do over there we can just check the
responsiveness as well we can move on to
the inspect panel so we can select the
responsive you can see it's looking
great over there you can see now we
don't have the the clear conversation
button inside the mobile devices but on
the desktop we have one and there you
can see everything seems to be working
perfectly fine and now let's move on
let's integrate that to the back end as
well so let's complete that as well so
now we need to move on so you can see we
have already created that on the back
end we want just to integrate that here
so how can we do that so first we need
the data of this input right so first we
need this input data so let's move on so
what we can do so we can deare a ref
inside this so we can declare a ref and
from that ref we can just get the data
of this input so the ref will allow you
to get directly to the reference to this
input element directly from the Dom so
we can provide the ref over there so we
can move on we can have the cons we can
have the input we can have the ref like
that and that should be equals to we can
have the use ref over there so we can
use the use ref hook directly from the
react and initial value could be here we
can have the null and we can just
provide HTML input element over there
HTML input element and that should be
equals to null as well like this and
after that now what do we want to do so
we can copy the input ra over there and
we can directly move on to the input so
here we have the input and here we can
just provide the ref we can provide the
ref and that should be equals to we can
have the input ref that should be the
input ref and that's how we want to do
that and after that now what do you want
to do so once we click on this send
button once we click on this icon button
so now we should send the input data so
let's move on so we can move on to the
top once again so here we have the
return statement and before that we can
have the cons we can have the handle
submit like that or we can have the
handle we can have the handle submit
over
there so that should be again equals to
a function and we can Define this
function as an asynchronous function as
well so we can have the async over there
and that's how it's going to work and
after that now what do we want to do so
inside this function now we'll be
getting the data of this input gra so
let's move on so we can log the data
like this we can have the input ref dot
we can have the current dot we can have
the value over there because it is
directly referenced to the input element
so that's why you can get the value you
can get the data of the input as well so
here we just need to get the value we
can just log the value and we can
reference this handle submit function to
this input like that so we can have the
icon button we can have the on click
state for this and we can have the
handle submit like that so let's see
what happens if we are getting the data
or the not so let's move on we can have
the hello so let's just click on the
send so let's just get the data so now
we are getting the data and everything
seems to be working perfectly fine and
again we can move back to the uh to the
chat page over there and here we have a
couple of Errors like the first error
that we have would be the role so as of
now what we can do so we can have the TS
ignore to ignore the type checking on
the next line so now you can see now we
do not have any error and now what do
you want to do over there so now once we
get the input over there once we get the
input now what do we want to do so first
we want to store all of these chats so
first all of the previous chats of the
user would be stored and then we want to
insert the latest chat into the array so
let's move on let's declare the chats
array as well so we can again have the
use State over there like this we can
have the use State we can have the chats
or we can have the
messages we can have the set messages
over there I think chat messages we can
have okay we can have the set chat
messages and use state would have the
initial value of the empty string over
there and we can Define the type as well
I think so first thing that we want to
do is now we can remove the chat
messages over there we can remove this
and now we have the set chat messages
and here we have the use state so as of
now we can use here without any type so
let's see what happens and after that
you can see now we won't be seeing any
chat over there now we don't have any
chat and after that you can see once we
move on so let's move on to the handle
submit over there so once we move on so
now first thing that we want to do is
now we want to get the latest input
message so we can have the cons content
and that should be equals to we can have
the input ref dot we can have the
current dot we can have the value like
this so we can have the input ref do
current do value we can have S we can
have the string over there we can have a
string and now let's move on so after
this now we want to move on so now we
want to move on and after that now we
can do I think so after we create a new
content over there now what we can do we
can just remove the ref of the input so
we can check if we have the input ref so
if we have the input ref and the input
ref do we have the current so then what
do we want to do so now we can have the
input ref do current do we can have the
value is equals to the empty string so
that now the input should be moved on to
the empty string once again and now we
have the content over there and after
that now what do we want to do so now
we'll be creating a new message so we
can have the cons we can have the new
message like this and that should be
equals to an object the role should be
of we can have the user over there the
role has the user and the content over
there so we can have the content like
this and that's how it's going to work
and after that now what do we want to do
so now we want to store that input
inside this state as well inside this US
state as well so we can have the set
chat messages over there we can have the
set sorry we can have the set chat
messages and inside there now we want to
First grab the previous chats so we can
have the previous and now we want to
create a new array so first all of the
previous chats would be stored and then
the latest new message would be stored
like that so that's how it's going to
work and now you can see now we getting
some type errors so we can move on so I
think what we can do over there we can
just declare the types as well so that
is the type for a messages so let's move
on so we can have the type we can have
the messages over there and that should
be equals to we can have the type of the
message only that should be equals to we
can Define the types over there like
this so we can have the role string we
can have the content of the string the
role we can also Define the exact type
like the user and the role can be of we
can have the assistant as well we have
the role user or the assistant and now
the use State can have the values of we
can have the message array like that and
that's how it's going to work over there
and the new message is also of type of
the message like this so we can have the
type of the message and now we should
not be getting any type errors as well
so this is known as the clean code so
because now we have the types of
everything that we use and after that
now we have the new message and now the
new message would be stored inside the
set messages array so let's move on so
if we send a new message over there like
we can send the hero so then I think it
should be stored there you can see now
we are seeing the hell over there we can
have the high we can just click on the
send so now you can see now we have the
high and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine over there and now let's
move on so now we have the new messages
let's just again refresh this and there
now what do we want to do so after this
now we can again move back to the chat
page over there we can again move back
we can close others and now let's
complete all of that so there you can
see so after we create a new message
over there inside this array now what we
want to do so now we want to send the
API request to the back end with a new
message so with that uh with the help of
that now we'll be receiving the response
as well and we can send the new response
inside the set chat messages array so
let's move on so what do we want to do
here so we can first move on to the API
Communicator so let's create another
function over there so let's create
another function like this so what we
can do so the function could be so the
function could be we can have the
send chat we can have the request over
there we have the send chat request and
here it would be a synchronous function
and here we need the message so we can
have the message like this so that
should be inside the string so here we
have the message over there and now what
do we want to do so xos start we can
have the post and this time it would be
slash chat and Slash new because we have
registered this route as well so/ chat
SL new and after that inside the second
parameter now we need to provide the
data as well so we can provide the data
the data could be equals to we need to
only send the message so that's how it's
going to work and after that if the
response. status not equals to 200 then
we can have the error message Chat like
that unable to send chat and after we
receive the response then inside the
data now we'll be receiving the full
list of all of the messages of the user
so then what we want to do so now we'll
be just replacing the full array with
the new list of messages so we can move
on so we can have the const over there
and then we can have the response like
that or we can have the chat data like
this and that should be equals to we can
have the await then we can have the send
chat request and here now we want to
create a new message that could be
equals to what do we want to do so we
can just send the content over there we
can send the content or we can send here
the new message so we can have the
content like that that and now let's
move on so after we have the content
let's see that what happens this time so
after we have the content over there now
we'll be receiving the response as well
so now after that now what do we want to
do so then we can move on so we can have
this set chat messages over there set
chat messages and that should be equals
to an array of all of the messages of
the user so we can have the chat data
dot we can have the chats over there
like that so we have the chat data do
chats and that's how it's going to work
and now let's see that what happens so
first we need to move on to back end to
verify all of that if everything works
correct or not if everything is properly
integrated or not so let's move on to
the back end so uh we can move on to the
chat routes we have the generate chat
completion so here you can see now uh we
are creating a new message role of the
user user. chats. push and from there we
are just sending the chats over there
and that's how it's going to work so now
let's move on and let's just try it out
so let's try it out out once again so
here now what I can send is I can send
hello how are you
today so let's send the message and
let's see that what happens this
time so let's see what happens so I
think we are receiving some errors we
can move on to the console so there are
some errors over there so let's just
refresh the page so now what do we want
to do so again we can send a new request
and we can track the network response
over there so let's move on so we're
going to the hello how
are you
today so let's just click on the send so
let's see what happens so now we have
the new it means now if we are sending a
44 not found it means now we do not have
this uh we do not have this URL
registered so I think we can move on to
the back end once again so we have a new
but inside the index we have the chats
so here it should be the chat I think so
we can have the chat only so let's see
what happens this time so it should be
we can have the chats only so let's move
on so let's just click on send once
again let's just again refresh that we
can have the
hello how are you doing
today so let's see what happens if we
just click on this end once again so
let's just click on this end you can see
now it is pending so now we should be
receiving a new so there you can see now
we are receiving a new message so you
can see here we have a message like
hello I am an AI as I don't have any
feelings but I here to assist you and
how can I help you today you can see
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine over there we just sended a new
message we just sent a new message like
hello how are you doing today we got the
preview as well and inside the preview
we got the ID of the message and there
you can see we got the data as well and
you can see that's how it works and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine over there so you can see it looks
great over there so let's send another
message like what is we at the
JavaScript so let's just send this
message and let's see that what happens
this time so this is a request and let's
see that what happens inside the preview
you can see now we are seeing the new
chat messages over there you can see
everything looks great over there now we
have the content you can see JavaScript
is the programming language you can see
now the design also looks great design
also looks similar to the chat gbt model
as well you can see that's how it works
and it looks great over there you can
see it looks great and everything seems
to be working perfectly fine so
congratulations on successfully
integrating the openi API to the monag
application
and you can see this looks great over
there and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine and here the last thing
that we can do is now we want to do
another thing so the thing is that if
you access a code block from this open
AI so suppose I can send a message like
show me the I think we can have show me
the
code um like we can have show me the
syntax that how can I
declare function we can have the how can
I declare the function and we can have
the
JavaScript so there you can see now we
are receiving the response as well and
it works great but there you can see
here we have the code blocks as well you
can see here we have the JavaScript we
have the function function name here we
have the Cod Snippets as well and now we
want to show the cod snipets as well to
the user and how can we do that so we
can do that with using a library of the
react which is a react syntax
highlighter so we can move on so we can
have the react syntax highlighter so we
can use this Library over there so let's
just move on let's just install this
library in our application let's install
this package and if you want to see the
demos as well you can move on so here
you have the demo as well inside this
you can get the demos you can see you
can provide some dark uh some dark
themes as well the language as well and
everything with that so that's how it
works over there so let's move on and
let's just Implement that as well so
here we want to install this Library so
we can move on we have the react syntax
highlighter we can just copy that and
then we can paste that over there so
inside this frontend we can have the npm
install react syntax highlighter and
after that let's move on to the chat
page once again so here we are rendering
all of the chats so let's move on to the
chat as well here we can move on to the
chat item and here now we want to just
import something from the prism code
highlighter so now we want to import
something from the react syntax
highlighter so we can have the import we
can have this something from it should
be equals to from we can have the react
syntax highlight o and here we can just
move on and we can just import the prism
style because if we move on to the npm
package so you can see there are a
couple of styles we can use the prism as
well and that's how it's going to work
so we'll be using this type of styles
over there like prism as syntax
highlighter and we'll be using some
themes over there we can use any theme
over there and then we can just write
here the syntax highlighter language we
can detect the language and then we can
move on we can just provide the code
strings between them so you can see if
you move on to the application
so could not find the Declaration file
okay now we want to install the
Declaration files as well so we can just
copy this thing over there we can just
paste it out
here I don't know why I didn't copy we
can copy it once again we can paste it
out over
there I don't know what is happening
over there so let's move on so we can
click on the DT over there declaration
file and again we can move on we can
just copy that and then we can paste is
that over you and it is npm install it
is inside the development dependency so
we can write D flag over there like that
and now let's install that as
well and after that now we want to move
on so now we should be having the types
over there now we can import the prism
over there prism as we can have the
syntax we can have the S syntax
highlighter over there and that's how
it's going to work and after that now we
want to move on so now we want to import
the Styles as well so you can see again
we can move on to documentation now we
can get the Styles as well so what we
can do so now here we are using the
prism so we want to import the styles
for the prism we can copy the statement
we can import the CSS file directly from
it and after that you can see we won't
be using the color of the dark we'll be
using the color dark like that so we'll
be having the colder K dark like that
we'll be using this style and it is
being imported directly from the prism
and after that now you can see now we
want to detect that where is the code
block between the string
so if we move on to the inspect panel if
we going refresh this if we refresh so
let's see what happens this
time I think the frontend server is not
open we can have the npm Run Dev so
again we can open the server and after
that you can see if we move on and
there's another thing that we want to do
so on the initial request now we want to
have the chats of the user as well so we
want to maintain that as well so now
let's move on so again what we can do so
we can just send the hello over there so
after we send the hello now will bece
saving all of the messages of the user
as well like this so that's how it's
going to work over there and after that
now what do we want to do so now between
the string if we open this here the chat
are if you open this thing over there
like this so we have the message five so
there you can see this is the string
over there this is the string in which
we have the code blocks as well right we
have the code blocks but how we can
detect that so if you see inside this
message so every code block starts from
this sign so I think that's the back Tex
so it starts from three backticks over
there so you can see every code block
starts from three back Texs and ends in
these three back tcks so with the help
of this now we can just grab the code
box as well so let's write the condition
as well so what we can do so let's just
copy it out so let's just test it out
our programming skills so let's move on
to the inspect panel we can move on to
the console and we can have the con we
can have the message like this so that
should be equals to we can have this
message so there we have the message and
that's how it's going to work and after
that let's move on so here now what we
can do so we can have the message like
this start we can have this split so we
can split the message with these three
back ticks over there so we can write
that over there and this key is there
onto the Escape I think before the
escape this key is there so first let's
move on and let's just use that over
there so you can see now we have the
array and inside the array we have seven
elements so you can see inside the first
one we have inside the Java script we
have this rule over there and inside the
second value of the array now we have
the code block you can see now we have
the code block and you can see inside
the third as well I think now we have
the code block inside this as well now
we have the code block so that's how
it's going to work and after that let's
use the same syntax inside our
application as well so let's move on so
what do we want to do here so inside the
chat item first thing that we want to do
we can define a function before the
component so before the component let's
define the function
we can have the
extract code we can have from that
should be we can have the string so that
would be a function and in set this
function now we would be expecting a
parameter as well which is we can have
the message like this we can have the
message the type that should be of the
string and after that now what do we
want to do so we can check a condition
like if the message like if the message
to have the includes so if the message
dot includes these three back takes over
there like this if the message do
includes this then what do you want to
do then we can just renter here this
over there now we can renter condition
we can have the con we can have the
blocks of the message that should be
equals to we can have the message dot we
can have the split so we can split all
of these things inside this and then we
can split that directly from the code
blocks like this directly from this code
blocks and after that now we want to
return the array of the blocks so we can
return the are of the blocks and that's
how it's going to work and after that we
need another function function suppose
you can see if we move on to the
application once again so some strings
do not have the code blocks right so
some strings do not have this so we
should get the error like this thing is
not found over there so we should get
that error so now what we can do so we
can just declare a function in which we
can verify if a block is the code block
so how we can verify that so there can
be multiple rules for that so in this
application we'll be declaring a basic
syntax a basic validation check in which
we can check that if that string
includes a code block or note so it
would be very simple so what do we want
to do so again we can Define the
function we can have is code block like
that so that would be equals to a
function like that and inside that what
we can do so we can have the Str Str
that should be inside the string format
and after that let's think that how we
can verify that if a string includes a
code or not so there can be multiple
parameters so you can see if we move on
to the application so each code block
contains a parenthesis like this so it
can be having a parenthesis like this it
can have the semicolons it can have a
lot of things so we can verify all that
so we can provide some if checks over
there so like what we can do so we can
have the if we can have the string do we
can have the includes if the string do
includes and equals to or what we can do
we can check another condition or if the
string dot we can have includes so if it
includes the semicolon so this condition
would pass and if the string dot we can
have the includes over there so if the
string dot includes this as well like
this so if the string dot includes this
block over there and we can provide a
couple of conditions like this so so you
can also Define your own conditions as
well if you want to do that so here we
have these conditions over there
formatted and after that we can have
another condition as well if the string
or we can have the includes and if the
string do includes that could be the
hash sign for for the comment and if the
string again we can have a condition
like if the string dot we can have the
includes over there once again or it
could be the includes and that should be
like this sign over there like the
comment sign so it is a code block right
so that could be a code block so now we
can move on and we can verify all of
that here so inside each message of this
so if the role is assistant now we can
verify that condition over there so
after this box now we can remove this
typography now we can remove this
typography and let's move on so after
this now first you can see inside this
component first we can grab all of the
code blocks so let's move on so we can
have the cons here we can have the
message blocks like that so that should
be equals to we can have the extract
code from the string and that should be
equals to the content over there like
this so that should be the content so if
we get the empty AR over there so if we
get this string are over there it means
now we have the message blocks and if we
do not get that if it is undefined it
means now we do not have any code blocks
over there so let's move on let's define
the condition inside this block over
there let's define that condition so
first there would be a condition like if
we don't have the message blocks if it
is an empty array then what do we want
to do so then we can have the condition
and instead this we can again use the
same typography over there we can have
the typography and it can use the SX
prop once again for the styling we can
have the font size over there the font
size could be we can have the 20 pixel
like that so that could be this
typography and inside this typography we
can just render the content over there
so that could have this content so you
can see this condition works when we do
not have the message blocks so let's
provide another condition as well so
once we have the message blocks and we
have the message blocks to we can have
the length um is greater than zero so
this condition would always be true with
the help of that and then we can move on
so if we have the message
blocks and we have the message blocks do
length is not equals to zero so then
what do we want to do so we can have the
message blocks dot we can have the map
so we can map through the message blocks
over there and inside that we would be
receiving the block string we would be
receiving the block string over there
and after that now what do we want to do
so we can just write the condition and
we can render something based on that
condition so we can check if that's a
code block if this block has the code
block over there we can have the block
like this so then what do you want to do
so if this has a code block then we want
to render something else then what do we
want to render we can render something
else and if it is not the code block
then we want to do something else so we
can provide the GSX over there the empty
jsx tax over there like that and for
this as well we can have the empty jsx
tax like that and now what do you want
to do so I think we are receiving the
error inside the escort block because
now we haven't return the true over
there like that so we should return the
true over there like this so we can have
the true and if we do not find all of
that we can just return the false over
there we can return the false so you can
see now we should not be getting any
error so now if we have the code block
then we want to render the syntax
highlighter and if we don't have the
code block within the same string then
we want to render the simple typography
so let's move on so inside this now we
should be rendering the syntax
highlighter we can have the syntax
highlighter over there and then what do
we want to do so inside that we can move
on we can provide the style that should
be we can have the colder Cod like that
so we would be having this style over
there I think we can have your CER we
can have the dark so we'll be using this
style over there so we can just use same
over there like this so we have this
style and after that we need to provide
the language so this is an assignment
for you that how you can grab the
language so this is an assignment so you
need to find the language of the code
and this is very simple and you can find
the answer of this assignment inside the
GitHub repository so inside my final
code you will be seeing the example you
will be seeing the assignment solution
as well so here now what do you want to
do so we can just provide the language
that should be for the JavaScript so as
of now I am giving here the static type
over there but now you should be just
solving this assignment you should be
solving this problem on
yourself so now as of now I have the
static language so now what you need to
do you need to define a new state for
the language as well so now we have the
language of the JavaScript and now after
that now what do you want to do so after
that we need to render the code block
between them so we can Rend the code
block and that should be equals to we
can have the block like this so that
should be the block and if we do not
have any code block inside that if we
don't have the code block then we just
need to copy this typography we can just
paste it out over there and that should
contain the block so that's how it's
going to work so you can see that was
very simple to explore you can see we
just created a condition like if that
string contains a code block and you can
see first we are grabbing the code
blocks from the string then we are very
defying it according to this condition
then we are rendering that according to
these conditions like if that's a code
block then we want to render the code or
we want to render this thing over there
so let's see what happens this time so
if I send you the show I think we can
have can you show the syntax of
declaring variable in
JavaScript like this so if I send this
query to the chat jity so let's see what
happens so what happened so let's move
on to the network so there you can see
now we are receiving the response as
well so inside the response you can see
now we are receiving the data can see it
looks great over there you can see now
we have the code blocks as well between
them you can see in JavaScript this this
this you can see the code blocks are
working fine you can see now you can see
all of the code blogs and it looks great
over there right it looks great and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine you can say it's looking great and
there you got the solution of your
assignment as well right you got the
solution so you can see inside each code
block you get the language of the code
as well right you got the language of
the code so your assignment has already
been completed so you just need to grab
the first word of the code block and
then what you can do you can just move
on and then you can just provide the
language to the code block so that's how
it's going to work so that's your
assignment already completed so that's
how it's going to work so you can see
with the help of this now we are
receiving all of the chats you can see
it's looking great so that's how the
chat G works you can see that's how we
can use their apis to do all of the
things so that's it for this so now
let's move on so we can do the same
thing for the users message as well so
sometimes users also send a chat
messages so what we can do so we can
move move on we can just use the same
box over there as well inside this so
that's how it's going to work over there
so let's move on so it would be same
over there so that's how it's going to
work and after that if you need to
provide some margin or the petting
between them so I think there's already
some margin in the padding you can see
the color is starting from there you can
provide the margin from this I think so
I think this box doesn't have any margin
so you can provide the margin from the Y
that should be equals to we can have the
two and that's how it's going to happen
and and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine over there you can see it
looks great and you can see that looks
fine and now let's move on now we need
to fix a couple of issues as well inside
this application so there are a couple
of issues you can see if we refresh this
application you can see now we are
successfully logged in but here you can
see now we do not have any chats so now
we need to create a route in which we
can get all of the chats of the user as
well so let's move on and we can make
the request directly from the client so
once we move on to the chat page so now
we should be receiving all of the chats
so let's Implement that so here let's
move on to the back end once again so
let's just quickly remove all of the
shoes from our application so let's move
on to the chat routes let's create a new
route as well so let's create the chat
routes. we can have the get request over
there so that should be the get and that
should be we can have the all chats like
that or we can have the chats like this
so that could be the route over there
and here I think we do not need any
valid date because we won't be sending
any data and after that let's create a
new function in which we can just send
all of the chats to the user so what we
can do so we can copy something like
this from this from the users controller
let's just paste it out there inside the
chats controller so let's paste it out
and that should be we can have the
send chats to we can have the user like
this so we can have the send chats to
user and after that now what do you want
to do so first we can verify the token
of the user then if we don't have the
user then we we have this conditions
over there and after that now we have
the return statement and inside the
return statement we have the message of
the okay then we can send the chats of
the user so we can send the chats so
that should be we can have the user do
we can have the chats like this and
that's how it's going to work so the
work on the back end has been completed
and now we can move on to the front end
to implement that so now we can move on
to the Au Communicator once again and
here now what do you want to do so we
can create another request in which what
do you want to do so we can copy we can
paste it out over there so that should
be we can have the get I think we can
have the get user chats like that we can
have the get user chats and inside this
we don't need any message over there we
just need to send the exos we the get
requests and that should be uh we don't
need to send the message so chat that
should be equals to I think we can move
on to the routes so this is the message
over there all chats over there so we
need to send all chats over there
so let's move on so that should be the
all chats and here I found another book
so it should not be the generate chat
completion it should be I think we can
get the chats like that so we can have a
chats like that uh we can see so we can
directly move on to the chat completion
so we can have this send chats to user
so that should be the function over
there that you want to render so that
should be this function and now what do
we want to do so again we can move on to
the communicator and here I think that's
enough for that so we'll be getting the
chats over there let's move on to the
chat so before the return statement
let's render the use effect code as well
so we can have the use effect and in set
this now what do you want to do so we
need to run it only one time and I think
instead of the use effect we can use the
layout effect as well we can have the
layout effect so layout effect runs
before it is rent out on the UI so let's
move on so after we have the layout
effect so we can have a condition like
if we have the O DOT we can have this
logged in it means now we have the user
and we have the o. user as well you can
rent another condition like you can have
the O do you can have the user so after
that now you want to run something so
after that you can run the code over
there so you can uh you can move on so
you can have the toast over there so you
can import the toast to you can have the
loading then we can have the loading
chats like that so we can have the
loading chats we can put the message
like that we can put the ID over there
so that should be we can have the load
chats like that we have the ID over
there and after that now what do you
want to do so we can move on so we can
have the get user chats like that get
users chats over there and after that
we'll be getting the data as well so we
can have then we'll be getting the data
over there data like this so then what
do you want to do so after we get the
data then we can have the set messages
over there set chat messages that should
be we can have an array we can
destructure all the elements so we can
have the data to we can have the message
messages like that we can have the data
do I think we have the chats so that's
what we want to do so after we set all
of these messages then we can have the
toast dot we can have the success over
there we can have the toast to success
so we can copy this string over there we
can have toast. success and that should
be we can have
successfully loaded we can have the
chats over there successfully loaded
chats and ID of the load chats and
that's all we want to do and after that
if we get any error then what do we want
to do we can renter the catch over there
so we can renter the catch statement and
inside the catch we get the error first
we can log the eror as well we can lock
the error inside the console then we can
move on so we can have the toast we can
have the error as well to. error and
that should be equals to we can send the
message as well directly like we can
have the loading fail like that we have
the loading failed and that should be
equals to the message as well so we can
have the load chats like that we have
the ID over there that should be we can
have the load chats and that's how it's
going to work and I don't know what is
the error over there
so I think this cannot be the array this
should be the call back function so this
should be a function over there like
this and that's how it's going to work
and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine so if we refresh so let's
see what happens so there you can see if
we just refresh the
page
so I don't know what happen so let's
move on to the go to chat and there you
can see now we have successfully loaded
the chats and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine over there and
that's how it's going to work so let's
move on to the go to chats and there it
seems to be working fine and if we
refresh this I think on the refresh
that's not working so I think the layout
effect has been called before the main
use effect and then what do you want to
do so after that you can see if we
refresh the page now you can see now we
won't be seeing the chats over there but
if we move on to the main route if we
again move on to the goto chat then
we'll be seeing the loading chats so
there is an error so what do you want to
do so you can see initially the context
is sending the request to the back end
regarding the token to check the users's
token validity until then it is calling
this code so what do you want to do so
we need to create the dependency on the
O So once the authentication changes now
we want to rerun this code so let's move
on and if we again refresh this now you
can see it works fine you can see now
successfully loaded all of the chats and
that's how it's going to work you can
see it's working perfectly fine
and there's another thing that we want
to do is you can see now we want to work
on the clear conversation Button as well
so we want to work on that so how we can
do that so we can create another
function we can create the cons we can
have the handle delete like that handle
delete chats like that so that could be
equals to when asynchronous Arrow
function and inser this now what do you
want to do so we can remove everything
we can remove the params so here we want
to create a function inside the API
communicator and we want to create a
middleware inside the back end as well
so that we can accept a request and then
we can delete all of the chats of the
user so let's move on so inside the chat
route now what do you want to do so we
can create another request over there so
we can have the chat routes or we can
have the delete over there now let's
move on so we can have slash we can have
the delete over there so we can have
slash we can have the delete and after
that let's move on so inside this now we
can create another function we can just
copy it out we can paste it out so we
can paste this function over there we
can have the delete we can have the
chats over there so that's how it's
going to work and after we get all of
the token user verification check then
we can move on so then we can move on so
we can have the user do we can have the
chats like this so we can have the user
do chats is equals to an empty array so
now we can set the users chats to the
empty array and that's how we want to
work and after we set that then I think
we have the type error as well so we can
expect the type error so we can have the
TS we can have the ignore over there and
after that now what do you want to do so
after we have the user chats then we can
have the await then we can have the user
to we can have the save like that and
that's how it's going to work and then
you can see everything seems to be
working fine and here now again we are
sending the user chats I think it's not
required over there so it's not required
and that's how it's going to work and
then now what do you want to do so again
we can move on to the chat routes we can
have the delete chats like that we have
the delete chats then we can move on to
the API Communicator let's create
another function we can copy we can
paste it out we can have your delete
user chats so we can have the delete
like this user chats that could be an
asynchronous function this should be a
delete request over there this should be
the delete then we can have the delete
like
this so we can have the delete that
should be chat / delete and I think yeah
it's same we have the chat SL delete and
after that now what do we want to do so
I think everything seems to be working
perfectly fine so it should be unable to
delete the chats like that we get the
error and then we can move on again to
to the chat page and here now what do
you want to
do we can have the try catch for that so
we can have the try catch so inside the
try we can have here the wait we can
have the delete chats of the user we can
have the delete user chats and after
that we can have the set messages of the
user set chat messages that should be an
empty array and after that we can run
the toast as well toast. we can have the
loading we can have the
deleting chats like this we can have the
ID as well we can have the ID
we can have the delete chats over there
like this we can just copy and after
everything is successful then we can
move on we can have the toast dot we can
have the success over there then we have
the
deleted we can have the deleted chats we
can have
successfully and then we have the same
ID then if we get an error then we can
move on we can lock the error we can
lock the complete error message then we
can move on we can paste it out we have
the TOs do we have the error we can have
the
deleting chats we can defail like that
so that could be the error message and
now we want to reference this function
to this button as well to this button
let's move on so let's provide the on
click as well so we can have the on
click over there and that should be we
can have the handle delete chats so
let's see what happens if we move on so
we have successfully loaded chats and
let's move on let's just delete all of
the chats let's move on let's click on
delete deleting chats you can see now
the chats are deled successfully and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine and now if we refresh now you can
see now successfully loaded chats but
here we do not have any chats of the
user and that's how you can see it's
working perfectly fine over there you
can see inside the all chats we do not
have any chat and it's working great so
it seems working fine and now what we
want to do as the next step so there you
can see now we want to enable the
protected routes inside the front end as
well so inside the back end we already
have the protected routes if we move on
to the chat routes you can see first we
are verifying all of the tokens we have
generate chat completion we are
validating all of that so we have a
couple of middlewares but now we want to
move on to the front end to verify all
of the protected routes of the user so
and then we want to create the front end
as well of the user so that would be
very simple so first thing that we want
to do is now we can move on to the chat
page so if the user is not logged in and
if the user tries to enter this page
then we want to move on and then we want
to redirect the user to the login page
so let's move on to the chat over there
so it would be very simple so what do we
want to do so we can just again have the
use effect code over there we can have
the US effect over there and inside that
now what do you want to do so let's just
call it once we change the Au over there
so inste the use effect now what do you
want to do we can have if we do not have
the O DOT we can have the user if that's
null then what do you want to do so then
we can have the return now we want to
return the user to a new route and to
use that we need to use use one thing
from the react rout Dom which is a
navigate so we have a hook inside the
react rout Dom which is a navigate so we
can use that as well we can have import
something and that should be equals to
we can have the from we can have the
react R Dom and the some thing is we can
have the use navigate so this is a hook
that we can use so first thing that we
can do is we can have the
cons and nigate like this we can have
the navigate that should have the
reference of the use navigate hook and
after that now what do you want to do so
after we have so after you can see once
we do not have the au. user we can have
the return we can have the navigate like
this we can have the return navigate
that should be equals to SL we can have
the login like this so that's how it's
going to work so if you move on to the
application and if you just click on the
log out so there you can see now we to
the Home Route but you can see now we
want to implement the log out
functionalities as well so let's move on
so if the user is not logged in so let's
just Implement that so before for
testing this now we want to implement
the log out as well so for implementing
the log out let's again move back to the
back end so we have the users controller
so we can move on to the user routes
let's create another route of the logout
so we can have the user routes do we can
have the get that should be equals to we
can have the log out so that should be a
log out request and inside the verify
user let's just copy this function let's
just paste it out and inside that we can
have the log out we can have the user
log out like that user log out like that
this and we have this function over
there and inste this function there
would be nothing but we would be just
removing the cookies of the user so we
would be removing the cookies of the
user so that's how we can create that so
you can see here we created the cookies
inside the sign up and inside the login
so we can remove the cookies of the user
as well so how we can use that so we can
use the clear cookie function so we can
use this over there so we have the
logout route and after we verify all of
the details of the user then we can move
on we can have the response do we can
have the clear cookie and inside that we
have a couple of things we have the HTTP
only domain of the Local Host signed of
the true the path is this and let's just
try the login oh sorry let's just try
the log out as well so let's move on so
it should be we can have the use a log
out like this so we have this controller
function and let's move on to the API
Communicator let's create another
request that should be we can have the
user log out again log out user like
this so we have this function that
should be a get request only and it
should be we can have slash user slash
we would have the log out like this the
log out so because the front end cannot
delete the HTTP only cookies so that's
why we need the back end to just remove
the cookies so that's how we want to
work and after that let's move on so
there now we can move on I think so now
we can move on to the header over there
we can remove we can move on to the
header or we can directly move on into I
think we can directly move on into the O
context so here we need the log out so
after that now what do you want to do so
we can have the a wait that should be we
can have the user log out like
this so I think we have the log out user
like this so we have the log out user
over there so we want to call this
function and after that we'll be having
the set messages like this sorry we'll
be having the set is logged in that
should be we can have the false set user
that should be we can have the null over
there and after that we want to reload
the page as well because once you remove
the HTTP only cookies it takes some time
it does doesn't immediately get uh
removed so it takes some time so we can
have the window dot we can have the
location dot we can have the REO like
that so we can reload the web page so
let's see what happens this time and
let's see that where we are using this
function let's move on to the header.
TSX so there you can see now we are
using the log out so let's just try it
out so if we move on to the application
if we again move on to go to chat and
let's just move on to the inspect let's
move on to console or we can move on to
the network let's just click on the
logout to see what
happens so here we have the log out so
let's just click on the log out I think
nothing is happening over there so we
need to do that so we can move on to the
navigation link and there you can see we
are not doing anything with the log out
so we can put the on click prop over
there we can have the on click and here
what do you want to do so now we can
just run near the props on click and it
would be very simple now we can move on
to the header you can see now here we
are providing the on click so it should
work perfectly fine over there let's try
it out once again so let's move on to
the application so let's move on to the
network tab over there let's click on
the log out so there you can see now we
are logged out and there you can see now
inside the O status now we are receiving
the message like the token not received
so everything seems to be working
perfectly fine over there so it's
working totally fine and now let's move
on so here you can see if we refresh now
we do not have any token over there and
let's move on to the application as well
so inside the cookies now you won't find
any cookies so now let's move on let's
just try and log in once again so let's
move on with the J games let's click on
the login so now we should be having the
cookies I think we are having the error
over there I think there's something
wrong with that I think it is admin it
it should be the James test.com 1 2 3 4
5 6 so email was wrong so let's try it
out with the login so you can see it
works perfectly fine now we are logged
in and if we now refresh now we do not
have any error message and that's how
it's going to work so that's all we want
to do and now let's move on so you can
see everything seems to be working fine
in our app ation and now we want to move
on so if we again click on the log out
now you can see now we are logged out
but now you can see if we move on to the
chat page over there if we move on to we
can have local L 5173 then we can have
the chat over there like that so let's
move on so now you can see now we should
be redirected to the login and that's
how it works and you can see that's how
it works and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine so now everything
seems to be working perfectly fine and
there are a couple of things remaining
to do this inside this application the
first is the sign up UI we have the
homepage UI and we have the protected
routes so we are into the middle of
protected routes and let's just complete
all of that so let's move on to the
login so there you can see if we are
logged in and if we move on to go to
chat you can see suppose I want to show
you an example if we click on the log
out and if we again move on to SL we can
have the chat you can see now we are
redirected to the login page so we want
to do the similar thing for the login
page as well so let's move on to the
login so we want to do same like if the
user is already logged in then we can
redirect the user to the chat page so we
can have the effect over there we can
have the effect and inside the effect it
should run every time the Au changes
then we can move on so here it should be
very simple so we can check if we have
the auth do we have the user then I
think what we can do so we can redirect
the user to navigate like we can have
the navigate over there SL we can have
the chat so that's all that we want to
do for the login so you can see now if
we move on so I have already registered
the navigate so with the help of this
now we can move on to the chat so if you
move on if you click on the login James
test.com we can click on the login so
you can see everything seems to be
working fine but now if we move on to
the login page over there like this so
then you can see now we'll be redirected
to the chat page so everything seems to
be working perfectly fine and now we
want to do another thing for the
protected routes so let's move on again
into the main file app. TSX and here now
what we can do so we have the chat page
over there and this is the protected
route so we can only enable this route
so we can wrap this inside a condition
so we can only enable this route once we
have the Au do we have the is logged in
is true and we have the Au dot we have
the user property so after all of these
things then only we want to enable this
route over there so now you can see if
we again move on click on the log out
and if we again move on we can go to/
chat you can see now we'll be moved on
to the not found page it means now the
user is moving into a page which is not
found so everything seems to to be
working perfectly fine over there so now
this functionality is completed the
protected routes let's just work on the
sign up as well so we can move onto the
login we can copy the complete login
page we can paste it out inside the
signup because the UI should be same of
the authentication of the O screens so
that should be we can have the sign
up and here as well we should be having
a the sign up over there like this so it
should have the sign up over there and
here we want to do another thing we need
another input for for this we have uh we
can have the customized input the type
should be we can have the text the name
should be the name itself of the user
the label should also be the name then
we can move on we can declare the
function for the signup as well so let's
move on to the API Communicator so let's
just copy the login let's just paste it
below that we can have the sign
up user like this so then we can have
the xl. post that should be we can have
the sign up over there like this and we
can have the name as well the name
should also so we can have the string
the email and the password then here as
well we'll be having the name email and
the password so you can see now it's
working fine and the sign up has the
2011 inside that we can have the unable
to we can the sign up like this so you
can see now we have already defined all
of the functions we just want to copy
paste all of these functions and change
these routes over there now we have the
sign up route if the response. status
not equals to 2011 unable to sign up
then we are just sending the data and
now let's move on so now we can move on
into the communic I think inside the Au
context let's move on let's do inside
the signup as well so let's move on so
we need to do the same thing inside the
signup so let's move on so we can have
the data equals to we can have the sign
up user like this sign up user we need
to provide the name email and the
password over there and then we'll be
setting all of these properties now
finally we can move on to the login
sorry to the signup page then we should
be having o where is the o uh there is
the O it should be the O do we can have
this sign up and now we want to get the
name as well so we can get the name over
there we can get the
const we can get the name that should be
equals to form data doget that should be
equals to the name and now we'll be
sending the name email and the password
and that's how it's going to work and
let's move on so there you can see now
we have the text of the login it should
be we can have the sign up over there
and now it should work perfectly fine
and now we have the button it should we
can have the sign up over there you can
see now we have similar UI we have the
sign up we have the name email and the
password so this is the sign up so
that's how we can do that so we can have
the name we can give the name of the
Mary like that we can have the Mary we
can have a we can have marry we can have
the Harry like that so we can give any
name like that so then we can have the
marry at the test.com we can give the
password 1 2 3 4 5 6 so let's just click
on the sign up and I think we can move
on again so it should be the messages
should be we can have the signing in it
should be um signing up like this
signing
up it should be having the signed up
once again we can have the sign signing
up that should be failed so now we
should be having a different ID that
should be the sign up here as well we'll
be having the sign up here as well we'll
be having the sign up so let's just try
it out so let's just click on the sign
up signing up and there you can see
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine and you can see now we have the
marry that's why we can see the MH over
there and now you can see it seems
working fine the sign up works now we
want to work on the homepage so let's
move on let's design the homepage of our
application as well so now let's work
with the homepage and for the homepage
now we'll be using some type of
Animation it should be some sort of
Animation that we can use inside the
typing so that should be a typing
animation so we can have the react we
have the react over there then we can
have the type animation over there we
can just use use this Library react type
animation and it's a completely animated
text Library over there like you can see
you can move on to homepage as well like
this you can move on to homepage and
this is their
homepage so then you can move on to
their site as well so here we have the
demo over there you can move out to the
demo you can see this is the demo over
there you can write this typing
animations as well and that's how they
will work so we need to use this type of
animations for that and that's how we
can use that so let's move on so let's
install this Library so we have the
react type animation of that so let's
install that over there we have the npm
install we can have the react type
animation over
there we need to install that and now
let's move on so after installing that
we'll be using the component over there
you can see this is the component like
this so we can use this component like
this we can just copy that over
there we can just copy here and then we
can move on we can paste it out so we
can create a shared component once again
we can have the typing animation like
that so I think let's create a new
component for the homepage I think
component we can have the tyer like this
typer and inside that we can have the
typing animation like that or we can
typing
anim do we have the TSX so we have this
component over there and let's just
write the ball plate code and after that
we can just copy this full component the
type animation let's just paste it out
here so we have the type animation let's
import that and there you can see now it
should be used and now after that now we
want to provide the text as well so you
can see after every 1 second first this
should be visible then this then this
then this so that's how it's going to
work so first that what we can do so we
can have the chat with your own AI so we
can have the chat with your we can have
the
your AI then we can move on then we can
write built with open AI then we can
move on so I have added the Emoji as
well then we can move on we can just
write something like your own customized
chat
GPT so that's how we want to work so you
can see now we can skip this one we can
skip this one and we can give the timing
of around we can have your uh 1,000
milliseconds that should be we can have
the 2,000 milliseconds and that should
be somewhere around we can give a same
like 1500 milliseconds for that so here
you can see we'll be repeating it for
the infinity times we have the style so
we can give a customized Styles as well
so we have the font size of 2m we can
give the font size of around 80 pixels
with that the 80 pixels of the font size
or I think the 80 would be so enough we
can give around 60 pixels for the font
size then we can move on so I think the
color we can give that should be we can
the white over there then we can have
the display like this we can have the
inline block over there and then we can
move on we can have the text Shadow as
well we can have the text shadow that
should be somewhere around 1 pixels we
can have the one pixels then we can have
the 20 pixels of the Shadow blow then we
can have hash 0 color for the shadow so
you can see now we have the typing
animation now we can successfully move
on to the homepage of our
application uh so we can move on to the
home. TSX over there we have the home.
TSX and now we can render all of that so
first we can just provide a box over
there from the material UI so we can
have the box over there and inside the
Box we can just provide the width that
should be somewhere around we can give
the 100% over there we can have the
height as well for the container that
should be 100% we can also give here I
think the flex for the display so we can
have the flex over there for this
display Flex then I think we can have
the flex over there and then I think we
can move on we can have the MX that
should be we can have the auto they like
that we have the MX that should be we
can have the auto now we can move on so
that's a parent container now we can
move on we can render the box here so we
can render another box it should contain
a couple of more styes so that could be
the container of all of these childrens
like the typing animation and after the
typing animation then we'll be showing
an image as well so it should also have
the display of the flex then we can move
on the width that should be I think we
can give the width or we can have the
100% over there we can have the flex
direction that should be inside the
column bases then we can move on align
items that should be I think inside the
center over there and then we can move
on we can the MX that should be again
that should be Auto and I think this
parent condition does not require the
flex and the MX Auto so that's should
only have a pent container and after
that inside the first thing that we want
to do so we can just render the typing
animation so we can have the typing anim
over there like this so we need to only
run that so let's see how it looks if we
move on to this application if we move
on to the
homepage so let's see how it looks now
so if we refresh the page I think it's
not over we can have the npm Run we can
have the dev so let's see what
happens so there we go now you can see
now we have the chat with your own AI
you can see it looks great over there
build with open Ai and there you can see
it is working perfectly fine over there
you can see now it looks great over
there we can provide some styles from
the Mt as well for the Mt that should be
somewhere around three like that so you
can see now it looks great so you can
see that's how we want to do that and
after this now we can move on and here
after this box let's define another box
over there so here we have another box
for us and inside this box now what do
you want to do so first we can provide
the SX we can have the width that's
should be we can have the 100% over
there again the WID should be the 100%
then we can move on we can have the
display like this so we can have the
display that should again be inside the
flex box over there and after that here
we need to render two images and two
images should be side by side on the
medium devices and on the small devices
it should be on the up and bottom so we
can have a flex Direction it should be
regarding the theme we'll be having the
responsive so we can have for the medium
it should be what we can do so the
medium the flex direction should be we
can have the row and for the extra small
we can have the flex direction that
should be equals to we can have I think
we can have the column like that so
that's how it's going to work and after
that let's move on so after that we can
move on we can have the gap between them
that should be we can have the five then
I think we can have the M that should be
equals to 10 that's enough for that I
think right that's enough and after that
here we need to render two images and
you will find all of these images inside
this section so first image that we want
to render The Source could be we can
have the robot. we have the PNG over
there so you need to create this image
over there sorry you have this image for
the robot let's move on so here we have
the robot image so we need this image
over there let's move on we have the
robot.png here as well we'll be having
the robot over there and after that
let's move on so here we can have the
style for that so we can have the style
for the images we can have a width that
should be somewhere around we can give
the 200 pixels for the width
a WID that should be we can have the 200
pixels and here what we can do so after
the width then we can have the margin
that should be we can have the auto over
there like this we have the margin of
the auto so that's how we want to work
after that we'll be having another image
of the open AI so we can move on so
again we can have the open a.png all
again should be the open a like that the
same should be there so now you can see
now we have two images over there and
that's how we want to work and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine and after that we need to provide
some class names for the opening image
because here we will be rotating this
image so let's move on so here we can
have the class name for that that should
be Mage Dash we can have the inverted
over there like that so that we can have
the white color and after that I have
added some CSS for that so let's move on
to the index. CSS here we have the
rotation CSS you can add the rotate over
there and inside the rotate you have the
animation and here we have the key
frames so from 0° to 359° to 360° so we
want to rotate and it is infinite sorry
it should be completed within 8 seconds
and it's a linear so you need to add
this CSS over there it's very simple
over there and now let's move on let's
just copy the rotate over there let's
just paste it out you can have the
rotate like this over there so let's see
how it looks so you can see now it looks
great over there now we have the
rotation images and everything seems to
be working perfectly fine and after this
now we want to create another box so
that would be the last box let's create
another box so what you want to do so
you can also create a new one so we can
have the box over there like that and
inside this now what do we want to do so
we can have the SX prop for that and it
should include so the SX prop should
include some props like we can have the
display again that should be we can have
the flex for this so display should have
the flex so that it should take full
available space then we can have the
width that should be we can have the
100% over there for the width then we
can move on and I think after that we
can move on and after the width then we
can have the margin from the X that
should be we can have the auto over
there like that so that's how we want to
work after that we want to have the
image as well so we can have the image
this time it should be we can have the
chat do we can have the PNG I think we
have the chat. PNG right so we'll be
using the our own image for that so
we'll be having the chat. PNG we'll be
having the chat bot like that so we have
the chat bot and then what we want to do
so here we can provide a customized
style as well so we can have the style
we can have again the display that
should be inside the flex we can have
the margin that should be we can have
the auto over there like that we have
the margin of the auto then we can move
on so after that we can have the width
that should be only 60% of the available
space the width should be 60% we have
the bottle radius that should be
somewhere around 20 would be enough 20
pixels would be enough then we can have
the box Shadow as well so we need the
shadow for this image so the Box shadow
that we want to Define could be we can
move on and it should have hash 64
F3 D5 so we have this chat over there it
is 64 F3 D5 then we can move on we can
have the margin from the top as well
that should be somewhere around 20 you
can see now we have this image over
there oh sorry we haven't defined the XY
positions for this box Shadow as well we
need to define the positions so for the
horizontal it should be somewhere around
we can have the 5 pixels and for I think
the vertical again it should be the
minus 5 pixels for that and we want to
define the blur that should be 105
pixels for that that's enough so there
you can see now we have the image over
there and everything seems to be working
fine over there you can see now it looks
great over there now we have this image
and everything seems to be working fine
over there if we move on to the 100% you
can say it looks great over there we can
have the margin from the bottom as well
so we can have the margin that should be
from we can have the bottom over there
that should be somewhere around 20 once
again and that's how we want to work and
everything seems to be working fine over
there you can see now we have the chat
with with your own AI we have built with
open Ai and if you open that inside the
mobile devices you can say it looks
great first we have the screens over
there first we have the data then first
we have these images and then we have
the image as well and that's how we want
to work and I think we need to move on
we need to provide for the smm as well
so we can have the smm over there small
devices that should be again we can have
the column or we can have the column
over there so that's how we want to work
so now it should look great over there
now you can see now it looks fine but I
think the image should be increased in
the mobile devices so how we can do that
so we can give customized style for the
mobile and for this and for the desktop
so let's move on so we can use mui for
that I think we need to First import
some things we need to import the Ed
media quiry from the M material and then
we need to use the theme as well so we
can have the use theme over there like
that from the a material so what we can
do we can create a media query so we can
have the cons we can have the
theme and that should be equals to so we
can have the use theme over there like
that and after that we need to create a
variable we can have the cons is U we
can have the
below medium like this is below MD that
should be equals to we can have the use
media quiry and inside that we'll be
having a Boolean as the return then we
can move on we can have the theme dot we
can have the break points DOT we can
have the down that should be from the MD
so with the help of this now we can get
if that's a mobile device or not with is
below MD so if the screen size is below
MD or not so we can get these from
this so you can see now it looks great
over there now it looks perfectly great
over there and everything seems to be
working perfectly fine over there and
now the final thing that we want to do
is now we can move on we can move on to
the app component so final thing that we
can do is now we can create the footer
as well within this application so let's
move on so here now what do you want to
do so we can move on so inside the
components let's create a new folder
that could be for the photo so inser the
photo let's create a new file that could
be be of the photo do we have the TSX
over there and now we can add some boil
update code for that so footer can have
the simple Styles over there you can see
here we have the simple Styles we have
the div and inside the div we have the
style over there we have the width of
100% padding of 20 minimum height of 20
V height Max height of 30bh margin top
of 50 and then you can see there are a
couple of styles for the paragraph as
well and after that now we want to
provide the link as well for the Indian
coders so let's move on so what we can
do so here we have the buildt With Love
by Indian coders so so we can just
provide this span like this so we can
have this pan and inside this span we
can just use the link directly from I
think react Dom so we can have the link
over there like this we have the react
router Dom over there we can just copy
the inter coders we can paste it out and
inside the link we can proide the two as
well the two should be equals to
https we can have the
youtube.com/ we can have the Indian
coders so we can have this channel name
for us so now we have the Indian coders
for that and that's how it works over
there now we have this link over there
and after that now what do you want to
do after that now we can provide the
class name for the link as well so I
think we have the nav link over there
like that so we have the nav link for
the class name let's move on to this CSS
as well so here we have the index. CSS
so I think yes we have the nav link over
there like this so we can provide the
nav link for the class names so let's
see how it looks over there so now we
have this like this so let's move on
let's just render the footer after this
now we have the buildt With Love by
encoders so I think we are just having
some like blue color over there so we
can have the style over there we can
have the color that should be we can
have the white over there like that and
now we have built with love B and coders
and we can remove this over there and we
can also remove the empty space over
there which has created so you can see
it's looking perfectly great over there
now we have the built with love by
Indian coders and it looks great over
there now what we can do so if we can
click on the Indian coders now we should
be moved on to the YouTube channel of my
YouTube channel you can see Indian
coders and you can also please subscribe
to the YouTube channel as well I create
a lot of videos on the monack fullstack
development FB development react native
so you can please subscribe to the
channel as well and now let's move back
so you can see now it looks great over
there on the mobile devices as well you
can see now it looks great and
everything seems to be working perfectly
fine over there so now let's move on so
there you can see if we now just move on
to log out if we can just click on the
log out over there now we can just move
on we can click on the login we can move
on with the login over there so we can
login as well and there you can see now
we have the loaded chats as well if
there would be chats then we would be
loading all of the chats of the user
then we can again create a new chat like
that and I think there's some margin
between them right so you can see we are
having some extra space between them and
now to fix this layout so what do we
need to do so we can move on to the chat
page so here we have the chat so here
you can see here we have the padding of
20 pixels and we have the width of 100%
so so either we can remove the padding
from this so let's see how it looks so
now you can see now we do not have any
extra spaces over there and then we can
increase the padding within the input so
let's move on so let's change it to 30
pixels you can see now it looks great
over there and everything seems to be
working fine and we can provide the
margin for this as well the MX that
should be we can have the one and now it
should work perfectly fine over there
like this so we can have the MX that
should be we can have the one over there
you can see now it's working great over
there and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine over there
and there you can see now we can again
move on so I think we can remove this I
think we can remove this photo inside
the chat page so what we can do so
instead of rendering the footer inside
the main layout so we can remove the
footer we can render the footer only
inside the homepage like this so only
inside the homepage now we can render
the footer as well so we can just render
here the footer and that's how it works
over there now let's move on so if you
move on to the homepage so now we should
be seeing the footer over there and we
can just increase some margin from the
top that should be somewhere around 60
like that so now we have some margin and
there you can see now it looks great so
now you can see now it looks great over
there and everything seems to be working
perfectly fine and after that I think we
can move on to the footer so font says
30 pixels text Aline Center okay so I
think we can just keep it default and we
can increase the padding to the 20
pixels directly inside the paragraph T
and that's how we want to work now you
can see now it looks great over there
now if you move on to go to chat you can
see now we do not have the extra spacing
left over there and if you enter any
chat over there like hi like this so
let's click on the send so now you can
see now we have the chats over there and
there you can see now it looks great
over there hello how can I help you
today and you can see I have made
another adjustment over there inside the
chat item so I added the bottle radius
that should be two and my y that should
be equals to the one um and here as well
we have the Bott radius of two we have
the gap of two and that's how we want to
do that you can see now it looks great
now we have a structured layout for that
and here you can see with the help of
this now you can see our application
looks completed over there now our
application feels completed you can see
it was a great application we integrated
with the open AI we created the back end
we created the front end we created the
perfect design for that you can see
everything looks great over there and
everything is working perfectly fine
like this so congratulations on
completing this application so I hope
now you have learned a lot from this
course you can see we created the back
end we integrated the authentication
systems here the authorization system
we integrated the open a here and here
you can see now we have integrated the
material UI for the design we created a
perfect design for us you can see
everything seems to be working fine over
there so now let's move on and let's
just close this application so now let's
mark is completed and let's move on to
the summary part and let's discuss that
what we have learned throughout this
course and now let's see that what we
have done throughout this course so we
have learned the mon stack so now you
know and now you have a great knowledge
about about the mon stack that how the
mon stack Works how the backend front
end integration Works how we create the
back end how we create the front end
with the react and then first we created
the very basic Express node rest API so
we created the rest API we showed you
the tutorial that how to get started
with the mon stack then we created the
fully secured authentication with our
back end so it is completely secured
with the HTTP only cookies JWT tokens
authentication authorization adding
middle wees for the security and there
was so many things and we have the data
w checks as well and then we created an
openi project similar to the chat GPD
clone so it was a huge project we
created the chat GPD clone with the
monack so then we created the modern
design with the material UI and react so
muui is a react UI component Library we
integrated that with the react we
created the animations we created some
components we created the chat type
layout we created a lot of designs with
the react and the material UI and then
we created this seamless integration
with the Monch with the back end and the
front end and we created the integration
with the credentials with the xos and so
many things so with all of that let's
close this project so it was very nice
working with you so now let's move on so
now in the end I want one favor from you
so please like the video because we
spend a lot of time building these type
of tutorials for you so we spend all of
our weekends and all of the things so we
don't go outside we just create some
projects like that so if this video
deserves one like And subscribe then
please do that because it gives me some
sort of like relaxation that if I'm
creating something then I'm receiving
something from you guys as well so
that's it from my side so I hope you
will be successful in the future you can
create the mon stag you can apply for
the job opportunities you can share this
project into your resume as well so
let's move on and let's just wrap
everything with this
project